Vor einer Woche hörte mein MacBook Air auf, sich in WLANs einzuwählen.
Von heute, die Dialing 999 wird nicht die Urlaubsdienste bekommen.
Ich hab das Problem mittlerweile lokalisiert. Dadurch, dass ich es lokalisiert habe, hab ich es auch sofort gelöst. Der Auslöser war eine von mir installierte Software.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall schon mal gut, dass du dir jetzt professionelle Hilfe gesucht hast.
So, plimm, plimm, plimm, plimm, plimm, plimm. Änderungen in der letzten Minute sind immer die Besten. Stimmt's? Ich schau, wie spät es ist. Ich geh gleich. Ja, ein beherztes Hallo, willkommen zur Freak Show. Hier 126. Ausgabe. Mit einem hoch motivierten Hucke. Und wieder aus der Versenkung zurückgekehrt, Clemens.
Mahlzeit.
Buntstift vergessen.
Und in fortgesetzter Versenkung, Dennis.
Ja.
Wir sind schon auf Sendung.
Kannst du jetzt los, Vader, an die Maschine?
Ich hab dich aufgepasst.
Irgendwas bezahlen.
Huckel arbeitet so viel.
Einer der schönsten IT-Crowd-Follower übrigens. Jeden zu empfehlen, der sie noch nicht gesehen hat.
Ich guck keine IT-Crowd.
Was? Nein, guck den. Big Bang Theory ist noch was anderes.
Du hast IT-Crowd nicht gesehen. Das ist nicht euer Ernst.
Hatten wir aber schon mal. Ich finde das nicht gut.
Ich guck auch nicht. Wer irgendwo im Hintergrund geklatscht hat, grundsätzlich geht überhaupt gar nicht. Geht nicht.
Clicking and double clicking.
Und äh.
Ist mir egal. Ist lustig.
Ich kann das nicht ertragen, weil sich da über eine Spezies Mensch lustig gemacht wird. Äh, die, also das.
Nein, sie sind ja die Helden.
Die sind ja die Helden.
Die sind es ja aber auch wieder nicht.
Doch. Auf ihre Art.
Die sind aber so überspitzt dargestellt.
Ja, das ist Englisch, hallo?
Und mit der Emergency Number, das ist wirklich so in Großbritannien.
Das heißt, du kannst ja gar nicht drüber lachen, als ich das vor fünf Jahren mal auf dem Kongress als Witz benutzt habe.
Was, mit Clicking und Double Clicking?
Ich hab da mal so Snippets hier und da gesehen, so YouTube, irgendwas wird ja immer rumgeschickt, aber das hat mich nie.
Englisch Amor ist nicht für jeden.
Das mach ich wirklich. Englisch Amor ist nicht für jeden, aber für mich ist Englisch, also man kann ja über England eine Menge schlechte Sachen erzählen und ich finde, man sollte das auch tun. Aber.
Du greifst jetzt in deinen Genpool.
Ich darf das ja sagen.
Mit dem Pass ja.
Mit dem Pass darf ich das sagen. Noch.
Aber nur hier, nicht auf der Insel zu Hause.
Was Humor betrifft, macht denen einfach keiner was vor. Also ich finde das einfach mal.
Ja, aber es heißt ja nicht, dass alles, was da herkommt, auch allen gefällt. Also es gibt ja bestimmt auch, also ich mag Cameron und die Paisten durchaus, ja.
Also hätte es L'Oréal nicht gegeben, hätte Englands Humor Deutschland vollständig vernichtet. Das, was sie in dem zweiten Weltkrieg nicht gelungen wäre, ja. Wobei es ist ja schon gelungen eigentlich, wenn man es genau nimmt. Naja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall IT-Crowd ist okay. Also es ist wirklich sehr okay und ich finde es echt komisch. Vor allem die Folge mit dem Internet.
Oder wo er die Feuerwehr ruft per Mail. Und die kommen am Ende wirklich, das ist der Gag. Schickt eine E-Mail an die Feuerwehr, weil er sich die scheiß Nummer nicht merken kann.
Das ist so klasse.
Und der Subjekt überlegt das als Subjekt. Fire! Nein, nein, das ist zu formal.
Die ersten shocking revelations.
Wir haben ja ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Haben wir überhaupt gar nicht in unseren Notizen drin, oder?
Glaubst du Geschenke?
Ja, wo sind die? Bitte?
Steht hier irgendwas von Fritz Boxenhöhen?
Doch, da steht was. AVM hat auch mal einen Bug. Ah, ein Fragezeichen?
Das ist ja schön.
Schön versteckt in dem Haufen da von Themen.
Genau, ja Clemens war ja mal einmal nicht da. Jetzt müssen wir ja wieder ordentlich nachholen. Wollen wir damit mal anfangen? Weil ich finde, das ist irgendwie gerade hochaktuell. Was?
Ich hab keine Fritz Boxen.
Erstens das und zweitens war das letzte Wochenende aktuell. Das ist jetzt schon wieder so.
Wer hat denn eine Fritz Box? Hast du eine Fritz Box?
Ja, mehrere.
Du sprichst gerade da, du badest gerade deine Hände da. Du sprichst gerade über eine.
Millionen Menschen lauschen dir.
Ah hier, genau, da gibt es so einen Google-Query. Habt ihr das auch gesehen? Wenn man bei Google siteduppelpunktsuperkabel.de sucht, dann findet man auf Google gleich so eine Liste von Office Druckern, Fritz Boxen und so weiter und so fort. Kannst ja mal eintippen. sitesuperkabel.de Das ist von Kabel Deutschland sozusagen die Domain, die sie an ihre Kunden rausgeben, das Reverse Lookup. Das heißt, wenn du siteduppelpunktsuperkabel.de eintippst, dann findest du Fritz Boxen, Office Drucker, das ganze Programm bei Google.
Irgendwie billig, was man sonst nicht findet, oder was?
Fritz Boxen melden sich aber normalerweise da nicht an.
Die Endgeräte.
Ja und? Ich meine, die finde ich doch auch ohne...
Findest du da einfach so mal eben eine Fritz Boxen? Also da kriegst du die öffnen serviert.
Z-Scan.
Ja genau, hier, da geht's runter auf Fritz Boxen. vielleicht ist deine auch dabei.
Ach so, die Geräte selbst.
Ich dachte jetzt so Shops und die Herdner.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, die Geräte, die Geräte. Ja, also vielleicht ist ja deine IP auch dabei und...
Ist ja nicht bei Kabel Deutschland.
Ach so, stimmt, ja. Vielleicht geht das hier auf die andere.
Jede Fritzbox auf Kabel Deutschland, oder was?
Na so, vielleicht nicht, weiß nicht, ob jeder, aber...
Nein, die Art und Weise, was da passiert ist, gibt halt IP-Adressen, die vergeben. Die haben ein Reverse-Mapping für 47110815dünnip.superkabel.de. Wenn so was irgendwo mal auftaucht, dann kommt der Google-Crawler und geht da vorbei. Der macht ein Request auf diese Seite und sieht natürlich erstmal die fritzbox-ditlogin-logo. Weil die Fritzbox, wenn du hingehst von draußen, sagt dir Hallo, ich bin ja eine Fritzbox, gib mir deine Daten ein. Das sieht der Google-Crawler und malt dir das dahin. Deswegen ist es immer Login, immer Login Log, immer dasselbe Ding. Oder melden sich mit ihren Benutzernamen an. Das ist das, was der Google-Crawler einfach abgreift von den Seiten. Was die Fritzbox eigentlich mal bräuchte, wäre ein Robots.text in ihrem App-Stash. Da haben sie, glaube ich, einfach noch nicht dran gedacht. Das ist der ganze Grund, warum du die dort findest. Weil die Suchmaschinen-Crawler sammeln ja den ganzen IP-Adressbereich ab, alles, was ihnen irgendwie unter die Füße kommt und machen da erstmal eine HTTP-Requestin. Wenn der nicht geht, machen sie eine HTTPS-Request dahin und finden, ah, okay, hier ist eine Login-Seite.
Tja, und jetzt ist angeblich auch schon gleich der Stream abgestürzt, wo wir irgendwie über die Fritzbox reden. Die Chatter sind schon wieder draußen. Das Ableton zeichnet aber noch auf.
Internet geht noch.
Ich weiß von nichts. Das müssen irgendwelche Sub-Streaming-Büchsen sein, die von meinem Zugriff sind. Ja, dann müsste ich einen anderen Streaming-Server aussuchen aus diesem Pool. Sorry, tut mir leid, aber hier läuft alles. Ja, nichtsdestotrotz vielleicht mal eine kleine Chronik, weil vielleicht hat das auch nicht unbedingt jeder so mitbekommen. Also, das war das letzte Donnerstag, Freitag. Irgendwann kamen Spiegel mit einer Meldung oder sonst irgendwie. Heise waren vielleicht auch die ersten. Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Das gab es schon ein paar Tage vorher.
Auf jeden Fall gab es Berichte, dass es wohl Angreifern gelungen sei, in Fritz-Boxen reinzukommen, von außen dort dann SIP-Accounts geklickt haben und diese auch genutzt haben zum Telefonieren. Keine Ahnung, wem sie diese Telefonenverbindungen zur Verfügung gestellt haben und ob das mit irgendwelchen 190er Scams zu tun hat, weiß ich nicht.
Also was du machen kannst, du kannst in der Fritz-Box interne Telefone geben, weil du die Fritz-Box auch zum Telefonieren benutzt, weil du einen ISTN-Anschluss oder einen analogen Anschluss dran hast oder auch einen der tollen neuen IP-Anschlüsse, die ja manche Provider auch da dran haben. Dann kannst du interne Durchwahlen, hat man vorher dazu gesagt, definieren, interne Telefoniegeräte. So ein interner Telefoniegerät kann auch ein IP-Telefon sein. Das kann also entweder ein analoges oder ein ISTN oder ein Deck-Telefon oder ein IP-Telefon sein. So und wenn du so ein IP-Telefon hast, kann man bei einer aktuellen Fritz-Box auch sagen, ich möchte gerne, dass dieses IP-Telefon sich auch von außen anwählen kann an die Fritz-Box. Wenn du das so konfigurierst, darfst du das. Und wenn jetzt ein böser Mensch sich deiner Fritz-Box oder Kontrolle über deine Fritz-Box bemächtigt, dann richtet er sich ein IP-Telefon ein und sagt, ja, da möchte ich auch über das Internet dran an dieses IP-Telefon oder an diesen Zugang. Und dann geht er hin, macht von draußen Zip-Calls übers Internet auf deine Fritz-Box, die immer schön per ISDN nach, keine Ahnung, Malediven wählt oder 0900, oder was halt so Spaß macht. So geht das. Vom Prinzip Dialer reloaded. Weißt du, was es so früher gab, dass du irgendwelche Malware auf deinen Rechner draufgeladen hast, die dann angefangen haben, mit deinem Modem rumzuwählen und da schön ausländische Nummern oder 090er-Nummern anzurufen, machen wir jetzt so, indem wir jetzt dein Telefonie-Gateway von außen adressieren. Dieser Teil ist erstmal alles okay, ist auch völlig okay, dass das alles geht. Der Problem ist nur, dass es normalerweise nicht möglich sein sollte, dass jemand anders sich einfach sozusagen da einloggt auf deiner Fritzbox und sagt, ich konfiguriere hier mal so ein IP-Telefon. Das ist der Teil, der so ein bisschen blöd ist.
Ja, da könnte man sich sowieso über bestimmte Grundeinstellungen Gedanken machen. Das mit dem Robot-CXT finde ich zum Beispiel schon mal einen ganz guten Hinweis und auch gar nicht darüber nachgedacht. Könnte auch darüber nachdenken, ob irgendwie solche externen Dienste überhaupt von extern eingerichtet werden können sollten, bevor man nicht irgendwie einen Fleck gesetzt hat, dass man das auch von außen tun möchte.
Es gibt ja inzwischen Benutzer mit unterschiedlichen Berechtigungen. Du kannst jetzt für einen User sagen, ob der Remote Access haben will oder nicht.
Ja, die Frage ist nur, ob bei Default dieser Remote Access auch tief zu falsch halten kann.
Du musst es explizit anmachen. Du musst diese Fernwartungs-Feature, wie das heißt, erst mal explizit anmachen.
Ja, dass es überhaupt erst mal da ist.
Und dann möchtest du es natürlich auch für Fernwartung benutzen. Dafür benutze ich das.
Ja gut, aber vielleicht kannst du ja... Das ist ja nur so eine Idee, dass man eine bestimmte Kategorie von Settings da erst mal ausschließt, bevor man die nicht auch noch mal explizit freigibt.
Ja, aber nochmal, wenn der Besitzer einer FritzBox sich die Fernwartung anmacht, dann möchte er nicht in seinen Urlaub fahren in freudiger Erwartung, seine Rufumleitung ändern zu können, dass ihm seine FritzBox sagt, ey, Spätsch, da hättest du aber einen Fleck für setzen müssen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so, glaube ich. Oder sind dir denn auch nicht so erfreut drüber?
Und der sagt, die FritzBox, ey, Spätsch, du kannst nicht telefonieren, weil da telefoniert schon wer anders.
Richtig. Das sagt es allerdings nicht mehr, wenn du jetzt......
das Update einspielst.
Das Update einspielst, das löst jetzt nicht, oder verhindert jetzt nicht das Telefonieren, sondern verhindert, dass sich da Leute einhacken auf den Admin-Level da deiner Kiste.
Ich starte mal den Streamer neu, weil er irgendwie bei Xenium überhaupt nicht mehr geliefert wird. Das geht auch echt nicht.
Aber das Internet ruckelt schon so ein bisschen. Also hier in meinem Chat, da scrollt das immer mal so Stückchenweise, so gleich einen halben Kilometer Messages nach und so. Irgendwie so ganz rund läuft das hier Nisch, würde ich mal behaupten.
Ich bin hier connected die ganze Zeit und keine Sorgen.
Er connectet schon, aber bei mir...
Nee, da läuft auch was. Also...
Ja, also ich habe hier auch irgendwie geschmeidige...
Also 20 Mbit Downstream von deinem BitTorrent. Naja, egal, dann lass uns doch einfach weiter machen. Wir werden uns jetzt hier...
Mehr machen kann ich leider nicht hier, als den Stream einschalten und er sagt mir, es gibt hier kein Problem.
Also ich habe auf dem V4 Packet Loss hier.
Ich hab halt da noch nicht mein eigenes Streaming-Network, was ich mal so da...
Ja, aber das ist ein Ping-Loss, den du da hast. Den hast du aus anderen Gründen, wenn diese Zahl dahinten, dein Ziel, wenn die hochgeht, dann hast du... Das sind einfach nur Router, wo Millionen von Leuten die ganze Zeit Trace-Routes durchmachen und der Router sagt, ich hab wohl noch was anderes zu tun als Trace-Routes zuwarten. Das ist wirklich so. Die haben halt ein Limit da drauf, wie viel sie von diesen Dingen, von diesen ICMP-Nachrichten rausschicken und so.
Du weißt also, dass es nicht ein Paket pro Dings ist, sondern pro Router-Hop muss da immer ein Paket sein, ja? Also das ist da...
Na gut, na gut, alles normal. Wir machen einfach weiter.
Genau, wir machen weiter. So, wie ist es dann weitergegangen? Warum ich das überhaupt alles für so interessant und erwähnenswert finde? Ja, nicht nur weil ich eine habe, sondern weil ich irgendwie finde, dass das mal ein echt gutes Beispiel war, wie man auf sowas reagiert. Also bei AVM, du magst da vielleicht noch mehr Einblick haben, aber es machte auf mich so den Eindruck, als ob sie da erstmal alle aus dem Urlaub geholt haben und irgendwie Wochenendschicht eingelegt haben. Und sie haben es jetzt, erstens dann haben sie einen, zwei Tage später haben sie irgendwie, nachdem sie mal geschaut haben, haben sie dann irgendwie auch klare Statement gemacht, so ja, Problem liegt vor, wir sind dran. Genau, wir mussten das erstmal finden. Ich weiß nicht, hast du da irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, was es jetzt eigentlich genau war?
Also ich weiß, dass die Wochenenden, in denen sie gearbeitet haben, weil ich hatte Mail-Verkehr mit denen letztes Wochenende und normalerweise kriegt die Antworten immer erst am Montag und die kamen dann schon am Sonntag und am Sonntag. Also die waren wohl irgendwie bis zum Dienst. Aber sonst kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, was die da gemacht haben, aber sie haben sich auf jeden Fall zügig rangehalten. Was natürlich erstmal das Problem ist und war, was jeder hat, der einen Bug fixen muss, der muss erst mal reproduzieren. Wenn irgendwelche User bei dir anrufen, sagen, hier ist was bei mir komisch, dann musst du erst mal jemanden finden, der schlau genug ist, dass du dir mal eine Frage stellen kannst, dass du dir mal sagen kannst, hier, mach mal einen Trace oder so, um das mal nachzuvollziehen. Das hat dann schon ein, zwei Tage gedauert, aber dann glaube ich, haben sie das relativ zügig auch gefunden, was da das Problem ist. Und eben auch gefixt. Also ich fand auch gut, dass sie da offen damit umgegangen sind. Was ich nicht so cool fand, war, das war dann eher so cover my ass, dass sie als erste Reaktion nachdem diese Thema überhaupt anstand gesagt haben, machtet mal alles aus. So und nach dem Motto, naja, wenn sie jetzt, macht mal die ganze Fernwartung aus und macht, macht, egal, macht alles aus, machtet IP-Telefonie, machtet alles aus, haben sie so geschrieben vom Prinzip. Und dann fand ich so ein bisschen blöd, weil ich hab mir die Fritzbox auch mit diesen Features, weil ich die haben will. Wenn ich sie ausmachen würde, kann ich mir doch gleich einen anderen Router kaufen.
Ja, aber um größeren Schaden zu verhindern?
Ja, ist ja klar, das war cover my ass.
Das fand ich eigentlich auch völlig in Ordnung. Das ist ja dann immer noch deine eigene Abwägung, ob du das dann tust oder nicht. Du kannst ja dann immer noch nein sagen, aber dass sie auf jeden Fall schon mal die Empfehlung rausgeben, das finde ich eigentlich auch völlig in Ordnung. Und vor allem, ich finde in Ordnung, oder was ich dann beeindruckend fand, ist, dass sie dann innerhalb von wenigen Tagen nicht nur einen Fix rausgehauen haben, für irgendwie ein oder zwei Geräte, sondern ich glaube, sie haben so, was war das, 20, 30 verschiedene Devices, Updates rausgehauen. Also im Prinzip alle Geräte, weil offensichtlich war das halt jetzt ein Bug, der ja, einfach mal alle Geräte betrifft, einfach so ein Stück Kot, der einfach überall drauf ist. da fiel mir irgendwie ein, dass es auch durchaus eine Menge Unternehmen gibt da draußen, die nicht unbedingt in der Lage sind für ein Gerät, was seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr im Verkauf ist, auch wirklich nochmal einen kompletten Bild durchzuziehen. Also da mal eine Firmware zu haben. Das ist das eine. Aber auch mal eben übers Wochenende für 30 Tag mit einer generellen Änderung, dafür eine Firmware-Update fähig, auch wirklich online zu stellen, sodass das eben auch klappt, vorausgesetzt. Das klappt jetzt auch alles, das kann ich natürlich im Einzelnen nicht bewerten. Bei mir hat's geklappt, bei meinen Geräten. Aber ich hab auch, sagen wir mal, eher die etwas populäreren rechts unten Modelle von AVM. Und das, ja, ich weiß nicht, da kann sich irgendwie andere Firmen durchaus mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden. So, insbesondere diese ganzen billig Plastoraute da draußen. Ja, die einfach gar keine Updates kriegen, generell nie. So, und sind halt verkauft. Die auch riesige Lücken haben, hier diese UPNP-Port nach außen, Geschichte hatten wir ja hier auch schon vorletztes Mal, glaube ich, ausführlich diskutiert, als es um den Kongress ging und so weiter. Ja, und das ist halt dann nicht so geil. Und von daher muss ich sagen, diese Routerzwang-Sache, die uns unsere tolle Bundesregierung aufdrücken möchte, weil sie das von ihren ISPs erzählt bekommen, von ihren Großen. Wo ich ja durchaus verstehen kann, dass wenn man jetzt so ein großer Netzwerkprovider ist, dass man die Möglichkeit haben will, von außen Updates durchzudrücken. Aber wenn das halt wirklich bis auf so ein User-Level geht, dann ist es schwierig, weil Kabel Deutschland zum Beispiel, die ja auch viele Fritz-Boxen am Start haben, die jetzt, glaube ich, heute angefangen haben, Updates dafür anzubieten. Da haben wir halt so diese Situation wie bei Android mit Software-Updates, dass die halt quasi erstmal von der Telco abgenommen werden müssen und dann eben auch über die rausgeschoben werden. Und ich weiß gar nicht, machen die automatische Updates? Nee. Dann muss der User immer noch selber mal Admin-Interfaces aufmachen.
Gibt doch welche, die bratzeln dir gnadenlos über. Auch mit Fritz-Boxen? Du kannst es zulassen. Es gibt irgendwo eine obskure Einstellung ganz in den Tiefen dieser Kiste, wo du sagen kannst, ja mein Provider darf das machen. Das müsste ich jetzt nochmal nachgucken. Es gibt ja diese TR69-Standard, wo sie auch ihre Fernprovisionierung machen von den Dingern. Diese Fernkonfiguration, darüber kannst du denen auch sozusagen das Antriggern, das Firmware-Update.
Na gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie es da aussieht. Wie gesagt, es mag Argumente geben, bis zu einem bestimmten Grad von außen da Equipment zu aktualisieren, aber jetzt nicht unbedingt komplett bis auf den User-Level. Zumindest nicht das selbe Gerät, was eben auch noch deine Anruf-Mailbox macht und so weiter. Das halte ich eben nicht für so eine gute Idee und insofern bin ich sehr froh, ehrlich gesagt, dass ich jetzt hier so ein Gerät habe, wo so schnell reagiert wird. Also, weil es halt geil war. Bei Apple hätte es wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht so lange gedauert, aber so bei Linksys oder bei Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Interpreises...
Was ich auch gut finde, ist, dass sie eben nicht nur Bugs fixen, sondern dass sie eben auch noch Features nachrüsten, was ich übrigens auch sehr nett finde. Es gibt ja auch sehr viele Firmen, muss man ja sagen, auch die Plastik-Router-Firmen, die jetzt echt fiese Bugs fixen, aber die dann auch genauenlos hingehen und sagen für unsere 30-Euro-Kiste, wenn du jetzt die supergeile Mega-Feature haben willst, dann kaufst du bitte noch mal so eine Kiste, diesmal für 35 Euro oder so, was die sehr einfach sagen. Wir machen da keine neuen Features drauf. Vielleicht, weil die dann auch so ausgeknaut sind.
Das ist ja in Ordnung, wenn es die Hardware nicht mehr kann, so ein Feature nicht nachzureichen.
Ja, aber du weißt genau, bei Apple ist das selbe Spiel. Apple behauptet auch mal, ja, leider, ihr könnt jetzt Facetime nicht auf, keine Ahnung, iPhone-Quitsch machen und dann die Jailbreaker zeigen dir immer sofort, dass das sehr wohl gehen würde, wenn man nur wollte. Da ist auch Produktpolitik mit dabei.
Das sehe ich, ehrlich gesagt, nicht ganz so.
Ja, also bei Apple gibt es schon ganz oft so Features, wo du denkst, so, Alter, jetzt kommt irgendwie den Geo-Feature oder, ach, weiß nicht, da waren schon in der ganzen Geschichte, klar, da waren Tausende...
Moment, es gab eine Menge Features, von denen die Leute meinten, dass das kein Problem sei. Meinten, aber überhaupt nichts darüber sagen konnten, wie das letzten Endes mit Memory-Verbrauch etc.,
Okay, ich hab jetzt keine Zeit, das irgendwie nachzurecherchieren, aber gefühlt waren da mindestens fünf oder sechs solche Features bei irgendwelchen iPhone-Updates, wo du dachtest, komm, Alter, das ist jetzt irgendwie echt keine Rocket Science, jetzt da dieses Feature auf einem älteren Gerät zu machen.
Ja, es gab vielleicht mal ein paar Features, wo man hätte drüber diskutieren können, aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass du eben auch noch jahrelang später Features bekommen hast, mit dem neuen OS, die alle weitgehend auf den alten Geräten verfügbar waren. Also das ist eigentlich bei Apple eher die Regel, als dass man immer drum betteln muss. Da betteln. Ich sage es nur, das ist meine Wahrnehmung. Wie auch immer, ich denke, dass sich Firmen grundsätzlich damit einen echten Gefallen tun. AVM tut sich meiner Meinung nach damit echten Gefallen. Weil das ist natürlich, wenn man sich sozusagen dieses Produkt anschaut und sagt, alles, was ihr mir einfach so liefern könnt, was die Hardware eh kann, das liefert ihr auch. Und ihr kümmert euch auch um Sicherheitsupdates. In dem Moment, wo ich wirklich gezwungen bin, mir neue Hardware zu kaufen, ist die Entscheidung ja irgendwie ganz klar.
Ich meine, sie machen ja sogar so etwas, die 7390, das VDSL-Modell, das wir noch am meisten verkauft haben, ist ja schon seit ein paar Jahren draußen. Und trotzdem richten sie jetzt nochmal Vectoring nach, wo die zum Beispiel auch okay finden. Da musst du noch richtig an der Firmware vom DSP rumfummeln und so weiter und so fort.
Das werden sie tun oder haben sie schon getan?
Der aktuelle Code kann Vectoring. Der 6er. Das finde ich wirklich dann okay. Das bereitet dann zwar immer wieder ein Problem, weil wenn du ein paar Millionen Installed Base draußen hast und dann machst du mal einen Firmware-Update, der derartig gravierend ist, gibt es dann natürlich wieder irgendwelche komischen Kombinationen. Bei Regen und Rückenwind wurde es bei 5 Usern mal nicht geht und es wurde die Aufregung groß. Warum habt ihr das jetzt angefasst? Aber naja, okay, das passiert halt. Aber wie gesagt, die Frage ist immer, wie man damit umgeht. Genauso wie mit dem Bug. Mich haben ja auch Leute jetzt angefurzt, weil ich ja auch häufiger mal The Box, which must not be named, in der Freak Show hier mal erwähne. Und was ich jetzt sage, ich sage, ja, dann haben sie halt eben auch mal einen Bug. Wichtig ist, wie sie damit umgehen und dazu halt das offen machen. Also offen zugeben, dass da was ist. Den Leuten sagen, macht was dagegen. Und hier habt ihr einen Patch. Wer denn jetzt nicht einspielt, sollte da nicht rummaulen.
Natürlich können wir das hier nehmen. Wenn wir was geil finden, wenn wir was geil, wenn wir was scheiße finden, wenn wir was scheiße.
Ich sage ja auch immer, ich mache hier keine Werbung. Wir berichten halt über das, was wir benutzen. Und wenn ich meine Fritz!Box benutze, benutze ich. Ansonsten gibt es da nicht so viel, ich habe keine interne Watze gemacht. Ich habe selber mal diese Login-Mechanik implementiert, weil ich mir mal Skripte geschrieben habe, die von den ganzen Fritz!Boxen, die ich betreue, was meine ganze Verwandtschaft und Freundschaft drumherum ist, die config zieht.
Machst du eigentlich hier wieder Netzwerk, Monitoring?
Ja, ich gucke gerade.
Mittlerweile haben wir nämlich richtige Abbrüche.
Ja, ich sehe es, aber momentan haben wir, V4 sind wir grün, V6 sind wir auch grün.
Es kommt immer so ein Burst, so ein Sekunden-Burst.
Das liegt aber nicht bei uns, das liegt außerhalb. Ja, was ich sehen kann, liegt außerhalb.
Ich habe jetzt ja auch MTRs offen auf V4 und V6, und da ist zwischendurch auch mal ordentlich Loch-Fraß.
Du gehst aber mal dazu.
spiegel.de, heise.de, mal V4, mal V6.
Ich bleibe hier in Berlin, gehe auf meine gehorsten Dinger und die sind grün. Also ich vermute mal, dass unsere Freunde von dem rosa T irgendwie Sorgen haben, wieder mal.
Na, war nicht heute auch die größte DDoS-Attacke schon wieder unterwegs, 340 Gigabit oder sowas?
Keine Schleichwerbung jetzt hier.
Die DDoS-Attacke?
Vielleicht für die Firma, die das immer berichtet. Weil die berichten ja, dass sie es wieder ausgehalten haben, die größte DDoS-Attacke seit immer.
Echt, welches ist es denn?
Keine Namen nennen.
Also Anfangsbuchstube?
Keine Namen. Disco betreibt ja nichts und die CIS-Webseiten selber willst du nicht sehen.
Ja, das ist eine C noch. Gib mal noch einen Tipp, Dennis. Naja, aber auf jeden Fall ist irgendwie in letzter Zeit irgendwie ganz schön viel so eine Attacke, so eine Attacke irgendwie unterwegs. Also ich krieg ja auch hin und wieder mal dann irgendwie, ah die, was, ach die. Ganz mysteriöser Treiber.
Clemens, kannst du mal zu Xenim mal irgendwie rumdresen, ob da irgendwie was braunes ist?
Musst du mir mal deinen Aufpunkt da mal, oder das Hinstreams mal zuhauchen.
Hast du noch ein Thema, können wir schon weiter machen? Ja, klar.
Also es ist auch nicht nur nach Xenim, es ist wie gesagt nach Spiegel D und überall ist irgendwie Loch Fras mal zwischendurch.
An welcher Stelle?
Zweiter Hopp. Oder angeblich, also im MTR ist es dann schon ab dem zweiten Hopp. Also hinter deiner Fritzbox. Telekom höchstwahrscheinlich, würde ich dann auch denken.
Schau mal, wir suchen uns hier mal einen anderen Provider.
Einen anderen Provider, wenn es mal einen anderen gäbe, der abwegs Internet anbietet.
Ja, dann gehen wir mal hier oben aufs Dach. Gehst du mal zu deiner komischen Hausverwaltung hier, sagst mal, du müsstest mal oben gerade aufs Dach drauf.
Und dann?
Ja, außerhalb, da musst du sogar ranlassen. Da hast du da recht, oh, türkisches Fernsehen.
Was soll mir das dann bringen?
Ja, machen wir auch Richtfunkstrecke.
Sagst du mir, dass das jetzt ein Telekom-Problem ist?
Ich bin noch dabei, mir das anzugucken, bevor ich starte, pointing names and naming fingers.
So, da wir uns ja vorher nicht so richtig abstimmen wollten, worüber wir reden, laufen wir jetzt Gefahr, beliebig zu springen.
Geil.
Wozu haben wir nicht Show Notes Leute, die das wieder schön sortieren?
Und da ihr einfach so verzweifelt seid, möchte ich einfach meine Themen durchdrücken.
Entschuldigung, einen letzten Satz zur Fritzbox noch. Bitte. Ich hatte einen kleinen Rennort losgetreten. Es kann durchaus sein, dass der automatische Update nicht geht, weil die letzte Version, die draußen ist, hat unter bestimmten Umständen einen Memory Leak. Der zeichnet sich dann dadurch aus, dass Teile der Webseite nicht mehr funktionieren. Du klickst drauf und passiert einfach nichts oder du kommst auf die Login-Seite zurück. Unter anderem auch die Update-Funktion. Das heißt, wenn die nicht geht, einmal Fritzbox booten und dann den Update laufen lassen.
Das hattest du auch selber, den Fall?
Ja, den hatte ich auf fast allen meiner Fritzbox.
Wirklich?
Ja, weil die laufen alle so lange und die waren halt eben schon so am Ende. Und ich immer so, oh, jetzt Update klicken? Und er so, hm, Update, nö. Lock dich mal neu ein. Dann hab ich's ja durchgebootet, dann ging's. Vielleicht ist es auch schon Nebeneffekt davon, dass diese bösen, bösen Hacker da versucht haben, auf meinen Fritzboxen rumzubohren oder sowas. Aber jedenfalls, wenn der Update nicht geht, weil er das einfach nicht tut, dann hingehen und einmal durchbooten und direkt danach den Update drauf lassen. So, jetzt dein Thema.
Ja, ich wollte ja letztes Mal noch mal ein bisschen was zu Abdotnet sagen, weil da haben wir schon sehr lange nicht drüber geredet. Und da das bei manchen Leuten auch gerade so ein bisschen so ein Thema ist, weil jetzt nämlich diese ganzen Verlängerungen des Bezahlens anstehen. Also für viele war so ein Jahr jetzt rum. Oder zumindest für die Früheinsteiger ein bisschen später. Weil da ja am Anfang noch mehr Geld genommen wurde und später dann der Preis gesenkt wurde und man dann dafür extra Monate bekommen hat. Und ich hatte drei bezahlte Accounts und werde jetzt mit zwei bezahlten Accounts weitermachen. Also einen lasse ich einfach weg, weil den einen habe ich nur deshalb bezahlt, weil es damals nur bezahlt gab. Und ich aber jetzt da an der Stelle mit dem sogenannten Free Tier genauso glücklich bin, weil so richtig aktiv in Nutzung mit Following und Pipapo bin ich eh nur mit meinem privaten Tempridlove-Account und dann habe ich noch einen Developer-Account, das ist der Podlove-Account. Und das ist eigentlich so das, was ich da wirklich an Premium-Dienstleistungen brauche. Jetzt war es so ein bisschen ruhig geworden um up.net, weil die sehr viel im Hintergrund gearbeitet haben. Und ja, dann gab es mal wieder ein paar Verbesserungen. Ich weiß nicht, haben wir überhaupt schon mal über Broadcast hier gesprochen?
Schwierig zu überantworten, diese Frage. Ich weiß es jetzt nicht so direkt.
Du meinst Up.net-Podcast?
Ja, genau, Up.net-Podcast. Ich glaube, wir hatten das noch gar nicht, oder? Naja, auf jeden Fall, das war irgendwie der erste Dienst, der dazukam, Broadcast, was eine ganz interessante Idee ist, wie ich finde. Also sie versuchen da vor allem zu nutzen, dass sie ja auf Android und auf iOS diese dedizierte Up.net-Passport-Applikationen haben, die ich an sich schon mal eine sehr gute Idee finde, weil du ja quasi damit so eine offizielle Abbekommst, die sich aber eigentlich nicht um die Anwendung des Netzes primär kümmert, sondern vor allem um ihre Konfiguration. Das heißt, du kannst da deine ganzen Accounts einrichten, jetzt in der neuesten Version halt auch mit mehreren Accounts und kannst da eben so die ganzen Settings machen. Und damit nimmst du ja quasi auch den Stress aus den anderen ab, sie dieses Netzwerk für irgendeinen Dienst, den sie quasi selber erfinden oder mitbenutzen, nimmst den Stress daraus, solche Sachen auch noch mit anzubieten. Weil du willst nicht irgendwie in jeder App nochmal irgendwie die Möglichkeit bieten, deinen Profile-String zu ändern oder deinen Avatar auszutauschen oder so. Da reicht irgendwie ein einziges User-Interface. Und insofern finde ich das eine ganz gute Idee, da so eine Hauptapplikation zu haben, nämlich dieses Passport. Jetzt ist das natürlich auf den Geräten und damit ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn du überhaupt app.net benutzt, dass du das ohnehin installiert hast. Und jetzt haben sie mit diesem Broadcast-Dienst etwas eingeführt, womit man Push-Notifications schicken kann. Und jeder User kann jetzt einen sogenannten Broadcast einrichten unter broadcast.app.net, mit dem man dann Nachrichten verschicken kann. Das ist halt nochmal was anderes als normale Messages. Es ist halt ein Broadcast. Broadcast hat einen Titel, hat eine Description, hat ein Bild und einen Link für Read More. Das sind so die Komponenten. Und wenn du halt einen rausschickst, dann geht diese Nachricht an alle Subscriber. Und am Anfang war das so, dass ein Subscriber einen normalen App.net-Account haben muss, dann mit diesem Account subscribt ist. Und wenn du einen Broadcast rausschickst, dann geht eine Push-Notification an dein Device, wo diese Abdeutnet-Passport-App installiert ist. Und die kommt dann hoch und zeigt das an. So, was bedeutet das jetzt konkret? Das bedeutet, dass wenn du im ADN-Universum irgendwie drin bist, also dein Account hast, dass du beliebigen Quellen folgen kannst und die dir Push-Notifications schicken können, ohne dass du für beliebige Quellen eine App installiert haben musst. Weil sonst gibt es Push-Notifications halt nur mit irgendeiner App. Also wenn ich jetzt als Podcaster Leuten Bescheid sagen möchte, dass jetzt hier ein Stream anfängt zum Beispiel. Und ich möchte gerne auch Push-Notifications haben, weil das total hip und cool ist. Und ja, wir tragen alle Hawaii-Himden.
Das ist schon lange her, dass die cool waren. Aber wir haben es dir die ganzen Jahre nicht gesagt, du kannst auch weiterhin Hawaii-Himden podcasten.
Naja, aber so kann ich halt auch eine Push-Notification bei Leuten erzeugen, ohne eine eigene Abhaben zu müssen. Weil diese gibt es quasi schon als Proxy, nämlich in Form von Abdeutnet Passport. Die dann eben diese Push-Notification erhält, du rufst sie dann auf, dann startet dieses Abdeutnet Passport, zeigt dir im Wesentlichen diese Informationen an, diese vier Komponenten, die ich vorhin gesagt habe. Und dann kannst du halt dem Link folgen oder auch nicht. Und dann hast du das eben zur Kenntnis genommen. Jetzt haben sie im Januar das nochmal so weit erweitert, dass du noch nicht mal einen Abdeutnet-Account brauchst. Wenn du nicht eingeloggt bist, dann kannst du zum Beispiel auch per E-Mail folgen. Also kannst du so an Broadcast auch sagen, ja, hier, wenn da was ist, schick mir eine Mail. Aber du musst als Sender nicht wissen, ob da jemand eine Mail haben will oder ob er direkt eine Push-Notification auf seinem Device haben will. Das ist dann irgendwie egal. Und wenn du einen Developer-Account hast, dann kriegst du auch noch irgendwie Analytics. Also wie viele Leute haben das jetzt irgendwie bekommen? Pipapo. Hab ich aber jetzt noch nicht so einen Blick drauf geworfen, obwohl wir das theoretisch mit dem Podlauf-Account machen können. Vielleicht machen wir das mal beim nächsten Software-Update, dass man da mal reinschaut. Also siehst du dann irgendwie, wie viele Leute haben das irgendwie geöffnet, wie viele Leute haben das per Push, per E-Mail bekommen und wie viele Leute sind überhaupt subscribt und wie viele haben uns subscribt in einem bestimmten Zeitraum. So, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr da irgendwie eine Meinung so habt. Und trage euch alles gar nicht, wa?
Nee, ich bin so ein bisschen, also ich mach so den Update-Net-Klient so vielleicht einmal die Woche so auf, guck so, was da so ein bisschen drin ist. Und mach dann dann meistens auch relativ schnell wieder zu.
Aber auf Direktnachrichten reagierst du schon?
Ja, aber krieg ich sehr selten, also ja, aber meistens, es kann auch mal eine Woche dauern, dass ich da drauf reagiere, weil irgendwie, ich weiß nicht. Welchen Client benutzt du? Ja, eigentlich benutze ich auf dem Desktop ja Wedge, hauptsächlich, weil das der Einzige ist, der Multi-Account kann und... Warum nicht?
Du benutzt auch mehrere Accounts.
Ja, halt so, um Announcements halt rauszuhauen, 300 Hearts, irgendwie neue Podcast-Folge. Wie viel hab ich denn da eigentlich eingetragen jetzt? Ich glaube, ich sind auch nur... Diese Clients.
Damit sind wir genau bei dem Thema. Ich bin dabei, diese ADN-Geschichte demnächst in die Tonne zu treten, weil ich bis heute immer noch keine funktionierende Clients gefunden habe.
Hä, hat jetzt Wedge Multiple Accounts wieder ausgebaut?
Nein. Du hast das Update gestartet, das 06-Update, und dann schmeißt er alle Accounts weg und du musst alle nochmal neu eintragen. Dieser Typ ist auch total unkommunikativ, und diese Software hat keine Zukunft, und das ist furchtbar.
Ja, und dieses Kiwi ist halt auch scheiße.
Es wird irgendwie für die Developer nicht genug Geld ab, dass sie da groß Zeit drauf verwenden. Es gibt allerdings jetzt die Ankündigung, dass es demnächst einen neuen Client geben wird, für den Mac namens Pigasus.
Nochmal, solange das Ding bezahlt ist, bezahlt ist bezahlt. Aber wenn es dann das nächste Mal rumkommt, die mich fragen, ob ich verlängere, wenn ich dann keinen Client habe, fliege ich das wieder raus. Das war schade, weil ich inzwischen 2.000 Queued-Follower habe. Und das auch wenn dann mal benutze, weil mich das schon freut, dass man gerade für technische Themen mal mehr als 140 Zeichen hat. Aber diese Kleinsituation ist total...
Vor allem, dass man für Direktnachrichten mal zwei Kilobyte vollschreiben kann, finde ich auch sehr entspannt.
Kann ich mit einem Message auch.
Was ich ganz entspannt fände, auch wenn wir die Heizung jetzt wieder ein bisschen runterdrehen, weil ich hier irgendwie gleich mich ganz ausziehen muss. Das ist ja irgendwie, Dennis, du bist doch jetzt auch wieder aufgewärmt, oder? Von diesen heißen Themen.
Nee, der Mac Pro ist an.
Ja, Dennis hat ja hier Temperatur hochgedreht.
Jetzt macht er auch die Jacke auf, siehst du mal.
So, schon hatten wir wieder einen kleinen Burst. Wir haben allerdings keine Störungen auf dem DSL draußen. Also ich habe jetzt Roh auf der Leitung keine Störungen, sondern das ist der Next Top, der gelegentlich mal aussetzt für ein paar.
Meins Telekom? Was ist das?
Ja, aber die anderen Leute, die... Die anderen Leute richten ja auch, dass sie das Tuxenium irgendwie Packet-Loss haben. Also irgendwas ist da gerade braun, eben Starter, Internet.
Ja, aber nur weil der Router ab und zu mal rostet, irgendwie gehen auch nicht gleich Stream kaputt.
Nö, ist ja auch TCP-basiert. Das müsste dann eigentlich mal ein paar Bits fehlen, die wiederholen, mittelfristig.
Naja, unser Verkehrsminister hat gesagt, wir kriegen total geiles Internet. Irgendwann fünf Jahre nach meinem Ableben. So, ich mache jetzt trotzdem noch meine Abdeutnet-Updates, weil ich sehe zwar, dass die Schwierigkeit haben, sich in bestimmten Zielgruppen in den Köpfen festzusetzen, aber ich finde es nach wie vor das beste Netz für die Dienstleistung, die ich eigentlich haben will.
Das ist aber echt Nerds Only, ne? Es gab zwar ein paar Leute, die sich in der Anfangszeit eben auch aus der nicht so nerdigen Gegend da mal reinverirrt haben, aber von denen hörste nix, liest nix und so, die sind allerdings wieder bei Twitter. Das ist echt Nerds Only. Abdeutnet. Ja, das war bei Twitter auch mal.
Das ist alles war mal Nerds Only.
Jede gute Zeit war mal eine schlechte neue Zeit.
ADN gelingt es entweder, die Killer abzufinden oder nicht. So, ob das wann das stattfindet, ob das stattfindet, wissen wir nicht, aber auszuschließen ist es eigentlich. Ich finde es technisch allerdings nach wie vor sehr interessant, was sie machen. Nächste Maßnahme, die sie dann gestartet haben, ist, dass sie gefragt haben, ob man denn jetzt mal bitte Bitcoin unterstützen soll als Bezahlung, weil viele Leute haben auch gesagt, ich würde ja gerne hier irgendwas bezahlen, aber ich nix PayPal aus technischen oder religiösen Gründen oder aus Mangel an Kreditkarte, weil du auch nur dann irgendwie, wenn da Kreditkarte hinterlegt ist, etc., da irgendwie überhaupt zahlen kannst, ist alles ein bisschen elend. Das Interessante ist, dass sie nicht gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt Bitcoin, sondern sie haben halt gesagt, wir machen vielleicht Bitcoin und haben ein Crowdfunding-Modell quasi. Also sie haben halt gesagt, wenn so und so viele Leute insgesamt 10 Bitcoins, also nicht so und so viele Leute, sondern wenn insgesamt 10 Bitcoins zusammenkommen als Pledge, dass sie darüber entweder einen normalen Account auf ein Jahr lang verlängern oder auch gleich 10 auf einmal kaufen oder einen Developer-Account verlängern, dann machen wir das. Das läuft jetzt noch 9 Tage, glaube ich. Ich gucke gerade mal. 8 Tage, also knapp eine Woche.
Und sie haben es ja auch schon fast.
Naja, 7,83 Bitcoins sind bisher reingekommen von 10.
Naja, 78 Prozent, das ist doch gut. Wie lange läuft das schon?
Ich glaube, ein Monat lief das.
Oh, verstehe. Also das ist schon noch ein bisschen knapp.
Na gut, aber erfahrungsgemäß...
Am Ende machen sie alle nochmal.
Was in den letzten Minuten passiert dann immer am meisten, muss man sehen. Vielleicht klappt es auch nicht. Was ich am interessantesten fand an dieser Webseite, als sie hochkam, war so, ah, alles klar, die machen hier Crowdfunding. Und was für ein Aufwand. Sie machen sich dafür jetzt hier irgendwie so ein komplett eigenes System für Crowdfunding, um diese Feature zu hinterfragen. Und dann zwei Tage später war dieser ADN Hackathon, den sie irgendwie, glaube ich, alle paar Monate im Silicon Valley-Bereich machen. Und als dann dieser Hackathon gestartet ist, haben sie auch noch eine neue Plattform vorgestellt. Die heißt nämlich Backer.
Musste noch richtig tippen.
Muss sie nur richtig tippen.
Und Internet muss gehen, aber gerade hackt es.
Das Internet ist gerade so richtig an der Wand.
Telekom ist jetzt sozusagen richtig...
Aber nicht nur Telekom, also Xenem-Jungs schreiben auf ihrer Status-Webseite vom Rechenzentrum von money2.de, dass es auch gerade Probleme bei der Erreichbarkeit des RZs gäbe. Vielleicht ist heute wirklich noch so... Ja, oder tatsächlich wieder so irgendwelche großflächigen Attacken auf alle, die nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen sind, die gerade so die Infrastruktur zum...
Na gut, dafür gibt es ja dann Podcasts, das ist ja das Schöne daran. Und es hofft, wer die zufällig aufnimmt.
Das ist zwei Gigabyte.
Unable. So, wie auch immer. Becker ist jetzt quasi die Plattform. Und das ist so ein Crowdfunding-Service für, explizit für Software gedacht. Also hier geht es explizit um Developer, die eben so sollen wir Feature X in unserer Software implementieren. Ja, nein. Und wenn ihr Geld gebt in der Größe, machen wir das, in der Größe machen wir das, in der Größe machen wir das. Du kannst also sozusagen verschiedene Arten und Weisen der Bezahlung zur Verfügung stellen und du kannst auch, du kannst da über, jetzt muss ich grad nochmal gucken, wie man da eigentlich bezahlen kann.
Es hat jetzt den Beras gerissen von der Telekom.
Bitte?
Es hat jetzt den Beras gerissen von der Telekom. Es gab keine DSL-Neuverhandlungen, sondern die PPP-Session ist kaputt gegangen, die PPP-UE-Session. In diesem Moment? Nee, nee, vorhin, also jetzt vor zwei Minuten. Deswegen waren wir hier offline, wie gesagt, lag er aber nicht an unserer Box oder an unserem DSL oder an dem Kasten vor der Tür, sondern an dem Beras. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass bei der Telekom irgendwie auch gerade jemand ein bisschen Ärger am Hals hat. Doch, Rubble ist im Karton.
In der Kiste.
Wir sind jetzt hier gerade die Bezahlungsoptionen gerade etwas unklar. Ich dachte, Bitcoin wäre jetzt hier schon dabei, aber irgendwie haben sie jetzt hier nur Kreditkarten-Payment, as I check this out.
Mit Stripe.
Das finde ich ja ein bisschen bekloppt. Aber vielleicht hängt das eben auch noch von diesem Bitcoin-Kram ab und wenn sie dann Bitcoin machen, ich dachte, sie tun das schon, dann wollen sie das so machen, dass man nicht nur da plätschen kann für dieses Crowdfunding mit Bitcoin, also dass du dann quasi mit Bitcoin bezahlst, sondern dass du es auch über Bitcoin ausgezahlt bekommst. Und natürlich nehmen sie eine Fee dafür, sofern es sich bei dir nicht um Open Source handelt oder anders ausgedrückt. Als Open Source Projekt kann man backer.up.net benutzen und übrigens auch ohne. Das wendet sich an jeden. Das ist unabhängig von up.net. Man braucht jetzt keinen up.net-Account, um das zu benutzen. Du kannst irgendwie, also du brauchst einen up.net-Account, um das einzurichten. Aber die Leute, die bezahlen, dort brauchen jetzt keinen up.net-Account.
Und ist 5 Stunden Freak Show auch ein Feature?
Wie? Du meinst, wir sollten uns dafür bezahlen lassen, eine längere Sendung zu machen?
Oder kürzer, je nachdem.
Also wie gesagt, es geht hier explizit um Software. Und wenn du jetzt ein Open Source-Projekt bist, dann zahlst du genau 0% Fees. Also es ist eine Plattform, die du benutzen kannst, wo du sagen kannst, sollen wir Feature X einbauen? Also was weiß ich, wenn wir jetzt hier bei POTLAP sagen, ja hier, wir könnten uns das und das und das mal auch mal vorstellen, aber wie das sowieso ist mit der Kohle, blablabla, wollt ihr hier irgendwie Statistiken, wollt ihr was weiß ich haben, und kostet X. Könnte man ja machen. Machen wir zwar anders, aber könnte man so machen. Und dann kriegst du als Open Source-Projekt, weil du ja quasi darüber was zurückgibst, die ganzen Fees von app.net erlassen. Du kannst die Plattform also kostenlos nutzen. Was jetzt so schlecht auch nicht ist, weil das hast du eben bei anderen Crowdfunding-Plattformen so auch nicht. Und in dem Moment, wo du auch noch Bitcoin als Auszahlung benutzt, hast du noch nicht mal Transfer-Fees. Also hast du noch nicht mal diese einen Auszahlungsprozente, die weggehen, abgesehen natürlich von dem, was du jetzt bei Bitcoin noch freiwillig oder zukünftig...
Die 0,0005 oder 1 oder hier...
Genau, aber ganz andere Nummer als jetzt hier irgendwie PayPal 2% oder sonst irgendwas.
Oder Flatter.
Oder Flatter, genau, 10%. Also das sind alles so Sachen, die an der Stelle irgendwie wegfallen. Finde ich auf jeden Fall eine coole Idee. Ja, so das sind so die Neuigkeiten. Außerdem gibt es mal wieder einen Podcast, wo sie dann diese ganzen Features und auch ihre Motivation dahinter erzählen. Leider benutzen sie immer noch nicht pot laufen. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob sie das jemals tun werden, aber mal gucken. Was habe ich noch entdeckt? Und dann gibt es noch ein Updatenet Wiki, was ich insofern interessant fand, als es einerseits nicht viel enthält. Da kann man noch eine Menge reinschreiben. Aber offensichtlich hat irgendjemand ein Media-Wiki-Authentication-Modul für ADN gemacht. Was ist los hier? Unterhaltet ihr euch wieder über andere Sachen?
Nein, nein, nein. Im Chat kam nur ein lustiges Bildchen.
Wirklich?
Das da ja.
Der Stream-Bildchen hier.
Kriegen wir da wieder Ärger für.
Waitfold, Waitfold.
Das hab ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Also es gibt ein Up.net-Wiki. Up.net-Wiki ausgeschrieben. Das ist irgendwie so userbetrieben. Und was sie jetzt auch gemacht haben, ist, im Blog gibt es jetzt so eine Art Disqus ähnliche Kommentarfunktion für Blogs, wo du quasi auch über ADN gehen kannst. Das heißt, das Kommentieren der Blog-Einträge geht quasi über ADN. Und wenn du dann halt einen Blog-Eintrag kommentierst und jemanden antwortest, dann antwortest du ihnen aber auch gleich in der Timeline. Also angenommen, du würdest jetzt in irgendeinem Blog-Eintrag was schreiben, dann erscheint es in der Timeline. Ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, aber so funktioniert es derzeit. Naja, auf jeden Fall probieren sie da nach wie vor eine Menge aus und so Sachen wie Disqus zu ersetzen kann durchaus ein näheres Ziel sein, weil dann hast du halt bei ADN eben nicht diese ganzen Datenharvester rein, sondern eben ein Netz, was eine andere Motivation hat darunter.
Ja, wie mein Freund Kurt sagen würde, dem sowas Spaß macht, ich interessiere mich für Fische. Wir teilen deine Begeisterung.
In Teilen.
Ich merke schon, ich bin auch voll motiviert.
Trotz fortgeschrittener Uhrzeit und Alters.
Ich bin das gewohnt.
Ich finde es ja auch schön, dass die das da alles so machen.
Ich bin ein Visionär. Wer erkennt das alles erst in zwei, drei Jahren, dass das cool ist? Ernsthaft jetzt?
Natürlich ernsthaft.
Bei Google Wave hat es ja auch eine Weile gedauert.
Das Leben des Temprittler ist ein Leben voller Missverständnis. Aber wo wir jetzt gerade schön rüber geleitet haben, ist natürlich das Thema Bitcoin.
Redux. Die lange Fassung heißt doch Redux bei Apocalypse Now.
Kommt jetzt die lange Fassung?
Wenn er wollt.
Okay, also something happened. Ich weiß nicht, willst du es gleich?
Wir können da Ping-Pong spielen, wenn du willst. Ja, ja, ich hab da ein paar Anmerkungen. Also es ging wohl los. Ich hab so ein paar Sachen gelesen. Das gesamte Bild kann man dir sowieso nicht wiedergeben, weil dazu fehlt einfach sowieso hier und da und dort immer noch so paar Schnipselwissen, die, weiß nicht, ob jemand alles komplett überschaut, aber dass auch schon vor einer Woche oder ein bisschen länger noch, gab es Leute, die sich beschwert haben, dass ihre Auszahlung von Mt. Gox irgendwie nicht ankommt. Da haben die auch schon bei Reddit irgendwie Also ihre Auszahlung Bitcoin-Auszahlung. Genau, es ging nicht um Euros, das dauert bei Mt. Gox sowieso immer so ein bisschen, aber gut, dauert halt, aber dass die Bitcoins irgendwie nicht kommen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die User das geprüft haben, weil das kommen vielleicht noch später zu, aber grundsätzlich war die Aussage erstmal, die Bitcoins kommen nicht so richtig an. Haben auch an die Bitcoin Foundation schon so einen Brief geschrieben, wo irgendwie zusammen, haben sich ein paar Leute zusammengetan, meinten sie, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, weil der Mt. Gox-Typie ist ja wohl auch in der Foundation diesem Board irgendwie der Member. Und das kann ja nicht sein, dass einer der Member ist an der Foundation und dann das Auszahlung, ich komme, und die hatten alle Angst, Mt. Gox ist pleite und insolvent und die kriegen ihre Bitcoins nicht mehr und haben schon voll irgendwie Panik, Panik, Panik, was man ja auch jetzt am Bitcoin-Kurs sieht. Und dann haben die da alle mal gemacht und geforscht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, was die richtige zeitliche Reihenfolge ist, aber ich glaube, es ging dann los. Also erstens hat Mt. Gox dann die Auszahlung erstmal gesperrt, also von Bitcoins.
Das war letzten Freitag oder Donnerstag?
Das war Freitag, genau, haben sie das angegeben. Dann ging noch der Kurs dann nochmal so richtig ab, also nach unten. Und dann haben sie auch geschrieben so ein bisschen, was denn ihr Problem ist.
Das kam aber erst später. Erst mal kam nur, wir haben ein Problem.
Wir haben ein Problem und deswegen gibt es keine Auszahlung. Montag gibt es genaueres oder so.
Dann kam aber, glaube ich, am Samstag schon nochmal eine Klarifizierung.
Ja, das wann jetzt was kam, weiß ich nicht so, aber die Klarifizierung war dann, dass sie gesagt haben, dass sie halt Probleme mit ihrem Accounting haben und dass halt Auszahlungen halt bei den Leuten nicht ankommen, obwohl sie aber getätigt wurden und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist eigentlich alles ganz okay, so in einem grünen Bereich, aber irgendwas ist wohl doch nicht ganz okay, so ungefähr. Und deswegen haben sie es halt ausgeschaltet. Und noch niemand hat so richtig verstanden, was es ist. Und da haben sie dann noch nicht gesagt, was genau das Problem war. Und, ähm, ja, also was die jetzt erzählt haben, ist eigentlich auch egal. Ich sag jetzt mal, was das Problem ist, oder? Dann kommen wir mal zur Sache. Ich kann nicht mehr herausfinden, wer wann was wie gesagt hat. Also...
Jaja, also ich hab's jetzt vor allem auch andersrum verstanden. Ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt schon aus ihren Meldungen oder aus der Berichterstattung an sich, dass es nicht so ist, dass die Zahlungen nicht ankommen, ist mir jetzt neu.
Ich dachte, das Problem ist das... Ich hab ja extra die Betonung geändert. Ich hab gesagt, da sind Leute, die gesagt haben, dass ihre Auszahlung nicht ankommt. Das haben die gesagt. Also, wie die das geprüft haben, das weiß ich nicht. Oder ob es grundsätzlich schon gelogen war. Aber die Auszahlungen, die sind schon angekommen. Aber du kriegst ja...
Nur Mount Cox hat es nicht gemerkt, dass die zugestellt wurden.
Die User eventuell auch nicht, weil wenn du eine Auszahlung hast, ist wie bei meinem Pool auch, du kriegst eine E-Mail, wo drin steht, ey, Jungs, alles super, wir haben die Auszahlung gemacht und zwar folgendermaßen, wenn du schon mal gucken willst, wo die denn ist, Blockchain Info, kann man ja prima gucken, hier hast du eine Transaction ID, dann kannst du gucken.
Da müsste sie gleich auftauchen.
Da müsste sie gleich auftauchen. Die Leute haben diese Transaction ID genommen, haben die in Blockchain Info reingeschmissen und siehe da. Wie sie sehen, sehen sie nichts. Und das ist genau das Problem, es gibt diese Transaction... Ja, diese Malability. Also man kann Transactions, wie soll man sagen, man kann die umschreiben und sie sind dann trotzdem noch valide. Man muss sich das jetzt so vorstellen, wenn man irgendwie einen Bitcoin-Demon anstarrt und macht eine Auszahlung, dann ist das so, als wenn man, man muss sich das vorstellen, man hat seinen Portemonnaie und da sind Coins drinne. Weil meine Bitcoin Wallet ist auch so, da sind lauter einzelne Coins und das ist nicht eine große Summe, sondern sie besteht auch schon da aus lauter kleinen, signierten Coins. Und wenn ich davon was bezahlen will, dann muss ich das passende zusammennehmen. Und dann kann es aber sein, dass ich immer noch Wechselgeld kriege und das kriege ich dann zurück. Das ist dann, eine Überweisung geht an den, den ich bezahlen will und eine Überweisung ist mein Wechselgeld an mich selbst. Das ist die Transaction. Die schicke ich ins Netz. Und wenn dann da jemand ist, der, also, weil Bitcoin ist ja ein riesengroßes Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk, also jeder spricht ja da irgendwie mit jedem und so weiter. Wenn da einer ist, der unterwegs diese Payment von mir, diese Transaktion umschreibt, dann ist sie ja dadurch nicht invalid, sondern...
Was heißt denn umschreibt? Also was könnte man denn da umschreiben?
Ja, da muss ich jetzt vorsichtig formulieren, man kann sich das so vorstellen, da sind ja auch Inputs und Outputs von diesen Bitcoins, also diese Keys drin, von wo das Geld halt kommt, oder die Bitcoins. Und auch eine Signatur und es gibt wohl verschiedene Formen, wie man diese Signatur speichern kann. Das ist wohl auch OpenSSL basiert, weil OpenSSL hat verschiedene Wege, so eine Signatur zu interpretieren. Man kann die so oder so schreiben. So, und da gibt's Leute, die ja unterwegs, wo halt diese Transaktion, wo die lang rennt, bevor die in diesen Blog eingetragen wird, die haben die sich angeguckt. Dann haben sie gesagt, alles klar, die Signatur, die ist ja komisch, wir schreiben die mal neu. Ein Grund ist auch eventuell, dass es eine Bitcoin-Policy gibt, die sagt, alles muss möglichst klein sein, damit diese Blockchain nicht so riesengroß wird. Das ist jetzt aber auch teilweise nur so Vermutung, weil sie wissen es ja auch alle noch nicht so genau. Zumindest ist es so mein Stand. Jedenfalls wurden diese Signaturen, wurden mehr wieder in Richtung Standard gebracht oder eben auch nicht oder wurden gekürzt. Jedenfalls wurden sie leicht angepasst. Aber es wurde, da wurde nichts, die Bitcoins kommen weiterhin da an, wo sie ankommen. Der, der sie verschickt, der ist hier auch genauso los. Also alles ist eigentlich voll super, alles prima. Jeder kriegt sein Geld und jeder, alles Geld kommt auch an und alles ist voll normal. Aber durch die Änderung der Signatur ist die Berechnung der Transaction ID haut nicht mehr hin. Das heißt, da entsteht dann eine andere Transaction ID. Das heißt, wenn du diese Signatur da z.B. änderst unterwegs in der Transaction, dann landet diese geänderte Geschichte in der Blockchain. Und in der Blockchain landet ja auch die Transaction ID dann, weil die beruhen sich alle gegenseitig. Aber jetzt findest du, die Transaction ID, die der Mount Gox in der Mail geschickt hat, die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, weil in der Blockchain ist jetzt die geänderte Transaction gelandet.
Beziehungsweise, wenn es eine Änderung gibt, ist das quasi so eine geänderte Kopie. Die sind beide im Netz. Aber welche von denen dann letzten Endes quasi die offizielle ist?
Interessant ist nur die, die im Blog angekommen ist, die vom nächsten Pool oder wer auch immer berechnet wurde. Das ist die, die dann zählt, weil alles andere ist ja egal. Und das, was Mount Gox dabei sich gespeichert hat, das ist zwar das, was sie dachten, was so entstehen wird, da das sie unterwegs aber jemand umgeschrieben hat, ist es nicht mehr diese Transaction ID.
Und dann warten sie immer auf die Bestätigung und die kommt nicht, obwohl die Zahlung eigentlich stattgefunden hat, sodass sie dann selber vielleicht auch irgendwann einen Timeout haben und dann anfangen, es nochmal zu wenden.
Das ist genau der Haken, also wenn Mount Gox wirklich so blöd ist und wenn ihr System da so ja, wir gucken mal nach, alles klar, Transaction ID ist noch nicht angekommen, okay, wir zahlen die 1000 Bitcoins jetzt mal nochmal, dann ja, sorry, dann sind die vielleicht auch pleite, glaube ich, aber ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich habe da aber interessante Erkenntnisse.
Na, da kannst du ja gleich noch zufügen. Ich glaube eher, dass sie mit ihrem Accounting gerade eher so ein riesengroßes Problem haben. Sie haben halt jetzt lauter Transaction ID's in ihrer Datenbank, die es aber so nicht gibt. Und ich glaube, sie mussten jetzt mal zurückspulen und haben auch rückwärts gesucht, ab wann das denn schon vorgekommen ist und müssen eigentlich jetzt ihr ganzes Accounting-System von vor zwei, drei Wochen noch mal, na ja, nicht einen Rollback machen, aber das noch mal neu in die Datenbank eintragen. Und weil es jetzt aber diese geänderten Transaction ID's gibt, gibt es, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden habe, von den Bitcoin Core-Developern, gibt es auch schon eine Normalized Transaction ID. Da sorgen sie dafür, dass diese Signatur immer in einer bestimmten Form geschrieben wird, egal wie sie angekommen ist. Sondern sie wird jetzt immer so geschrieben. Das heißt, das ist eine Transaction ID, die sich nicht mehr ändern kann. Die haben sich sozusagen auf so eine Art Standard, oder die nutzen halt jetzt ein Standard, wie man dafür sorgen kann, dass die Transaction ID auch, wenn man unterwegs die Transaction so umdreht, dass man sie so berechnet, dass sie immer gleich ist. Weil die Inputs und Outputs, die ändern sich ja nicht. Sonst ist der Key ja nicht mehr gültig und der hascht nicht mehr und sonst nichts.
Also man setzt die ID einfach aus anderen Sachen zusammen. Es ist nicht einfach nur so ein Hasch von dem Blob, den man da los schickt, sondern es ist quasi etwas, was mehr auf den Komponenten, die da drin sind, basiert.
So wie vorher auch, bloß, dass sie sich jetzt geeinigt haben, dass die Signatur immer so aussehen soll. Und wenn sie anders ist, dann passt man sie erst wieder an. Also dass sie immer gleich ist. Und so einen Code gibt es schon. Ich weiß nicht, wann sie denn releasen werden und ob sie das wirklich so durchdrücken oder ob das jetzt nur so ein Hotfix für Mt. Gox ist. Also das war auch die erste Antwort von dem Gavin Andresen. Er hat gesagt, Bitcoin hat irgendwie gar kein Problem. Das ist Mt. Gox, was das Problem hat. Und die haben ihr Accounting da nicht im Griff. Und dieser Fehler ist schon seit Jahren bekannt. Diese Transaction-Malability. Und sie hätten ihr System nicht darauf aufbauen dürfen. Und die sind ja doof und stinken nach Luna. Und die sollen das mal fixen. Das war so Montag. Inzwischen ist es aber so, dass auch schon andere Exchanges das gleiche Problem haben. Da ist es nämlich auch schon passiert, dass unterwegs die Transaction geändert wurden. Teilweise haben die das schneller gefixt. Aber was jetzt halt noch dazugekommen ist...
Dass das jetzt alle ausprobieren, so ein richtiger DDoS, irgendwie wir...
Was genau die Ursache ist, weiß nicht. Da gibt es auch Leute, die sagen, dass es eventuell auch eine gut gemeinte Änderung von einem Pool war, der halt diese Signaturen wieder gerade schreibt. Weil Montgogs vorher auch schon komische Signaturen rausgeschickt hat. Und die dachten sich, die sieht ja komisch aus, wir machen die mal wieder richtig. Dadurch haben sie aber die Transaction-ID von Montgogs irgendwie geändert und so. Eine Weile lang ist es wahrscheinlich keinem aufgefallen, weil dein Geld kommt ja an und wen interessiert die Transaction-ID. Aber irgendwann gab es halt ein Problem. Und Montgogs kann man ja auch kleinreden und sagen, die sind ja nicht mehr die größten und coolsten überhaupt, aber ich glaube, da gehen schon ein paar Euros bei denen durch. Also die werden schon ein paar Transaction am Tag haben. Also man kann sich ja die Millionen Dollars, die da täglich durchfließen oder an Bitcoins und Auszahlungen kann man sich ja angucken. Die haben ja eine API, wo man alles gucken kann und es gibt ja lauter Webseiten, die das anzeigen. So, das ist aber jetzt nur die anfängliche Geschichte. Was jetzt noch dazugekommen ist, ist, dass wenn du diese Auszahlung machst und du kriegst dein Wechselgeld an dich selbst zurücküberzahlt, also diesen Change, den du dich an dich zurück überweißt, wenn unterwegs deine Transaction verändert wird, dann, warte mal, ich muss das kurz anders erklären. Also wenn du irgendjemandem 10 Bitcoins rüber schiebst und du hast aber gerade nur einen Coin, der 15 Bitcoins groß ist, dann gehen ja fünf Bitcoins an dich selbst wieder zurück, damit du die weiter ausgeben kannst. So, normalerweise sagt man ja, wenn Bitcoins irgendwie überwiesen werden, dann brauchen die sechs Confirmations, bevor man die wieder einsetzen darf, damit man weiß, dass die auch wirklich in der Blockchain angekommen ist und nicht da irgendwie so ein Orphan-Block, wie man das so nennt, und sie jetzt doch an dem anderen Block weiterrechnen. Deswegen soll man sechs Blöcke warten, also sechs Confirmations, bis man irgendwie weiß, dass das Geld auf jeden Fall da ist und sich da nichts mehr ändern wird. Wenn du aber diesen Change an dich selber beweist, dann ist es im Bitcoin-Demon so eingecoded, alles klar. Das ist der Change, den du an dich selbst beweist, den darfst du sofort gleich weiter benutzen. Da musst du keine sechs Confirmations warten. Aber wenn jetzt unterwegs jemand deine Transaction ändert, also auch wieder diese Transaction-Mailability da durchführt, dann ist auch dein Change von den anderen, der wird dann irgendwie anders betrachtet und du kannst den dann nicht sofort einsetzen. Wenn du das aber machst, das ist auch gerade schon ein Patch, dieses Spend Zero Confirmation Coins, dann denken die anderen, dass es ein Double Spend wäre, wobei dein Bitcoin denkt, das ist doch mein Change, den kann ich doch ausgeben, den habe ich doch gerade mir selber erst zurück überwiesen. Also da sind die sozusagen dann auch nicht mehr in Sync, wenn unterwegs jemand deine Transaction ändert. Und da gibt es halt schon so einen Fleck, wo man das in seinem Bitcoin-Demon abschalten kann, dass das nicht sofort gespendet werden soll. Das heißt, wenn du zwei Transactions hintereinander machst. Also du machst einen, kriegst Change zurück und überweist dann gleich nochmal und der nimmt diesen Change, der eigentlich erst ein paar Runden warten müsste. Und das kann man jetzt gerade abschalten. Das ist noch nicht im offiziellen Bitcoin-Demon angekommen, wird aber auch, ich denke, da gibt es den nächsten Hotfix, es wird ein 087 geben und die 09 Release Candidate 1, da wird es einen neuen Release Candidate geben und da wird es dann gefixt sein. Aber das ist das Problem, warum bei Leuten jetzt die Wallet gerade so ein bisschen durchdreht, weil sie machen Transactions von ihrem Change, wenn sie so zwei hintereinander machen und die kommt dann nicht richtig an, weil sie als Doublespent gesehen wird und so weiter und so fort. Also es bröselt so gerade ein bisschen auseinander dort. Und ich fand es eigentlich ein bisschen unfair, dann zu sagen, der Mount Gox ist schuld, auch wenn es den Fehler schon länger gibt. Aber diese Transaction-ID, die konnte man ja nur mal auslesen und jeder dachte sich, dass die einzigartig ist. Also ich habe jetzt keine großen Warnhinweise gelesen, dass so, ja, da darf man sich nicht drauf verlassen. Ich habe jetzt nicht den kompletten Bitcoin-Demon-Sourcecode durchgelesen, aber bin jetzt schon ein bisschen länger dabei und mir ist das irgendwie noch nicht so bewusst entgegengeflogen.
Also für dich war das auch neu. Ich habe auch so gehört, dass das so seit 2011 überhaupt erst ein Good-Knowledge ist, dass das überhaupt geht oder überhaupt so ist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man sich jetzt das ganze Satoshi-Paper durchlesen muss, Mitglied bei der Foundation sein muss, keine Ahnung, aber mir war das so genau nicht bekannt. Ich dachte auch, alles klar, diese Transaction-ID, die ist fix. Also die ist wohl auch fix, aber erst in dem Augenblick, wo sie in der Blockchain gelandet ist. In dem Augenblick, wo mein Bitcoin-Demon diese Transaction macht und mir diese so gibt, das ist anscheinend nur eine Vermutung. Da muss man warten, ob sie dann wirklich auch genau so in diesem Block landen wird. Das ist wohl das Problem.
Darf ich jetzt eigentlich mein Bokbier aufmachen?
Ja, mach doch.
Offen ist es doch eigentlich schon.
Aber wir müssen jetzt noch ein bisschen über Bitcoin reden.
Ja, dürft ihr. Aber wenn ich dazu mein Bokbier trinken darf?
Sicher, klar.
Mach doch.
Aber dann können wir ja deine Reaktion, deine unmittelbare, nicht so mitspeichern. Oder wolltest du jetzt einfach mal hier nur trollen?
Nee, ich wollte jetzt mein Bokbier trinken. Ist das nicht das Gleiche?
Also, Clemens trinkt jetzt eine Berliner Weiße. So, ich war jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht mehrfach betroffen von dieser ganzen Geschichte. Weil erstens bin ich ja auch Mount Gox-Kunde. Und der Kurs ist ja bei Mount Gox noch sehr viel mehr als bei den anderen Bitcoin-Exchanges gefallen.
Ja, weil alle denken jetzt, Mount Gox ist schuld. Und vielleicht haben sie mit ihrem Accounting auch ein bisschen verschissen. Aber im Großen und Ganzen haben sie jetzt eigentlich dafür gesorgt, dass dieses Mollability, dass es jetzt ein großes Thema ist, dass die jetzt da Fixes einspielen. Und ich glaube, der größere Fix ist auch, dass jetzt alle auf so eine Art neue Transaction-ID umschalten müssten. Das ist aber eine Änderung, die man noch nicht von heute auf morgen machen kann. Sowas gab es letztes Jahr auch schon. Und da haben die das so gekodet, dass sie so eine neue Regel einbauen, die aber erst dann wirksam ist, wenn mehr als, keine Ahnung, 90-95% der generierten Blöcke innerhalb oder der letzten, wenn mehr als 90% der letzten 1000 Blöcke diese neue Version sind, dann switchen alle um und die restlichen 10%, wenn die da nicht switchen, haben die Pech gehabt. Das haben die letztes Jahr auch gemacht mit der neuen Block-Version 2. Da haben die eine neue Block-Version eingeführt. Und da haben sie gesagt, wenn die letzten 1000 Blöcke, 95% davon Version 2 sind, dann ab da wird dann Version 1 nicht mehr angenommen. Und diesmal können sie wieder eine neue Block-Version einführen, nämlich die Nummer 3. Die letzten 1000, 95%, 90% oder irgendwie so.
Das heißt, dieses Datenformat ändert sich quasi auch durch denselben Konsens, der auch überhaupt zur Bewertung von allen.
Ja, genau, weil es geht ja nicht. Ich kann nicht sagen, ihr müsst jetzt alle einen neuen 30 nehmen.
Aber das ist eigentlich sehr cool. Ich meine, wenn man das Internet so upgraden könnte. Man sagt jetzt, wenn hier irgendwie 90%...
Wenn 90% IPv6 benutzen, dann wird IPv4...
Dann gibt es einfach keinen V4 mehr. Und wer dann keins hat, tschüss. Schön wär's.
So machen die das da.
Interessant.
Weil jetzt...
also, ich war insofern betroffen, als dass ich sowohl Bitcoins als auch Geld da bei Mt. Gox rumliegen habe, so zu Experimentgründen. Und ich hatte ein paar Bitcoins verkauft und hatte also noch ein bisschen Geld rumliegen. Jetzt sah ich so den Kurs fallen und dachte natürlich auch...
Und dachte, kauf mal wieder einen. Oder machst du es nicht schnell verkaufen, weil es sinkt noch mehr. Das ist ja immer so eine Sache.
Ich hab halt dann angefangen, ein bisschen zu lesen, hab so ein bisschen auf ein paar Blogs gestoßen. Leute, die da irgendwie rumtwitterten und auf die verwiesen wurden, auf deren Blog-Einträge verwiesen wurden, die dann zu dem Zeitpunkt alle noch auf Mt. Gox eingeschlagen haben. Mit, ja, ihr seid ja doof und ihr riecht nach Lulo und ihr habt ja irgendwie das Internet nicht verstanden und Bitcoin schon gar nicht. Und was könnt ihr denn hier überhaupt...
Vor allem wird ja mal vorgeworfen, dass Mt. Gox heißt der Magic the Gathering Online Exchange. Das war ja einfach mal für diese Spielkarten gedacht. Und dann kommt so ein Typ hier daher und ändert irgendwie Karte gegen Bitcoin und meint, er kann jetzt irgendwie einen Bitcoin-Exchange fahren. Ist natürlich ein bisschen fies, weil alle müssen ja mal irgendwie klein anfangen und der war halt nur mal der Größte und dass die anderen den dann halt vielleicht überholt haben oder einen China-Exchange, der inzwischen aber auch schon wieder kleiner geworden ist. Also ich, ja, rummeckern ist immer einfach, finde ich. Also da sollte man schon ein bisschen mehr Ahnung haben.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall hatte ich auch gerade mal die Zeit, dem so ein bisschen zu folgen und es betraf mich an gewisser Hinsicht. Ich habe dann erst mal geguckt, wie der Kurs sich so verhält, so und als ich so das Gefühl hatte, verstanden zu haben, dass er sich hier nicht um... also, weil es wurde ja am Anfang auch gleich wieder diese Panik gemacht. So, ja, Apokalypse, Bitcoin-Protokoll, doch einen Fehler gefunden, alles geht den Bach runter, pipapo, dem ist ja nun mitnichten so. Und manche dann auch schon so schrieben, also auch gerade ihre anderen, die meinten so, ja, sollen sich mal alle irgendwie nicht so haben und so. Der Kurs wird schon wieder auf die 700 zurücksegeln, wo er hergekommen ist, weil es gibt hier eigentlich gar keinen Anlass, es gibt halt nur Verunsicherung. Ach, ich mir kauf immer mal wieder mal zwei Bitcoins.
Bei welchem Kurs? 500?
450. Nicht schlecht. Na ja, ist da schon teilweise noch mal so auf 400.
380.
380 runtergegangen, naja, also da hätt's noch bessere Momente gegeben, aber ich dachte mir dann auch so, ich setz auf 700, von daher bin ich mit 450 wahrscheinlich auch gut bedient.
So.
Dann kam diese von mir vorhin erwähnte Bitcoin-Geschichte mit up.net, an die ich mich dann deswegen auch noch mal dran erinnert habe, und dass es halt nur noch ein paar Tage sind und ich wollte...
Dann dachtest du, spende es doch mal schnell, weil jetzt ist ja gerade billig, weil die zählen ja in Bitcoins.
Das war so ein bisschen der erste Gedanke, auch wenn das insofern egal ist, als das abdot.net sowieso gesagt hat, dass sie einem den günstigsten Kurs am Ende zum Stichtag geben werden. Dass es also egal ist, zu welchem Zeitpunkt ich das commitment mache. Und naja, und dann habe ich zwei Überweisungen gemacht an abdot.net abdot.net mit meiner Bitcoin-QT.
Und die zwei Überweisungen waren in welchem Zeitrahmen?
Du meinst, wie schnell hintereinander? Kann ich dir genau sagen. Die erste war an dem Tag um 14 Uhr. Also ich kann es dir nicht so genau sagen. Die eine war 14.26 Uhr und die andere war 15.45 Uhr. Also da war so 40 Minuten dazwischen.
Also auf jeden Fall wurde dazwischen ein Blog gefunden. Kann man davon ausgehen?
Naja, also ich habe halt eine 0.036 Überweisung gemacht und eine 0.1 Überweisung gemacht. Wenn ich dir das mal hier kurz transparent machen darf. Ich habe wirklich, also es ist für mich insofern ein bisschen verwirrend, weil in dem Moment, als ich da rumgeklickt habe, das geht bei denen über Coinbase, lalala, habe ich aber nicht benutzt und habe halt direkt überwiesen. Dann hing irgendwie so das Web-Interface so ein bisschen, egal, aber ich habe dann letzten Endes, also ich kann mich an nichts anderes erinnern, als zwei Transaktionen autorisiert zu haben. Ich kann mich an nichts anderes erinnern. Das heißt nicht, dass ich nicht vielleicht ein Idiot bin und irgendwie alles falsch gemacht habe. Aber die eine Überweisung taucht hier zweimal auf. Und einmal ist sie irgendwie konfirmt und einmal ist sie nicht konfirmt.
Ok, deine Wallet ist kaputt. Das ist genau das, was die da alle berichtet haben.
Genau, weil Bitcoin QT enthält nämlich denselben Fehler.
Ja, deine Wallet ist kaputt. Also jetzt pass mal auf, ganz vorsichtig.
Schief durchatmen.
Schief durchatmen. Step 1, Backup machen. Step 2, du kannst, das gibt beim Bitcoin-Demon, das gibt eine Option, die heißt Salvage Wallet. Und die geht dann neu durch und guckt alle nach, was da nun mit deinen Transaktionen passiert ist.
Die schickt deine Wallet einmal nach Russland und nach China.
Also es gibt eine Option, die heißt Salvage Wallet. Du solltest aber vorher einen Backup machen, falls das nicht hinhaut. Und die sollte das wieder fixen. Und du solltest aber auch nach der letzten, bevor du das machst, sollte eine Weile Zeit vergangen sein, seit deiner letzten Transaktion, damit wirklich alles in Blöcken jetzt angekommen ist. Weil sonst geht das nämlich nicht.
Na gut, die letzte ist jetzt ein...
Von gestern, also seitdem wurden Blöcke gefunden. Und dann sollte das gehen.
Und? Also, was meinst du jetzt? Ich gehe auf ein Backup zurück?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Da ist ja diese Wallet.dat. Dein Bitcoin-Demon speichert ja irgendwo in Library, Application Support, Bitcoin. Da liegt eine Wallet.dat. Davon machst du erstmal ein Backup. Grundsätzlich machst du immer bei allem Shit Backup. Bei Bitcoin auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das, ob der Apple-Dings, hat er eine Command-Line mit dabei? Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Der Apple-Dings?
Na, hier das Bitcoin-QT auf Apple. Weil eigentlich dieses Salvage-Wallet ist eine Command-Line.
Aber das kannst du über Homebrew installieren, zur Not.
Ja, da gibt es glaube ich inzwischen... Ansonsten, FreeBSD, da gibt es sogar ein Port. 086 ist aktuell. Aber ich würde gleichzeitig noch empfehlen, dein Bitcoin-D, also dein Bitcoin-Programm macht ja gar nichts. Und der macht auch keine Transactions. Und ich hoffe auch deine Wallet ist gekryptet und so. Richtig. Ich würde vielleicht einfach mal gar nichts machen, noch zwei, drei Tage warten, bis die wirklich alle durchblicken und machen und tun. Und dann machst du Salvage-Wallet. Vielleicht gibt es auch noch ein Salvage-Wallet-Update, der das automatisch irgendwie wieder gerade biegt oder so. Was du halt mal gucken kannst, ist aber trotzdem, ob deine Überweisung angekommen ist.
Ja...
Und dazu guckst du nicht, ob die Transaction-ID bei Blockchain Info ist, weil das könnte eben sein, dass das nicht geht, sondern du guckst bei...
Der Zieladresse.
Bei der Zieladresse nach, ob von deiner Adresse da Geld angekommen ist. Du kannst natürlich erstmal auch nach der Transaction-ID gucken, aber wahrscheinlich wirst du denn von der, die du jetzt doppelt hast, wirst du die nicht finden.
Ja, weil...
Genau, der denkt, du hast das Geld wiederbekommen, richtig? Weil er kann halt nicht sehen, dass deine Transaction-ID, die er sich da lokal speichert, der kann jetzt halt nicht sehen, dass das Geld rausgegangen ist und denkt, das hat nicht geklappt und die wurde nicht in einen Block eingebaut. Sie wurde wahrscheinlich in einen Block eingebaut, aber mit einer anderen Transaction-ID. Und das ist das Problem. Das ist auch das, was alle... was... Deswegen, ich denke, das ist ein bisschen unfair, jetzt zu sagen, Mt. Gox ist schuld, weil da ist jetzt überhaupt hat nichts mit Mt. Gox zu tun, oder? Und das ist das viel größere Problem, als irgendwie Mt. Gox, die da ihre Transactions nicht im Griff haben, weil die können das wahrscheinlich fixen, müssen jetzt so ein paar Tage irgendwie von Hand vielleicht so ihre Logs da durchgehen und irgendwie Sachen gerade biegen, aber das da, das betrifft eher alle, solange da einer ist da draußen oder in den Pool oder wer auch immer, und irgendwie Transactions umschreibt, oder? Ja, aber ich hab's ja selber noch nicht gesehen, jetzt weiß ich da, was es ist, also die man macht eine Transaction und die kommt einfach wieder zurück, als wenn sie nicht stattgefunden hätte, richtig?
Ich kann das nicht so richtig deuten, weil ich habe ja nur eine angestoßen. Sie taucht zweimal auf, mit einem Unterschied von ungefähr eine Stunde, Minuten.
Aber beide rausgehend, oder wie?
Beide rausgehend.
Ach so, als wenn er doppelt abgebucht hätte.
Ja, nur die eine ist halt nicht bestätigt. Ich verstehe schon mal gar nicht, warum überhaupt zwei rausgehend. Es könnte halt nur sein, dass die erste halt nicht bestätigt wurde und dann hat er nochmal selber eine...
Nee, nee, der macht das nicht einfach mal nochmal. Nee, nee. Trau der Anzeige da einfach nicht mehr. Die falsche Menge wird er dir jetzt ausrechnen. Also wenn du dir jetzt guckst, wie viel Bitcoins du hast, dann wird er dir genau um diese Zahl, die du überwiesen hast, um diese Menge stimmt das halt jetzt nicht. Und trau auch dieser Zahl nicht, das stimmt gerade da alles total nicht.
Also wir fassen zusammen. Es ist schon eine leichte Erschütterung des Ökosystems zu spüren.
Sie ist nicht dramatisch, aber es ist keine, wie soll man sagen, es ist der, der das gerade umschreibt, ob es eine Tech ist oder ein Pool, der es einfach nur zu gut meint, das sorgt auf jeden Fall nicht dafür, dass Überweisungen nicht mehr dort ankommen, wo man sie hinsendet. Das ist nicht der Fall, sondern alles kommt dort an, wo es ankommen soll, aber es sieht halt nicht so aus, als wenn, und das ist das Problem. Also es ist kein Security-Problem, sondern es ist irgendwie fast ein User-Interaction-Gui-Optical- Tralala-Problem.
Na gut, jetzt stell dir mal vor, ich würde eine Banküberweisung machen und die würde mir dann halt als konnte nicht überwiesen werden.
Naja, ich sehe das ein.
Oh ja, das trabe ich schon gelegentlich. Also das ist schon so mit E-Bahn und Tralala kommt schon häufig auch vor.
Die meinen ja so Leute, dass von den zehn größten Bitcoin-Probleme, die es so gibt, wäre das nicht dabei. Ich denke schon, dass es dabei ist, weil wenn die User durcheinander kommen bei ihrem Accounting, nicht nur Mt. Gox, sondern grundsätzlich jeder User und das bei dir, ich meine, das ist jetzt eine Minisumme da irgendwie, aber es gibt Leute, die vielleicht noch ein paar mehr Bitcoins haben und dann, ich meine, die kriegen eine Herzattacken zu Hause, wenn du sie plötzlich... Andersrum ja genauso, bei Leuten, wo das Geld ankommt, die sehen das dann glaube ich doppelt, weil da meint einer, er hat irgendwie 350 Bitcoins, aber eigentlich dürfte er nur 170 haben und so und der meint, er würde sich ja freuen, wenn er 350 hätte, aber es sind ja wahrscheinlich nicht so viele und so weiter und denen wurde auch gesagt, ja, Salvage, Wallet und dann Reorganization, aber vorher erstmal warten und so. Deswegen, ich würde empfehlen, erstmal garnisch machen, abwarten.
Aber sicherstellen, dass man Backups hat.
Sicherstellen, dass man Backups hat, auch von der kaputten, das ist ja total egal. Also die alten aufheben und dann zusätzlich noch neue machen, bevor man irgendwelche Kommandos ausführt und ich denke mal, da gibt es demnächst so ein Paper, was zu tun ist, wenn, tralala und welche Version man dafür benutzen soll und was man da machen soll und vielleicht machst du die nächste Version, die rauskommt, die checkt das sogar selbst und man muss keinen Savage Wallet machen, sondern man startet, der geht da einmal durch, repariert alles und alles ist wieder im grünen Bereich. Weil so sieht nämlich auch User Support aus, so wie Fritz das irgendwie macht, indem die sich da mal hinsetzen und ich denke mal, die Core-Developer da, die machen das auch gerade und überlegen sich durch, wie können wir diese Probleme da am besten lösen, weil ich meine, die haben da ihre Milliarden und Millionen von Dollars drin, weil, kannst du mir nicht vorstellen, dass die keine Bitcoins haben, deswegen, die werden schon dafür sorgen, dass die weiterhin viel Wert haben. Ich glaube nicht, dass die gerade happy damit sind, dass dieser Kurs so abstürzt.
Nichts in der Kurs eigentlich gerade.
Die Hälfte. Fast, fast. Also bei Mt. Gox ist es fast auf die Hälfte. Von 700 auf 400 irgendwie so circa.
Da kommt gerade ein Price-Alert rein.
408. Ist noch nicht so gut. Bisher nur Verlust, gerade wieder enorm abgesunken. Naja, haben wir es.
Ja, gibt's noch was zu sagen.
Und zwar, ich habe jetzt seit einer Weile auch hier von Butterfly Labs meine Bitforce Single meiner. Das ist so ein Kasten, der machte 50 Giga-Hash und da Butterfly, ja ich will den ja nichts unterstellen, aber den besten Ruf haben die ja nicht und so weiter. Jedenfalls kamen die Geräte an, es sind vier Stück, es sind nicht alle meine. Ich habe mir jetzt mit einem Kumpel geteilt. Eine machte 37 Giga-Hash von versprochenen 50, eine machte 43 Giga-Hash, eine 47 und ein einziger machte 50 Giga-Hash. Ich habe mich dann mit meinem Kumpel irgendwie geguckt, habe ich gesagt, alles klar, ich nehme die beiden mittleren schnellen, er kriegt den ganz langsam und dafür aber auch den ganz schnellen. Hatten wir beide so ungefähr so um die 90 Giga-Hash beide Geräte zusammen. Also er 90, ich 90. Und dann hat er seine Dinge an den Start gebracht, sein 37er war dann doch nicht so schlecht und der hatte mal ein paar Giga-Hash mehr als ich. Ich dachte, das kann irgendwie nicht sein. Geht ja nicht, dass mein Kumpel schneller als ich. Na es ist wie bei Intel, die machen halt irgendwie hier ihren großen Silicon-Wafer, machen da einmal lauter Haswells und dann gucken sie, wie schnell die sind. Und meistens sind, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, die in der Mitte sind immer voll gut und die nach außen, da verzieht sich auch das Silicon irgendwie durch Kühlung oder was auch immer, die sind dann wohl nicht ganz so gut und die werden dann durchgetestet und in der Mitte werden teuer Exeons verkauft und die Äußeren gehen dann als billig, ramsch für sonst wie irgendwas raus und wenige getaktet und so.
Aber hast du für alle das gleiche bezahlt?
Ja, weil die machen das mit den Testen natürlich nicht, die hauen einfach alle Chips drauf und...
Deine Sorge, wie schnell die sind.
Ja, und die dachten ja eigentlich mal, sie verkaufen 60 Giga-Räte und das hat aber nicht gereicht, dann haben sie einfach auf 50 abgesenkt und dann ist denen sozusagen auch egal, ob da ein Chip drauf kaputt ist oder nicht, weil 50 kriegt man auf jeden Fall hin, aber diesmal war irgendwie so schlecht, dass es halt gar nicht ging. Ist egal. Jedenfalls habe ich geforscht und gesucht und gemacht und getan und habe rausgefunden, weil die ganze Kiste wird von einem Atmel AVR32 gemanagt. Also es ist ja auch so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller-Prozessor, der so alles, weißt schon, so ein Atmel halt. Und da hat die Butterfly-Firma den Sourcecode dafür freigegeben. Das heißt, du kannst dir den Sourcecode hier bei GitHub runterladen, GitHub, Bitforce, SC, Single oder SC, und irgendwie den Atmel Studio auf Windows, kannst du den Sourcecode holen, kannst den bauen. Und wenn du einen Atmel von einem AVR Dragon hast, so ein kleines Programmierer-Bot, was ich eh schon hatte, und das passende Kabel hatte ich auch alles schon, habe ich einfach die Kiste aufgemacht von Butterfly, habe meinen JTAG-Kabel da herangeschlossen, habe die neue Software reingeschoben, ohne erstmal was zu ändern. Man will erstmal sehen, ob es geht. Und Chakra hat funktioniert. Ich dachte, boah, geil. Na, die neue Software.
Also es lief auch weiterhin, aber nicht schneller.
Lief weiterhin, aber diesmal, ich musste vorher halt den AV erlöschen, weil der war lesegeschützt. Man konnte nicht auslesen, welche Software schon drauf war. Weil die schreiben da schon rein, alles klar, folgender Chip ist kaputt und schalten den in der Software schon aus. Die machen da einmal so einen Test am Anfang und bestimmte, also da sind in diesen riesen Kasten sind zweimal acht Chips und jeder Chip hat 16 Engines. Also insgesamt 16 mal 16 Engines, 256 Engines. Jeder Engine macht 240 Megasch, irgendwie so. Ungefähr 50 bis 60 Gigasch. So und alle, die nicht gehen, machen die schon aus, machen da so ein Mapping und die Software schreiben sie dann rein, damit das nicht getestet werden muss und so weiter und das keinen Strom verbraucht.
Dann kam deine Software an und hat gesagt, irgendwie hier geht erstmal alles.
Dieser Software ist so ein Test, der das am Anfang auch durchcheckt, werden welche Chips dann auch noch irgendwie ausgeschaltet werden sollen. Den Test habe ich ausgemacht, also weil das so ein Typ das auch schon so geschrieben hat. Und siehe da, der startet einfach erstmal mit allen Chips. Natürlich habe ich jetzt auch beeinten, dieser beiden Kisten geht ein Chip, geht so gar nicht. Nummer fünf immer, der Nummer fünf lebt nämlich nicht bei mir.
Nummer fünf stirbt.
Ja, nee, es war schon tot und war immer tot. Aber vorher hat er mir gesagt, Nummer neun wäre auch tot, nachdem ich dann die neue Software reingeschrieben habe und habe das Ding gestartet. Jetzt geht irgendwie komplett alles. Und was sie auch bei Butterfly gemacht haben, sie haben einen von meinen Minern, haben sie mit 292 MHz getaktet und der hatte 7 Prozent Fehler. Man kann ja sich alles schön statistisch-mäßig angucken und so. Da habe ich gedacht, naja, wenn man so hoch taktet, weil der ist höher getaktet als der, der besser lief, dann takte ich den jetzt einfach auch mal runter und siehe da, hat beide ein bisschen weniger getaktet und beide erst mal grundsätzlich alles eingeschaltet und alle Engines, die nach 300 mal probieren kein richtiges Ergebnis liefern, die werden dann auch nachträglich noch ausgeschaltet, damit die keinen Strom verbrauchen. Und jetzt habe ich einmal 50 Giga-Hash und einmal 51 Giga-Hash und jetzt läuft alles wie Buddha.
Und vorher hat es so?
90, 88, irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Also insgesamt hast du über 100 sozusagen.
Insgesamt habe ich jetzt 101,8.
Also du hast 10% rausgeholt sozusagen.
101,8 habe ich gerade.
10% rausgeholt.
Ja, ein bisschen mehr, noch 12, 13 würde ich sagen.
Ist ja bares Geld.
Eigentlich schon, ja. Nicht ganz, weil es kostet jetzt natürlich auch mehr Strom, weil die bleiben jetzt an und Stromverbrauch ist natürlich dann auch von 380 auf 400 Watt gestiegen und so. Aber grundsätzlich, wer Bock hat, weil mal ehrlich, die Dinger sind eh nichts mehr wert, die bringen irgendwie noch 5 Euro am Tag oder was?
Mit was für einem Strom fährst du eigentlich deine Bitcoins? Sind das ökologische Bitcoins oder ist das so Atomschmuck?
Nee, ich hab den schon vor Jahren, weil ich bin ja eigentlich auch, also eigentlich bin ich ja keine Ökosau, aber irgendwie dann doch. Jedenfalls, ich habe Ökostrom zu Hause. Also ich bin ja voll der Verschwender, aber ich verschwende Sonne. Ich bin bei Lichtblatt, kann ich nur sagen. Also finde ich gut. Auch wenn es nur noch auf dem Papier ist, weil inzwischen gibt es ja so viel Öko-Zeugs, das ist ja schon, also und so weiter, aber vielleicht hat es ja was gemacht.
Keine Ahnung. Das Streaming hier übrigens auch, alles komplett.
Das erklärt einiges.
Deswegen wird das Licht auch hier immer heller und dunkler. Aber warum da noch keine LED-Lampe da oben drin ist, kann ich ja nicht so nachvollziehen.
Was ist denn da gerade drin?
Da ist eine Halogen drin, immerhin, aber Halogen spart ja nur so ein bisschen, so LED spart ja mal so richtig.
Aber LED macht ja scheiß Licht.
Nee, inzwischen nicht mehr.
Nein, geht inzwischen.
Es geht, aber es ist immer noch scheiß Licht.
Ja, aber ich hab die eingesetzt, als es noch nicht ging.
Also ich finde, das geht auch immer noch nicht. Also außer die richtig teuren LED-Lampen, wo die eine 40 Euro kostet.
Die kosten 10 Euro, haben einen Color-Rate-Index von 85 und es ist warm, kannst du gar nicht unterscheiden. Kannst du gerne nachher zu mir zu Hause gucken kommen.
Ich kann das unterscheiden. Mach ich einmal ein Foto mit meinem Telefon und dann sehen wir das sofort.
Gut, ich glaube, das Bitcoin-Thema, das haben wir jetzt auch erschöpft und behandelt, oder?
Muss ich denn jetzt hier raus aus der Red Group?
Wie ist denn der Wasserstand hier in unserer Internetversorgung gerade?
Momentan haben wir gerade mal was. Dir wird gelegentlich die PPPoE-Verbindung entzogen. So alle halbe Stunde mal.
Von außen? Vor 12 Minuten.
Aber die DSL, also die Modulation auf deiner Leitung, zum DSLAM, ist stabil. Also daran liegt es nicht. Sondern da wird das PPPoE weggezogen.
Was ist deine Vermutung?
Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht gefällt dir Telekom dein Programm nicht. Oder hier hat jemand schon gemutmaßet, dass die GCHQ jetzt gerade mal die Platten austauschen muss, weil die voll sind. Und derweil drücken sie halt auf die Pause-Taste. Jetzt zum Beispiel ist gerade das Netz wieder weg. Jetzt. Kommt aber gleich wieder. Ist immer dasselbe. Siehst du dann irgendwie PPP-Verbindung, wie Timeout und dann kommt der dann gleich wieder. Aber ich kann mich währenddessen mit deiner Fritzbox unterhalten.
Wenn wir zumindest V6-Connectivity für den Stream hätten, dann kriegen wir jedes Mal wieder ein neuer App.
Nein, deine V6-Connectivität geht ja noch über V4-Connectivität, der eher einen Six-Tunnel benutzt. Du hast ja keinen Native V6. Das heißt, wenn dann V4 weg ist, ist auch dein V6 weg.
Nein, es ist weg, aber danach wäre es zumindest noch dieselbe Source-Adresse.
Aber der Ausfall dauert dann immer.
Kriegen wir am laufenden Meter neue V4-Adressen gerade?
Ja.
Dann ist halt nichts mehr zu retten.
Richtig. Du hast aber immer so ungefähr 30 Sekunden, 35 Sekunden Ausfall, wenn dann. Und das kann sein, dass du dir auch schon den TCP-Dings zerknackst. Je nachdem, wie die so keep alive sind.
Welche sind in deiner Meinung nach die tollen LED-Lampen?
Für zu Hause? Na, ich habe hier so eine Osram-Dinger.
Ja, habe ich natürlich auch verbaut. Sieht auch echt aus.
Kosten glaube ich, keine Ahnung, zwischen 11 und 13 Euro oder so. Machen, verbrauchen 10 Watt und sind so hell wie eine 60 Watt Lampe und haben so einen Colour-Rate-Index von 80.
Na, das ist ja schlecht.
Colour-Rate-Index?
Also irgendwie...
Der Ästhet in dir, ja?
Nee, also ich merke das halt schon. Ich habe zu Hause noch alle Arten von Lampen. Ich habe irgendwie so eine Energiespar-Schlumpflampe.
So eine Ringe?
Energiespar-Lampen, da gehe ich dir recht, die sind einfach sehr in Kacke aus. Und vor allem sind die auch viel zu langsam, bis die an sind. Das dauert ja auch irgendwie eine Weile und so weiter und so fort.
Da habe ich irgendwie im Flur, da brennt noch eine schöne alte 60 Watt Glühbirne.
Die auch instantan an ist, voll geil.
Im Bad auch, ja. Und dann habe ich in dem einen Zimmer so eine relativ moderne, ich glaube eine Phillips-LED. Und die mache ich einfach jetzt nie mehr an, weil da kriege ich auch, die ist halt zu kalt und so. Die ist halt so ein richtig hässliches Licht. Wahrscheinlich, das Spektrum von dem habe ich mir jetzt noch nicht irgendwo mal ausgemessen, aber die sieht schon, das sieht einfach nicht gut aus. Und da habe ich mir eine richtig teure gekauft, wo sie damit geworben haben, dass sie jetzt so Tageslichtspektrum haben. Vollspektrum LED-Lampe, was mir schon Leute gesagt haben, dass das Quatsch sind, die sich tatsächlich an Universitäten mit genau dem Thema beschäftigen, nämlich so ordentliches Licht aus LED-Lampen. Und die meinten, also die Forschung, die ist jetzt vielleicht langsam so weit, dass wir das wirklich hinkriegen, aber auf dem Markt gibt es das noch nicht. Und alle, die sagen, dass sie es hätten, ist irgendwie auch geflunkert. Aber die, die ich gekauft habe, die ist von diesem Farbwiedergabeindex. Also der Test ist halt, man nimmt irgendwie ein iPhone, wenn es draußen dunkel ist und dann wirklich nur noch die Birne den Raum beleuchtet. Und dann kann man sich mal irgendwie so irgendwas Buntes dahin stellen, das fotografieren. Mit der Energiesparlamp ist dann alles so rot und so krisselig und ganz furchtbar. Und wenn du halt so eine schöne Vollspektrum-Lampe hast, dann sieht das halt aus wie am Tag sozusagen aufgenommen. Muss ich gleich nochmal gucken, warte mal. Was war das, Philips? Ja, die Philips, ich habe eine ganz alte, also eine nicht so tolle Philips. Mittlerweile baut Philips wohl angeblich auch welche mit hohem Farbwiedergabeindex, aber die habe ich noch nicht getestet. Also die würde ich gar nicht erst erwähnen. Warte mal, ich gucke mal bei Amazon in meiner Bestellliste. Und also die macht, die, die ich jetzt gekauft habe, die teure, um das mal auszuprobieren, die macht geiles Licht, aber die ist halt zu schwach auf der Brust. Also die, davon bräuchte ich irgendwie drei um den Raum einigermaßen hell zu kriegen. Deswegen, also ich, nach dieser, ich habe mir ja natürlich, wie das so nerdüblich ist, habe ich mich dann auch Stunden und Tage und so damit beschäftigt und, und alle möglichen Artikel gelesen und alle möglichen Hersteller, Webseiten und alles Mögliche. Und hier, das ist die Lampe, die ich gekauft habe. Warte mal, ohne diesen Hinter, gleich einen Erfehlt, Link, Paste, nein, Quatsch. Hier, da, Live-Lite heißen die. Ja, die haben auch, ja derzeit sind die jetzt auch wieder nicht verfügbar, die ist auch, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das auch empfehlen könnte letztendlich. Das war halt mal so ein Versuch, weil die halt jetzt so schön damit geworben haben. Aber wie gesagt, die macht halt Licht für 45 Watt und...
Das ist ein bisschen zu wenig, meinst du?
Das muss ich auch nicht gucken. Ja, also deswegen, ich bin von diesen LED-Lampen noch nicht überzeugt. Meine Glühbirnen, ich habe gesehen, bei Bauhaus, da gibt es jetzt auch immer noch so die polnischen 100 MBit-Lampen und so. 100 MBit sei ich schon, 100 Watt. Ich bin gerade so ein bisschen in die geile 100 MBit-Lampe.
Du meinst die Heizung?
Nee, also irgendwie, es gibt echt im Baumarkt, jetzt gerade noch 100 Watt Glühbirnen zu kaufen.
Ja, aber es gibt ja, wie Tim auch hier schon hat, es gibt ja auch Halogen-Glühbirnen.
Die kriegen aber den nächsten auch raus, diese Dinger.
Die gibt es jetzt gerade noch, die sind sparsamer als Glühärmel und Halogen hat ja eigentlich auch eine schicke Farbe.
Aber, genauso wie die Energiesparlampen, wo Quecksilber drin ist, was halt scheiße ist, ist ja bei Halogen, das ist ja genau so.
Was ist da dran jetzt schlimm?
Ist auch giftig. Soll man auch nicht, wenn die kaputt geht, soll man da nicht gleich irgendwie mit der Nase drüber gehen.
Da müssen aber irgendwelche Metalle oder so, Halogen, ne.
Oder irgendwas ist da drin, also ich weiß nicht, ob es Quecksilber war oder was sind die Neonröhren?
Das ist Edelgas, da passiert nichts.
Irgendwas war da. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau. Aber auf jeden Fall bei den Energiesparlampen ist ja das Problem, dass da das Quecksilber noch mit drin ist.
Bei Energiesparlampen hier, diese alten Dinger, die sind doch wirklich scheiße, weil die brauchen ewig, bis die an sind, das Licht sieht scheiße aus. Und wenn man dann wieder an der Glüh... Also mir ist meine Sparlampe kaputt gegangen und hab wieder eine normale Glühlampe reingemacht und so das erste Mal, wo ich den Scheiter mache, und es sofort an ist, also sofort, so boah, ist das gar nicht wilde zu haben. Dann hab ich gedacht, okay, wenn die LEDs das jetzt auch können, mit dem sofort an, dann hol ich mir die, hab ich meine ganze Bude ausgestattet. Aber die sind halt auch nicht sofort an. Die brauchen so eine Zehntel- oder Zwanzigstel-Sekunde. Das ist so eine leichte Verzögerung. Und jedes Mal denkt mein Gehirn noch ganz kurz, warum geht das jetzt nicht an? Und dann ist es aber, bevor ich zu Ende denke, kann es schon.
Aber die ändern nicht noch mal nachträglich ihre Farbe, wie manche für diese Energiespar-Dinge.
Aber, was auch geil ist, ein Kollege von mir hat sich so günstige Energiesparlampen irgendwo bestellt. Also LEDs. Und wenn die zu heiß werden, dann schalten die sich einfach ab. Nee, die gehen einfach ganz aus, so von alleine, weil irgendwie der Controller da drin, sagt irgendwie, äh, nee, danke. Mal kurz abkühlen.
Ja, aber heiß werden. Ich habe jetzt hier eine verbaut, die siehst du ja gerade auf dem Bild, die Hörer zum Glück nicht. So ein 4 Watt-Ding, ja, aus dem Baumarkt von Ostrahm. So eine Kerze, ja. Also gerade so in diesem, was du so gerne als Nachttischlampe haben willst. Also nicht so Scheinwerfer, Fett, ja, sondern so ein bisschen. Und das hat eigentlich eine recht ordentliche Farbe. Und wie gesagt, für 4 Watt kann man da nicht maulen. Das hat angeblich dann einen Output, also entspricht sozusagen, keine Ahnung, 140 oder 60 Watt Lampe oder so.
Können Sie an so einem Bild schon sehen, ob das gute oder schlechte Licht ist?
Das sieht doch schon mal ganz okay aus.
Das sieht schon relativ gut aus.
Ja, das ist auch eine LED-Lampe schon.
Das geht schon.
Also, was für mich ja hier, warum ich mich hier auch noch nicht weiter betätigt habe, ich wollte halt hier als nächstes mal eine DIMM-Lösung haben.
Und ein Lampe anbauen, dann flackert das hier so. Beim Zuckerschütten und so, dann ruckelt das Zuckerschütten.
Das ist die Frage, ob es flackert.
Selten sind die immer so gut, dass wir nicht flackern.
Das finde ich sehr interessant. Ich habe mit dem iPhone 5S mal neulich mal Aufnahmen gemacht, bei so einem Tanzworkshop, in diesem Slow-Mo-Modus, der eigentlich echt ganz cool ist, den man ganz gut gebrauchen kann. Und ich habe das schon mehrfach gemacht, ohne Probleme. Diesmal hatte ich ein ganz fieses Flackern drauf. Und habe dann festgestellt, ah, okay, das iPhone erkennt normalerweise diese typische 50-Hertz-Flackern oder 60-Hertz-Flackern, je nachdem, wo du bist auf der Welt, und blendet das aus. Nur in diesem Tanzstudio hatten die mehrere Schleimwerfergruppen an verschiedenen Phasen dran. Und da hat dann das iPhone einfach keine Chance mehr gehabt, welche Flacker nicht nur wegrechnet. Das jeweils andere hat dann immer noch geflackert. Und das war gut.
Mit welcher Frequenz arbeiten denn diese LED?
Ja, mit Netzfrequenz.
Aber es gibt halt auch zum Beispiel...
Die transformieren die doch hoch.
Die Frequenz transformieren die nicht hoch.
Für die LED müsst ihr doch gleich Strom machen.
Sonst geht das dann nicht.
Die können das dann nicht mehr so wie bei der Glühlampe einfach so hin und her ballern. Sondern da müssen die ja noch was tun.
Da wird halt fürs LED-Dimm halt zum Beispiel so einfach an-aus nur sehr schnell. Und je nachdem wie hoch der Prozentsatz ist von an zu aus, ist er halt heller oder dunkler. Und wenn du das in einer sehr niedrigen Frequenz machst...
Das nennt man den Duty-Cycle.
Genau, den Duty-Cycle. Und wenn du das nicht ordentlich machst, dann flackert es halt. Und das weißt du schon, hier dieser Effekt, du machst so. Und dann siehst du hier deine Finger so, oder der Stroboskop-Effekt und so.
Vielleicht denke ich gerade falsch. Also ich meine, wird der Wechselstrom noch in Gleichstrom gewandelt? Muss er doch, oder?
Man kann jetzt einfach immer nur den positiven Teil durchlassen und den negativen weglassen. So würde es ja auch gehen.
Aber das heißt, ohnehin ist da Elektronik am Start.
Im Sockel von dem Ding ist eine Unik drin.
Wenn du jetzt einen normalen Dimmer hast, der ja im Prinzip...
Es gibt ja zwei normale Dimmer. Es gibt ja einen Phasenanschnitts-Dimmer und einen Phasenabschnitts-Dimmer.
Also irgendwie schneidet er diese Sinus-Kurve an oder ab. Sodass da Pausen entstehen, was bei einer normalen Glühlampe kein Problem ist, weil die leuchtet dann einfach nach. Aber insgesamt kriegt sie weniger Energie. Wenn da jetzt eine Elektronik dran ist, die für eine LED versucht, ihre Welt zu übersetzen, dann kann sie ja das eigentlich auch dekodieren und quasi so den Energiewunsch, den Helligkeitswunsch daraus ablesen.
Das Problem ist ja alt. Es gibt ja schon seit nicht nur gestern, gibt ja diese berühmten Halo-Dinger, die die Leute haben, mit so einem Trafo. Als man das zuerst gebaut hat, haben sie einen schönen fetten Wickel Kupfer-Trafos, die ja an die Decke gehängt oder so, die richtig teuren, schweren. Seitdem aber die Menschheit erkannt hat, dass Kupfer teuer ist, und zwar richtig teuer und inzwischen die Elektronik billiger ist, wird dafür seit Jahren ein elektronisches Trafos eingesetzt. Und die zum Beispiel, die kannst du mit einem Phasenanschnittstimmer, kannst du die nicht anficken, das finden die gar nicht toll. Die brauchen einen Phasenabschnittstimmer. Also du musst wirklich gucken, was du für einen Last hast. Hast du eine sogenannte obenste Last, wie zum Beispiel eine Glühlampe, die sich sozusagen richtig neutral verhält und da nichts macht, weil da nur der scheiß Glühfaden ist, der dann eben an oder raus ist, aber sonst nichts macht, keine Induktivität drin, die da irgendwie was zurück spielt oder so. Dann kannst du das mit einem Phasen an- oder Abschnittstimmer dimmen, dann ist das wurscht. Sobald du da Kapazitäten drin hast, oder Induktivitäten gerade, also zum Beispiel Spulen, Trafos oder sonst irgendwas, kannst du da nicht einfach so rumdimmen, wie du willst. Und wenn du elektronische Trafos hast, dann erst recht nicht. Weil das ist das selbe Prinzip zu dem elektronischen Trafo, wie dein Schaltnetzteil, was du in deinem Rechner drin hast. Und die können höchstens damit ab, dass man ihnen sozusagen ab der fallenden Flanke ein bisschen was klaut. Aber wenn du ab der steigenden Flanke was tust, was er nämlich selber auch gerne tun würde, das macht er nämlich sonst, dann kommt er völlig aus dem Tritt. Da könnte man jetzt drei Stunden drüber drüber ziehen, das ist ein relativ komplexes Thema, aber das wollen wir gar nicht. Aber unterschiedliche Dimmer und unterschiedliche Lasten.
Ja, also das ist halt sozusagen da eine bestimmte Kombination von Dimmer zu LED-Glühbirne oder LED-Glühbirne.
Die Verkaufene, die LED-Lampen jetzt auch als dimmbar, und ich denke mal, das schreiben wir ja deswegen so hin, weil das heißt, die kommen mit den normalen Dimmern, die man vorher auch schon benutzt hat, klar.
Ja, aber habt ihr schon mal irgendwie eine Dimmer-Kombination zum Einsatz gebracht?
Ich dimme keine Lichter.
Ich kann es gerne ausprobieren.
Also was ich ja gerne hier hätte, wäre so eine Lampe, die sowohl Tageslicht als auch Warmlicht-Programme kann. Na ja, die, was weiß ich.
Und die eine IPv6 hat auch.
Dann brauchst du zwei Fassungen, weil es gibt keine, die beides wirklich gut kann.
Was ist denn mit dieser Philips Hue, oder wie sie heißt, diese Steuerbar und so weiter?
Ich würde auch zwei Fassungen reinmachen, das ist nicht so das Problem. Es muss halt nur beides parallel dann irgendwie auch umgeschaltet, weiß nicht, ich könnte mir hier, naja, Doppelschalter, Dimmer, Kombinationen gibt es wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Also diese Philips Hue, die sind auch ganz großer Scheiß, wenn es so um Lichtqualität, sagen wir mal, geht, wenn man jetzt eher...
Ach du meinst jetzt diese WLAN-Lampen oder was?
Ja, aber es gibt von Philips halt auch so Lampen, die, also ich meine, es muss jetzt halt nicht Vollspektrum sein, und Tageslicht ist sowieso als Lampe eigentlich Quatsch, aber sozusagen zumindest, das Problem ist ja bei den LED-Lampen ganz lange gewesen, dass die halt so im Rot, Grün und Blau einfach nur so fiese Spikes drin hatten und dazwischen halt nix. Und dementsprechend, also wie gesagt, wenn du halt ein Foto gemacht hast, dann hast du das auch gesehen, weil das Bild einfach total irgendwie räudig aussieht, weil irgendwie dann im Spektrum fehlt. Und deswegen haben die so einen niedrigen Farbreproduktionsindex, bla, bla, bla. Und jetzt sozusagen die ganz neuen, zum Beispiel Philips gibt's ja jetzt auch, so irgendwie ganz neue, tolle Modelle. Die sehen aus wie irgendwie so ein Alien-Penis oder so.
Alien-Penis? Philips, guck dir das an, wirklich.
Die sehen aus wie, also die sehen wirklich unmöglich aus. Da willst du den Lampenschirm drum herum machen, weil das überhaupt nicht geht. Warte mal, wo sind die hier? Die sind auch immer sehr schwierig zu finden auf ihrer Seite. Und die haben einen relativ guten, angeblich relativ gutes Dingsbums hier. Produkte, Körperpflege, Haushaltsgeräte, Beleuchtung. So, LED-Lampen. Und die hatten sie auch bisher nur auf der USA-Seite. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie die jetzt mittlerweile schon, nee, haben sie immer noch nicht. Warte mal, ich muss das mal woanders suchen. Das ist schon seit 10 Minuten ein stabiles Stream.
Soll ich nochmal GCHQ sagen?
Warte mal, philips.com geh ich mal. Komischerweise hatten sie die nämlich nicht. Oder gibt es die bei Amazon schon?
Nö, ist schon wieder vorbei. Ist kein Witz, Tim. Jetzt ist er wieder da.
Das ist Philips, die bei den zwei Filmen gleichzeitig.
Komm, wo sind die? Oder gibt es die jetzt nicht mehr von Philips? Ja, warte, haben wir gleich.
Da ist er wieder.
Die Alien-Lampen.
An wen können wir uns jetzt mal wenden? Telekom?
An das Internet-Komitee ruf doch mal deine...
Den Verkehrsminister, Herr Dobrindt.
FaceTime-Call geht jetzt auch nicht.
Wenn der in Berlin ist, den lassen wir sofort hierher zitieren.
Ja, wir zitieren den Botschafter.
Genau, jetzt zitieren wir den Botschafter.
Also, ich packe es in den Chat, der jetzt bestimmt auch schon wieder geht. Doch, hier, guck mal da. Oh, gerade Reconnect. Doch, jetzt irgendwie, nee. Warte, ich mache hier... Airplay geht auch nicht.
Ich habe ja aber Chats, die stabil sind und auch keine Reconnects benötigen.
Also, ich hätte ja noch die Möglichkeit...
Ja, weil wenn man nur so 7-8 Sekunden aus Autodesarm das hält dein TCP-Socket durch.
Ich könnte ja hier noch Kabel-Fernsehen-Internet noch reinholen von so einem Prolo-Provider hier.
Kabel Deutschland, oder?
Nee, nicht Kabel Deutschland, Prolo.
Scheiße, die waren bei mir letztendlich auch. Ja genau, ich habe immer die Zettel von der Wand weggerissen und so und dann haben die auch den ganzen Tag geklingelt. Dann habe ich meinen Nachbar gefragt, was jetzt los war, meinte er, nee, hat die natürlich auch nicht reingelassen, weil die können einem ja gar nichts. Die hängen einfach Zettel rein und sagen, die bauen dir da alles um und wahrscheinlich ist nicht mal was mit der Hausverwaltung oder mit wem auch immer abgesprochen. Und, ja, nee, geh da nicht hin.
Alles Verbrecher. Jetzt habe ich meinen Rechner hier irgendwie gezieltet, weil ich auf Blackmagic connectet habe und jetzt habe ich hier Blackmagic.
Du bist schwarz.
Ich bin schwarz mit einem weißen Pixelmagnet.
Ja, ich meine, ist da scheißegal. Ich würde mir halt einfach so das minimale Internet-Paket, was sie da irgendwie haben, klicken, einfach nur für solche Fälle.
Also willst du dann auch DS Lite haben, ja?
Ich will das alles nicht haben.
Das ist doch alles Hühnerkacke. Wir gehen hier aufs Dach und machen ordentlichen Richtfunklink irgendwo hin.
Muss man das umschalten, wenn man das Airplay macht?
Ist das jetzt eigentlich deine Fritzbox am DSL?
Ja, aber die ist gerade happy in dieser Sekunde.
Ich dachte, das PPP-OE stirbt noch mal.
Im Moment ist sie gerade happy. Was möchtest du jetzt machen?
Ich habe jetzt hier einen schwarzen Screen. Ich bin zur Black Magic-Connection und ich habe einen großen Mauskasten.
Was erwartet du? So ein weißer Punkt, dass dein Bildschirm kaputt ist?
Es geht alles kaputt. Ich komme jetzt auch nicht mehr aus diesem... Ach so, ich könnte mal meinen Kabel ziehen. Vielleicht.
Haben wir eigentlich noch ein Thema gerade?
Wir waren bei diesen LED-Lampen. Ich wollte eigentlich das hier gerade präsentieren. Jetzt ist mein Rechner weg. Gehe wieder zurück in deinen Screen. Such bei amazon.com nach der Philips-Lampe. Ich boote in der Zwischenzeit.
Sag mir doch endlich mal, wie die Scheißnummer heißt.
Such einfach nach Philips LED auf amazon.com. Scroll einen halben Meter runter.
Es gibt Leute, die behaupten, dass jedes Mal der Stream zusammenbricht, wenn ich GCHQ sage.
Tja, ich muss echt neu booten.
Noch geht er.
So, scroll mal ein Stück runter. Noch weiter, noch weiter, noch weiter, noch weiter, noch weiter, noch weiter. Und jetzt noch die nächste Seite. Die neueren Modelle sehen schon ein bisschen besser aus. Jetzt müsste gleich noch der Alien, das Alien Glied. Na, was kommt, wo ist das in? Hatte ich es gerade bei amazon.com? Nee, amazon.com sollst du doch suchen.
Nicht de...
Ja, nee, da gibt es... In Deutschland gibt es die neuen noch nicht von Philips. Also diese Alien-LEDs gibt es da nicht.
Wie so üblich gibt es diverse Hersteller, die ihre Produkte aus wat wies ik vergründen, in anderen Ländern anders nennen.
Nee, ja, oder erst da releasen, weil vielleicht gibt es hier Regularien. Ja, da, da, dieses Glubschi da, dieses...
80 Dollar!
Und jetzt ist mein Rechner gleich nochmal rebooted.
Ey, das Netzchen aussieht da wirklich ein bisschen schräg aus.
Das willst du dir ja nicht in so eine Schreibtischlampe reinschrauben.
Die ist gelb.
Ja, und genau die Tricks sind halt so rum mit der Farbfarbe, dass sie sozusagen jetzt nochmal einen farbigen Schirm drumrum knallen, damit es halt nicht zu...
22 Watt? Ist doch uralt, oder nicht? Wie viel Lumen steht da? 1780, okay.
Das ist nicht so wenig.
Das ist halt das Ding, weil die meisten LED-Lampen auch nicht ordentlich hell machen und die brät halt dann gleich richtig wie eine 100 Watt-LED-Lampe angeblich. 100 Mbit-Lampe. Naja, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, das mit den LED-Lampen, das sitze ich jetzt noch so ein, zwei Jahre aus und hoffe, dass dann weitere Fortschritte erreicht wurden.
Das ist das Thema, das setzt sich nicht durch.
Na, vielleicht doch irgendwann, aber noch bin ich damit unzufrieden. Naja, gut, also so viel zum Thema LED-Lampen. Ja, ich will eine Glühbirne. Das war so schön.
Naja, aber es war auch irgendwie nicht das richtige Farbspektrum.
Und heiß, immer. Und immer heiß.
Na, ich hätte schon Bock auf so Tageslicht und die einzige Möglichkeit, das hinzubekommen, also die effizienten...
Diese Philips Lichtduschen halt, die sind richtig gut.
Na, Leuchtschafröhren, damit kriegst du das halt alles gemixt, dann machst du einfach die richtige Gasmischung rein und Lampe an und fertig ist das. Das kann man auch relativ gut austauschen. Das Problem ist nur, wenn du halt eine Leuchtschafröhre als Arbeitslicht haben willst, dann brauchst du definitiv auch ein elektronisches Vorschaltgerät und diese EVGs sind sehr teuer. Das heißt, wenn du wirklich, also, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr ganz genau, was die jetzt kosten, aber es ist halt jetzt nicht so wie ohne Vorschaltgerät. Dann musst du schon nochmal irgendwie so 50 Euro oder 100 Euro extra einplanen. Zumindest last timer checked, ich weiß nicht, ich hab das nicht so richtig im Blick. Dann kannst du das aber schon machen. Jetzt sind natürlich Leuchtschafröhre auch immer nicht so schön, ohne weiteres integrierbar. Ich meine, wie würde ich das hier ins Studio machen? Dann willst du irgendwie indirekt haben, Pipa-Po.
Ja, hier, zum Beispiel hinter deinem großen Poster oben auf die Kante, so kurz da runter, dass es so schön an die Wand hochleuchtet.
Ja, das ist natürlich was, aber dann willst du vielleicht auch mal hier irgendwie das so gleichmäßig überall haben, dann denkst du über ganz viele nach.
Deswegen indirekt das Licht.
Ja, und dann hast du aber dann irgendwie auch mal eben so 4, 5, 6, 7 verschiedene Leuchtschafröhren. Dann willst du vielleicht auch eine Mischung haben zwischen warmweiß und Tageslicht weiß. Also wir würden jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Situation mit, ich hatte hier irgendwann mal so ein helles Licht drin und da bist du glaube ich durchgedreht.
Ich hätte jetzt hier gerne San Francisco Sonnenuntergang oder so, dass man das so einstellen kann. So vom Farbspektrum her.
Ja eigentlich, wenn man so LED-Sroy so im Sack kauft in den Baumarkt, so Kilo-LED, dann schmeißt du das irgendwo so an die Wand. Ja, hat alles seine V6-Adresse und dann strömst du da mit 800, 211, xxx. Ja, also so das WLAN, was wir so in 20 Jahren haben, wo Bluetooth 4.0 als Energiefresser durchgeht, so. Wo nur noch so Atomstößchen, so kleine Elektronenpulse rausgegeben werden und dann fangen die Dinge manisch an zu glühen. Aber genau in der Lichtabstimmung und jedes Teil hat so ein anderes Farbspektrum und dadurch, dass du halt so Tausende ansteuerst, kannst du das halt dann einfach mischen.
Blinkenlites.
Mission possible.
Das ist dann schon beyond Blinkenlites.
Ich hab ja dieses große, weißt schon, was die auch bei GateFive und so früher hatten, diese großen Phillips-Eier, die Frank auch immer noch hat. Da hab ich ja auch eins davon zu Hause. Das kostet ja auch irgendwie stolz 199 Euro, glaube ich, immer noch.
990 Euro?
199?
Für so ein Mann-Solarium?
Wenn ich mal so irgendwas fotografieren will zu Hause, oder ein Video, oder was auch immer, nehme ich immer die, wenn draußen schon kein Tageslicht mehr ist, weil damit kriegst du halt so echt geile Farben noch.
Ja gut, für so die eBay-Session mag das ganz hilfreich sein.
Oder morgens zum Wachwerden ist auch ganz gut.
Also so Lichtgestaltung in Büroräumen ist ohnehin ein Thema für sich. Ich hab hier auch echte Schwierigkeiten da, auch nur den richtigen Ansatz zu finden. Also was nimmst du?
Nimmst du Röhren?
Nimmst du Sträler?
Mit der Beleuchtung. Wir sind froh. Wird wir jetzt hier schon alles erdullen müssen wegen deiner Audiomoney? Stell dir mal vor, du hättest noch deine Videomoney hier. Dann würden wir jedes Mal geschminkt werden draußen mit dem speziellen 4K-HD-Make-up. Damit auch die Videobilder schön aussehen.
Wir müssen uns beide rasieren.
Das kommt noch erschwind hinzu. Nicht nur wir beide. Eigentlich können wir alle rascheln.
Ich bin gerade ein bisschen unzivilisiert.
Sind wir alle. Das ist das Schöne am Podcasting. Man kann auch wirklich in so einer Unterhose sitzen oder nackt podcasten.
Hast du damit Heugi schon gemacht?
Nach dieser Black Magic Nummer habe ich hier kein Netz mehr.
Momentan netzt das gerade.
Bei mir ist jetzt so richtig, gerade Ethernet, WLAN, tot. Einfach.
Dein Rechner ist auch irgendwie...
Aber nach diesem Black Magic Connect, schwarzes Green, großer Cursor, ist jetzt hier gerade komplett Netz.
Einmal Apple TV, nie mehr Netz.
Unsere Gelegenheit, mal ein neues Thema zu finden.
Ja, mein neuer Rechner.
Wovor wir gerade über Apple TV reden? Ich wollte mal kurz in die Apple-Gerüchtetücher reingehen, weil wir sonst nicht so viel darüber reden. Habt ihr das gehört?
Könnt ihr mal über Max reden?
Neues Apple TV soll ja kommen. Ja, es ist in so einem iOS 7, 7.1-Developer...
Moment, ein neuer Hardware oder eine neue Firmware?
Eine neue Hardware steht an. Das ist jetzt aus dem Kaffeesatz gelesen. Der Kaffeesatz sind diese Gerätestrings, die sich so in der OS-10-Software finden. Weißt du, so die Kennung. Da ist von einem Apple TV 4,1 die Rede. Und deshalb bei 3,2 oder so.
Mich wundertet echt, warum die Apple-Fuzzies nicht schon seit Jahren einfach mal in welche Geräte-IDs in irgendwelche Betasoftware reinschmeißen, nur um zu sehen, wie sich die Leute bei MacRumors und bei den ganzen Webseiten ein runterholen.
Vielleicht tun sie das ja auch.
Ja, weiß man nicht, ne?
Ja, sie haben ja ganz lustig, sie haben ja auch noch dieses iProt. Es gibt iProt, wo sie auch alle lange drüber siniert haben. Und iProt nehmen sie immer dann, oder haben sie genommen, das glaube ich iProt war damals das iPad. Also im Sinne von iProduct, so nach dem Motto.
Aber wir sagen euch nicht, wie es heißt.
Nein, wir sagen euch nicht, wie es heißt. Und dafür haben sie dann halt diesen Stream benutzt. Oder war es auch das iPhone? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr ganz genau. Ich glaube, es war das iPad. Naja, wie auch immer. Und sehr viel mehr steht da jetzt eigentlich auch nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das jetzt hier so groß thematisieren wollte. Ich glaube, mich hat das einfach nur beflügelt, darüber nachzudenken, was denn so ein Gerät können könnte.
Das könnte mal awesome sein.
Das könnte funktionieren. Das wäre schon mal ganz geil, oder? Also ich finde das auch so ein bisschen unawesome.
Ich wollte ja meiner Schwester zu Weihnachten eine Apple TV schenken, weil die hat auch so ein Fernseher da irgendwie zu Hause stehen und hat auch so Apple-Geräte. Und dachte, ich habe ja vielleicht ein ganz cooles Weihnachtsgeschenk, so ihr Fotos und so und alles so. Ja, hat aber ein iPhone 4. Damit geht das ja schon mal nicht.
Na doch, Fotos kicken kannst du mit einem iPhone 4.
Nee, geht nicht. Das ist einfach offiziell nicht supported. Macht nichts. Steht auch drauf, ab iPhone 4S darfst du damit spielen.
Was jetzt Airplay oder Fotostrom?
Ja, vielleicht vergeht Fotostrom, aber Airplay, aber hier ist in deinem Foto zu sagen...
Ja, das Syncing, dein Bildschirm Syncing darüber.
Das geht halt nicht. Und dann war schon wieder... Habe ich es wieder zurückgebracht.
Also ich habe die Dinger verteilt bei Verwandtschaft und so, gerade eben für den Zweck, die jetzt hier mal Fotos kicken sollen oder so.
Also irgendwie... Was fehlt denn da eigentlich? Man hat so das Gefühl... Ich habe ja damit vorher erstmal ausgiebig rumgespielt. Ich hatte auch gerade ein externes Display, wo ich dann mal so ein bisschen...
Es fehlt die Zuverlässigkeit einfach. Es ist nicht so, dass es immer geht. Du hast Abbrüche, du hast allerlei Merkwürdigkeit.
Ja, wenn du das als remote HDMI-Anschluss für deinen Rechner benutzt. Aber ich benutze es dafür, um zum Beispiel Quack aus dem iTunes-Store zu gucken. Und das geht einfach. Einfach so. Dann hast du alles, was ich gekauft habe auf dem Rechner oder wie auch immer. Kannst du da klickst du drauf, playen, dann ist es gut.
Wenn du deutsch-synchronisierte Filme geil findest, ist es toll. Aber versuch mal damit, einen englischen Film mit Originalspur zu finden. In diesem scheiß Verzeichnis auch nur irgendwie ein Verständnis dafür zu entwickeln, ob das, was du da jetzt begriffen bist, zu kaufen.
Schnucki, ich habe einen US-ITunes-Account. Da gibt es nichts deutsch-synchronisiertes. Tada, Ende Elendr, fertig. Geht. Seit Jahren. Seit Jahrzehnten.
Muss erst mal aufladen, große Kreditkarte mit US-Adresse, bla. Oder du musst wissen... Ja, aber das ist halt einfach mal ein Fail.
Das ist ein politischer Fail, aber wenn du sagst, dass das Ding nicht geht oder nicht so fällig geht, so was macht das einfach.
Versuch mal mit deinem US-Account einen deutschen Film mit einer deutschen Turnspur zu kaufen.
Nehm ich meinen deutschen Account.
Du musst lachen.
Du musst es immer wieder neu einrichten.
Das Apple TV kann inzwischen mehrere Accounts. Du musst zwar umschalten, du kannst jetzt nicht...
Wie? Seit wann?
Wo? Seit irgendeinem Software-Update von vor einem Jahr oder so was. Du musst jetzt nicht... Du musst umschalten, musst dein Passwort wieder eingeben, aber das hat jetzt... Du musst mal begriffen, dass es unterschiedliche Accounts gibt.
Kann man dann auch mit mehreren Home-Sharing machen.
Hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist auch so ein Problem. Also ich meine, wir haben bei uns... Es gibt potenziell zwei Zuspieler.
Aber die Amis denken so nicht. Die Amis denken so, dass du, wie du Familie hast mit zwei Kindern, dann hast du mindestens sechs TV-Sets im Haus. Jedes Kind hat seine eigene iPad und seine eigene iPhone. So denken die und so wird auch kalkuliert.
Jedes hat aber auch seine eigene Apple-ID.
Ja, aber die haben ja auch ihr eigenes TV-Set oder zwei in ihrem Kinderzimmer. Von daher ist das dann auch egal.
Ach so, aber auf das andere TV-Set können sie da nichts drinnen, oder was?
Ja, du hast ja recht, da gibt es noch Themen da drin, aber ich glaube, das liegt auch nicht notwendigerweise... Ich will jetzt mal deine Lanze brechen für Apple. Ich liege nicht daran, dass sie das nicht verstehen würden, sondern dass sie selber natürlich auch hier fangen sind in Millionen von Verträgen mit Content-Providern, die ihnen das auktorieren, was sie dort zulassen dürfen, was nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass innerhalb von Apple die Leute so blöd sind, die nicht verstehen, dass es solche Kombinationen gibt, oder dass man auch mehrere IDs zu Hause haben kann. Ich glaube, das wäre ihnen sogar ganz recht. Aber dann kriegen sie halt mit ihren Fernsehgesellschaften und Filmbuden und Musikbuden eins auf den Sack, also bauen sie da diesen Scheiß ein. Diese Nervereien ist bitter. Würde ich jetzt eigentlich meinen, dass eine Firma mit der Marktmacht von Apple da mal auf den Tisch haut, aber offensichtlich schmerzt es sie denn so doll auf, oder nicht? Ja, das möchtest du zumindest nicht jetzt aktualisieren. Das kann unter Umständen eine Weile dauern.
Ja, wo kann, wo, deiner Meinung nach, kann man hier...
Immer, immer findet.
nie sehr darüber.
Apple ID's.
Ja, da steht Apple ID's. Da kannst du eine hinzufügen.
Die wird dann auch gleich für dieses blöde Homesharing benutzt?
I don't know. Ich hab bloß eine. Also ich benutze bloß eine. Aber es kann jetzt mehrere Apple ID's immerhin. Soll ich dich mal gerade entschmatzen, Huckel?
Du könntest mal den Darth entdarfen. Ist vielleicht jetzt alles nicht so die Big News. Ich hätte bloß die Erwartung, dass wenn sie jetzt ein Update machen, dass sie das Teil dann doch auch mit diesen 64-Bit-Steinen ausstatten, die sie jetzt schon in iPad und iPhone drin haben.
Dann wird das Ding A7.
Ich öffne übrigens jetzt auch einen Bokbier.
War übrigens sehr lecker, hat mir sehr gemundet. Hallo Andreas, der hört ja nichts zu, der mag ja nichts von Max, aber trotzdem sehr lecker. War jetzt ein bisschen wässriger, als ich gedacht habe, aber nicht schlimm, sondern sehr angenehm sogar.
Das ist jetzt so Sommerfrischbier.
Ja, da ist Dreck in meiner Weise.
Das gehört da, das muss so.
Das ist Berliner Schwärze.
Das Kind schielt nicht, das muss so kicken.
Hat dich pass für passend gemacht.
Ich kann ja mal kurz einstreuen, hier noch so ein kleines Mac-Thema am Rande. Zum einen, also ich habe ja...
Moment, waren wir fertig mit dem Apple TV? Ich wollte eigentlich nur meine Hoffnung äußern, dass das Teil mal zu so einer Game-Konsole umgebaut wird.
Game-Konsole.
Man hat mich dis-disabled.
Game-Konsole?
Ja, der Master of Disaster hat gesagt, soll ich entwedern, da ich eh gerade den Finger drauf hatte, habe ich dann mal entwedert.
Wir machen morgen Autogrammstunde.
Morgen?
Oder Freitag? Wir.
Die weißen Vulkanen?
Nee, wir. Also folgendes. Die Geschichte geht so los. Ich habe in meinem Kurs in der Uni erwähnt, oder bei irgendeiner Gelegenheit habe ich erwähnt, dass mein Traum-Notebook ja eigentlich das hier wäre. Da ging es gerade so um, welches Notebook kannst du empfehlen? Und was soll ich mir denn kaufen? Und ich meinte, das, was ich hier mit Matten, Display, Ethernet und Fire war ja super, aber das gibt es leider nicht mehr. Und dann stellte sich heraus, eine der Studentinnen arbeitet bei Gravis so, um ihr studentisches Büro zu verdienen. Und sie hat mir dann eine E-Mail geschrieben, ich habe gerade mal im System geguckt, in irgendeinem Lager gibt es das letzte MacBook Pro 9 I, mattes Display, 2,6 Gigahertz, USB 3 und so weiter. Und ich kann es dir jetzt reservieren. Dann habe ich bei Vuga hier gefragt, wie sieht es denn aus? Der ist hier langsam durchgehackt und so. Und kann ich jetzt noch so ein altes, neues Notebook haben, statt jetzt so ein fancy Retina? Da haben sie gesagt, ja.
Weißt du, hast du hier nochmal dasselbe Gerät, wolltest du nochmal haben?
Nein, das ist ja ein altes. Das ist ja ein MacBook Pro 8 I oder irgendwie sowas.
Mit USB 2.
Ach so, die letzte Generation, die für dich schon noch ein Upgrade wäre, aber die nicht mehr State of the 8 ist.
Dann hat sie mir das reserviert und VUGA hat es jetzt auch bestellt und ich kann es jetzt am Freitag abholen. Und dann hat sie gesagt, die Kollegen meinten, sie würden gefragt haben, ob ich nicht hier dieser Hucke und so einen Freak Show. Und die würden ja alle da diesen Podcast hören, da ist das Graves in der Kulturbrauerei. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass da jetzt ein Graves ist.
Ach so, dieses kleine Minigraves da.
Ja, und die würden das wohl hören und werden auch ganz große Freak Show-Fans und die haben auch, ich wollte es nämlich erst schicken lassen, dann haben die gesagt, ja, es ist doch gleich um die Ecke und so und willst du nicht hier vorbeikommen, abholen und so. Kann man noch eine kleine Autogrammstunde... Nein, also mit der Autogrammstunde habe ich mir natürlich ausgedacht, aber die waren auf jeden Fall ganz hibbelig, dass ich da vorbeikomme persönlich und das Gerät abhole. So wurde es mir zumindest zugetragen. Wenn das nicht stimmt, dann redet mit, ihr wisst schon wem, für diese Verleumdung. Aber auf jeden Fall werde ich wahrscheinlich morgen oder übermorgen vorbeigehen und dann mein altes neues Macbook abholen.
Kräischen die Teenager?
Na, ich hoffe jetzt nach dieser...
Wenn wir nachher mal vorbei fahren, dann stehen da schon Zelt und die Warte.
Also wenn ihr jetzt auch noch, wenn ihr jetzt euch sozusagen sehr karawane anschließt und wir tauchen dann einfach so in Mannschaftsstärke auf... Mit Sonnenbrillen, dann ist da was los wahrscheinlich, ja? Aber, ich fand es natürlich trotzdem ganz geil, dass ich jetzt das letzte MacBook Pro in dieser Bauart bekomme und das Verrückte war, da hatte ich das reserviert, so intern im System. Dann hat sie mich irgendwie nochmal angeschrieben und meinte, hier ist gerade jemand in den Laden gekommen und wollte genau das gleiche Notebook haben, aber weil das in irgendeinem Lager ist, kann man das jetzt gerade nicht im Shop bestellen, sondern er muss über die Webseite das bestellen, haben sie ihm gesagt. Das heißt, der Typ ist jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade in dem Moment nach Hause gefahren und ich so habe gerade Essen bestellt, muss das holen, irgendwie Rase, Rase, Scheiße, okay, jetzt muss ich in den Webstore klicken oder so. Und dann, als ich gerade wieder zu Hause war, schon mit Schweiß auf der Stonne, meint sie, ich habe gerade die Reservierungsbestätigung bekommen, das ist jetzt schon deins und es kommt jetzt an.
Ich kriege das letzte jetzt, was Graves noch irgendwo in irgendeinem Lager hat.
Ja, ist geil, ich freue mich. Ich kann noch ein bisschen länger mein Ethernet und mein FireWire 800-Port und mein mattes Display haben. 16 Gigagramm kriege ich jetzt immerhin, schneller Grafikkarte.
Wie viel toller ist denn das Gerät im Vergleich zu dem, was du jetzt hast?
Na, ich habe jetzt einen 2,2 Gigahertz. Sandy Bridge noch. Jetzt kriege ich einen 2,6 Ivy Bridge. Statt USB 2 kriege ich USB 3. Eine schnellere Grafikkarte. Statt der AMD kriege ich jetzt die dicke Intel, glaube ich.
Also Build-In-Grafics oder was?
Ja, auch die.
Hast du schon mal in MacBook Pro eine Grafikkarte nachgesteckt?
Nein, es gibt da auch.
Weil du gerade sagtest, natürlich Build-In.
Nein, Indie-CPU-Build-In.
Oder On-Chip.
Die haben ja Zweier drin.
Ja, das wissen wir schon.
Mittlerweile ja nicht mehr.
Und die ist dicker dann auch. Also als die, die ich jetzt habe, sozusagen. Das heißt, im Prinzip ist jetzt so von der, und ich kriege mehr RAM, den hätte ich zwar hier, glaube ich, der hat, glaube ich, auch schon, Apple hat ja gesagt, bei den MacBook Pros, bei den alten gehen nur 8 rein, aber man hat ja rausgefunden, dass 16 reingehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei dem auch schon so war, aber bei den Ivy-Bridge auf jeden Fall. Und jetzt kriege ich halt auch nochmal 8 gegen mehr RAM rein. Das heißt, insgesamt ist die Kiste auf jeden Fall schon noch ein bisschen sportlicher.
Kommt sowas schon serienmäßig mit SSD eigentlich?
Nee, aber ich werde halt die rausnehmen und da reinstecken.
Was hast du da drin gerade?
Da ist eine 500-Gig-Samsung.
Es gibt jetzt Tera.
Ja, ja, ist alles aber auch...
Aber du hast nicht die Pro-Variante, wenn du die 500er hast, ne? Hast du eine 500 oder eine 512er?
Mensch, jetzt fragst du mich hier wieder, was der kickt nach, sag ich mal. Ja, es ist schnell genug auf jeden Fall, ne? Also, Samsung SSD 840, 500.
Wie du neulich so schön getwittert hast, das ist immer ein Schock, wenn man noch mal in welchen Leuten über die Schulter schaut, die noch drehende Platten drin haben. Ich krieg auch jedes Mal zucken im Finger. Ich denke, warum startet denn die App nicht? Da ist was kaputt. Ach doch, sie startet ja.
Die Keyboard-Spielerin aus unserer Band, die hat ja auch so für ihr Logic und so MacBook Pro und hat jetzt dieses Logic X und sie klickt da so drauf bei der Probe und alle sind schon bereit und warten so, dass es losgeht und es macht Bounce, Bounce, Bounce und sie guckt schon so, ja geht gleich los, Bounce, Bounce, alle starten auf dem Bildschirm. Nochmal schnell Gitarretune, Bounce, Bounce. Dann kommt dieser Loading-Screen und dann lädt es ja noch diese ganzen Plug-Ins und was nicht noch an. Schon in diesem Moment habe ich schon so, ich halte es nicht aus, ich kann da nicht hingucken, das geht wirklich nicht.
Wir haben ja wirklich Minuten gewartet, bis Software gestartet ist.
Und das war völlig normal.
Ich habe jetzt mittlerweile echt alle meine Systeme auf SSD. Also alle primären Bootplatten sind in allen Rechner.
Der Tafel ist plus und SSD.
Hast du an dem Mac Pro jetzt so eine Karte drin?
So eine Karte.
So eine SSD-Karte.
Nö, ich habe das einfach an diesem freien SATA-Slot.
Einfach mit Gaffa-Tape und drin?
Nö, mit so einem Halter. Kannst du kaufen so einen Winkel, wo du dann reinpasst, die zweieinhalber.
Weil bei meiner Intel SSD war so ein Winkel dabei, aber der ist nicht so, dass man diesen Winkel sozusagen in so einem dreieinhalb Zoll-Slot, dass die Anschlüsse an der gleichen Stelle sind, wie da, wo sie von der Festplatte wären. Also genau das, was man beim Apple-Teil da ja braucht.
Das ist bei mir aber so.
Das heißt, die originalen Metallteile, den Mac Pro, oben schiebst du die Platten, die kommen weg und da kommt ein neues, oder kommt was für die SSD, was man an dieses Metallteil ran schrauben kann? Also ich habe zwei Metallteile.
Link doch mal auf das Produkt, was du hast.
Okay, also das alte Metallteil ist raus und es ist ein neues rein mit der SSD.
Das alte, da war ja vorher nichts.
Na klar, da sind doch diese vier Teile für die vier Platten, wo du eine Platte ran schrauben kannst.
Nein, nein, nein, ich rede von dem Slot, von dem zweiten CD-Slot.
Optische Laufwerke und so.
Genau, optische Laufwerke.
So, dann hast du die einfach eingelegt, oder was?
Nein, nicht hingelegt, sondern mit so einem Winkel. Das ist ja ein dreieinhalb Zoll Slot für ein CD-Laufwerk. Du weißt schon, diese Dinger...
Ein Fünfeinviertel Zoll Slot ist das, oder? Ist das so ein großer Slot?
Richtig, ein Fünfeinviertel Zoll Slot, genau. Du hast recht. Entschuldigung. Und dafür gibt es halt dann so Winkel, dass du da so kleine SSDs reinschieben kannst, als wäre es halt ein CD-Laufwerk.
Ich verstehe, weil da oben gehen ja zwei Kabel, und du hast nur einen CD-ROM und da ist noch eins...
Genau, das ist einfach ein kabelfrei.
Und das Strom ist da schon auch genau, dieser Doppelstecker war es genau...
Genau, das ist halt einfach SATA 2. Genau, und die Plattslots, die habe ich auch voll mit Platten. Also da ist halt auch wirklich alles voll mit Platten.
Verstehe, verstehe. Und das Ding da oben ist auch SATA 2, oder ist es sogar nur SATA 1?
Das ist alles SATA 2.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir auch mal so eine SSD von meinem Mac Pro holen und die da oben einfach reinlegen.
Genau, du kannst da sogar 2 reintun, aber dann fehlt dir halt noch... Also wenn du auf das CD-Laufwerk komplett verzichten kannst, kannst du natürlich auch beide...
Eigentlich fast schon, dann brauchen wir den Scheiß schon.
Naja, ich brauche das schon nochmal von Zeit zu Zeit.
Eine SSD reicht ja auch. ZFS haben sie ja leider nicht. Sonst würde ich ja zwei machen. Die Plattenindustrie könnte so viel Geld verdienen, wenn man mal irgendwie mehr ZFS machen könnte. Ich würde mir alles doppelt kaufen, aber so, mit HFS Plus auf deren Rate, tra la la, 0, 1, keine Ahnung, habe ich keinen Bock.
Habe ich keinen Bock? Ich habe ja in den Servern jetzt hier, die wir da gerade fett bestellt haben in der Firma, da benutze ich mehr der Doppel-SSD als Zill-Device.
So, ich habe noch zwei Software-Tipps.
Software-Tipps.
Genau, der eine ist im Prinzip noch nicht so ein richtiger Tipp, weil es sich hier eigentlich um eine Beta-Version handelt, aber ich bin ja mittlerweile ein großer Freund der einst von dir gepickten Software ARK, die ich auch immer noch benutze. Zur Erinnerung, ARQ ist your one-stop-address for back-upping your files. Und was das Ding gemacht hat, ist, es hat ursprünglich mal schön alles, immer schön auf Amazon S3 geschoben. Dann gab es ja vor einem Jahr, glaube ich, in etwa, kam ja dieses Amazon Glacier. Ja, der Glacier, wo auch eine Menge reingeht, aber halt alles ein bisschen langsamerer ist. Schöner Name eigentlich für das Produkt, muss ich sagen. Und das wurde dann von ARK in der Version 3 durch irgendein Update relativ schnell unterstützt. Also alle haben irgendwie auf ihn eingeredet, hier Glacier, bitte sofort, kostet alles nur noch ein Zehntel usw. Klar, war ja ein No-Brainer. Und dann hat er das auch geschafft, das relativ schnell zu implementieren. Und das Ganze hat er aber gemacht mit der ersten von Amazon, also klar, damals auch der einzigen existierenden API. Und diese API war halt sozusagen speziell für Glacier. Und Glacier unterscheidet sich ja auch von S3 dahingehend, dass es halt einfach ein anderes Storage-Modell ist. Man kann da zwar auch seine Daten hinschieben, aber es ist halt Slow Storage. Das heißt, man kann da zwar schnell hinschieben, weil es erstmal irgendwo zwischengepuffert wird, aber dann geht es vermutlich auf Tapes oder was auch immer das sein mag. Und wenn man dann wieder darauf zugreifen möchte, dann muss man das so mit Vorlauf machen. Das heißt, man sagt dem Teil, ja, hier hätte ich jetzt gerne mal. Und dann muss halt irgendein armer Roboter das aus irgendeinem Schrank rausholen. Und das kann dann halt mal vier Stunden dauern. Also das ist zumindest der Timeslot, den sich Amazon selber frei hält. Das dürfte dann in der Regel schneller gehen, aber man weiß ja gar nicht. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass ich dann eben quasi nur noch ein Zehntel bezahlte für meine Backups und mich auf einmal auch getraut habe, ganz andere Datenmengen zu speichern. Also auch so fette Teile, die so Recordings und so weiter, wo ich vorher einfach mich überhaupt nicht ran getraut habe, weil es einfach zu teuer geworden wäre. Mit Glacier ging das alles. Dann gab es bei Amazon eine Änderung. Und zwar haben sie... Also das Problem, was mit Glacier...
Bei Amazon?
Ich rede jetzt nur von Amazon.
Ich dachte, du warst vorher noch bei Google.
Nein, Glacier ist Amazon. Also Amazon S3 ist ja der normale...
Okay, okay, dann habe ich das gerade vertan...
.deine Festplatte bei S3. So, wo du immer alles so in Buckets abspeicherst. Und dieses Glacier war auch so irgendwie so ähnlich. Und hat aber seine eigene API.
So.
Dann haben sie vor ein paar Monaten, halben Jahr, haben sie eine neue API gemacht, wo sie quasi Glacier so richtig als Backend für S3 definiert haben. Das heißt, wo du vorher das separat benutzt hast, kannst du jetzt von irgendeinem S3-Bucket sagen, ja, ich schiebe das jetzt hier mal rein über das normale S3-API, aber die Daten wandern dann halt irgendwie ab. Ich kann euch das jetzt im Detail nicht so genau erläutern, weil ich mir dieses API nie so richtig durchgelesen habe. Aber mit diesem neuen API, kann man halt Dinge besser machen, kann es halt besser definieren, was soll jetzt hier wie bei S3 sein, weil auch ARK hat dann in S3 nochmal in irgendwelchen Buckets quasi diese Verzeichnisse abgespeichert, sodass es immer schnell darauf zugreifen konnte, was habe ich denn da weggeschrieben, aber die Daten selber waren halt auf Glacier. Also das Verzeichnis hast du auf S3. Und jetzt mit dem neuen API kann man das halt alles zusammenfassen. In dem aktuellen Shipping ARK geht das halt alles noch nicht, aber es gibt jetzt eine Beta-Version von ARK. Da kann man einen Blog nachschlagen, Haystack Software. Und naja, die hat noch Issues. Also wer jetzt nicht total hinterher ist, sollte noch ein bisschen warten. Ich benutze das jetzt aber, weil das für mich einfach Vorteile bietet. Und er schreibt da relativ ausführlich in seinem Blog, welche Vorteile das alles so hat. Zum Beispiel hast du halt so Payment Control. Also du konntest vorher bei S3 sagen, schieb mal alles dahin, aber wirf mal alte Back-ups so weg, damit ich nie mehr zahle als X. Und das ging so mit Glacier, mit der normalen API nicht. Und mit dem neuen geht das halt. Das heißt, neues ARK kommt. Es gibt schon eine Beta-Version, kann man ausprobieren. Und wer sozusagen noch nicht mit ARK arbeitet, möchte vielleicht unter Umständen schon mal mit dieser Beta-Version testen. Weil da kann man halt billig Kram wegschmeißen. Es gibt noch ein zweites Feature, was noch auch sehr interessant ist, was ich aber noch nicht getestet habe. Wenn man jetzt selber irgendwo Storage hat, und der ist per SFTP erreichbar, kann man das auch da machen. Das heißt, ARK kann jetzt auch Backup via SFTP machen.
Und halt auch andere Hoster oder Dinge, die halt auch eine S3-kompatible API anbieten. Da gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel Rackspace, die bieten ja auch Storage an mit S3-API. Das gibt es jetzt bei ganz vielen.
Auch Google auch, glaube ich.
Genau, und du kannst, glaube ich, sogar, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, dem Engine X so eine S3-Extension, Third-Party-Extension mit installieren. Zumindest, bildlich mir das ein oder andere gesehen zu haben. Dann verhält sich auch dein Engine X irgendwie wie so eine S3. Und dann kannst du halt auch da drüber sozusagen mit anderen, ich glaube auch sogar so was wie Domain Factory oder Host Europe irgendwie. Ich habe das schon an vielen Ecken und Enden gesehen, dass sie so, ja, jetzt gibt es übrigens auch so S3-kompatible API irgendwie für deinen Storage.
Ist das jetzt so der De-Facto-Standard für mehr Storage, Overnet?
Ich würde ja sagen, es ist ja alles HDP darunter. Das könnte man vielleicht auch nochmal anders machen, aber...
Ist auch nicht so, dass es da nicht schon Standards für jede wie WebDAF oder so.
Aber es funktioniert, sagen wir mal so.
Bei WebDAF hat er halt andere Abstraktionen. Letztlich muss man sagen, hat das alles sehr gut funktioniert. Und Amazon ist halt einfach allen um Jahre voraus gewesen mit ihren ganzen Storage-Klimpen. Und das zahlt sich dann halt auch so aus.
Naja, auf jeden Fall. Also, dass man das jetzt zumindest auch eben auf eigene Kisten und so schieben kann, schon mal sehr cool. Sehr begrüßenswert.
So, dann gibt es noch einen zweiten Tipp. Und zwar eine Software, die auch heute erst rausgekommen ist. Wie ihr ja sicherlich entweder schon wisst oder zumindest am Rande immer mal gehört habt, verwenden wir hier auf Phonic, um unsere Podcasts vor der Veröffentlichung noch mal so auf Vordermann zu bringen.
Und auf 44,1 Kilohertz zu konvertieren.
Ja, da bin ich gerade in der Debatte, aber davon mal abgesehen.
Die Leute brennen sich immer CDs von den Podcasts, das ist denn ideal.
Ja, die Pandora-Büchse mache ich jetzt hier nicht auf. Egal, also ein Kernfeature von der Auphonic Software ist ja die Audioaufbereitung. Also abgesehen davon, dass es einem auch noch so Sachen abnimmt wie Encoding in verschiedene Formate und Upload und dieser ganze Kram und Kapitelmarken und Pipapo, die nicht ohne weiteres nachzubildende Kernstarfeature, Eigenschaft von Auphonic ist der Leveler. Also dieses adaptive Analysieren von Audiospuren und Audioaufzeichnungen, dem Untersuchen, wo ist hier Musik, wo ist Sprache und danach eben Stück für Stück alles so auf eine einheitliche Lautstärke zu bringen, also Musik wird dabei anders behandelt als Sprache. Und dann wird am Ende alles auf denselben Lautstärkegrad gebracht und dann wird das Gesamtergebnis vor allem noch auf einen definierten nach EBU-Lautnisstandards hochgezogenen Pegel gebracht. Das ist sozusagen das Meisterstück in dieser ganzen Auphonic Software. Und für die Leute, die mit Online-Services ein Problem haben, weil sie das nicht dürfen oder weil sie notorisch offline arbeiten müssen oder arbeiten wollen, gibt es jetzt genau diese Leveler-Geschichte als Standalone-Applikation zum Kaufen.
Für Plattform?
Für derzeit gibt es nur die OS X-Version, aber eine Windows- und Linux-Version sind auch in der Mache. Jetzt muss ich kurz nochmal gucken, was eigentlich die Preise sind. Das hatte ich zwar.
Und vor allen Dingen, wo findet man das auf der Webseite? Du hast vorhin irgendwie einen Link gepostet, aber jetzt suche ich den gerade auf der Webseite. Ich habe einen Link gepostet? Na, irgendjemand hat einen Link gepostet.
Ach so, der von Auphonic.
Aber wie finde ich das auf deren Seite, das Produkt?
Das ist gerade eine gute Frage.
Also es ist nicht im Blog zu finden.
auphonic.com/leveler.
Na ja, ist noch nicht ordentlich verlinkt, naja.
Nee, ist noch nicht ordentlich verlinkt, aber gibt's. Und es gibt halt zwei Preise. Es gibt halt eine Discounted-License, die liegt bei 60 Euro, und es gibt eine Commercial-License. Und ja, wie man sich denken kann, Personal Non-Commercial Use ist sozusagen das eine. Und wenn man halt irgendwie eine Entität ist, dann kriegt man da eine Five Seat Installation für 280 Euro. Das ist halt der Deal. Im Prinzip ist das das erste Mal, dass es so eine Software gibt, seit dem Tool, dem Levelator von dem Conversation Networks, was vor vielen, vielen Jahren mal vorgestellt wurde. Das ist eine Python-Software, die im Prinzip dasselbe gemacht hat.
Nur nicht so gut.
Nee, nicht so gut. Es stimmt übrigens nicht, wenn ich sage, dasselbe gemacht hat. Die hat nicht dasselbe gemacht. Was die gemacht hat, ist, die ist davon ausgegangen, dass diese Audioaufnahme einfach eine Sprachaufnahme ist. Und wenn sie es nicht war, dann ist da auch schnell mal Salat bei rausgekommen. Wenn du da so ein Intro drin hattest, ein Musik-Intro, das hat es einfach zerstört. Es eignete sich also nur dafür. Und es war jetzt auch nicht so sophisticated, nicht so gut im Leveling. Und schon gar nicht waren da irgendwelche EBU-Lautness-Standards und Anpassungen. Das Endergebnis war zwar vielleicht etwas gleichmäßiger laut, aber es war halt nicht irgendwie definiert laut. Das hat man halt mit dem Auphonic Leveler. Na gut, vielleicht ist das für irgendjemanden ein Ding.
Also ich habe ja kürzlich davon Gebrauch gemacht, nicht nur weil ich ja das auch beim Podcasten sowieso da Auphonic und so weiter benutze. Ich habe jetzt kleine Überleitung schon fast. Jetzt so vier FreeBSD Screencasts mal aufgenommen. Bevor wir da kurz drüber sprechen. Aber da hatte ich nämlich das Problem, ich habe die ja auch so mit dem Mikro aufgenommen, dann musste ich halt immer dazwischen so tippen und habe meinen Kopf auch immer so ein bisschen beiseite gedreht quasi. Deswegen war das schon sehr unterschiedlich laut. Wenn man jetzt einfach eine normale Normalization, wie auch immer, drüber laufen lässt, dann kann man zwar zum Beispiel einen Reaper, könnte man das nach Sektion teilen und sagen, mach mal hier jede Sektion, dass es einen Common Gain hat und so weiter, aber da kommt man vom Hölzchen aufs Stöckchen, das wird alles nix. Und dann habe ich, was ich gemacht habe, ich habe es mit Screenflow aufgenommen, dann habe ich das Audio so lossless exported, habe das einmal durch Aufphonic gejagt und auf irgendein Lautness-Standard sowieso eingestellt. Und dann hatte ich irgendwie Audio, was konstant schön laut war und so weiter. Und auch, was machen die noch? Hier dieses Noise-Filtering und so weiter. Habe ich irgendwie das schön durchgeputzt und dann wieder in Screenflow reingeklebt und dann klang das ordentlich. Das war also dafür, war dieser Adaptive Leveler genau das Richtige, weil ich halt mal so und mal so vor dem Mikrofon saß, beim Tippen und so. Und da wurde aus diesem sehr inhomogenen Gebrabbel wurde dann ein schön gleichmäßig lauter Audio-Strom. Ja, also dafür konnte ich das schon mal gebrauchen. Deswegen, wenn ich jetzt so eine App tatsächlich auf dem Rechner hätte, finde ich das sogar noch ein bisschen charmanter als tatsächlich nur für dieses eine Leveling, weil ich ja nicht mal diese ganzen Podcast-Features brauche, ich habe immer mit Chaptermarkets, da ging es wirklich nur ums Leveling, das dann extra einmal hochladen und wieder runterladen und so. Da hätte ich so eine Standalone-App tatsächlich schon mal ganz sympathisch gefunden. Tja, und jetzt Überleitung zu... Ja, genau, ich habe irgendwie, weil ich jetzt gerade in der Firma habe, so ein Projekt, wo wir so Fettinfrastruktur hinstellen und irgendwie der Kollege und ich, wir haben uns jetzt eben drauf geeignet, wir machen FreeBSD, weil wir ZFS haben wollen und sowieso FreeBSD-affin sind. Und dann ist uns natürlich, oder ist mir so ein bisschen auch wieder klar geworden, ganz viele Leute benutzen einfach FreeBSD nicht, weil sie auch so ein bisschen nicht damit jetzt klarkommen oder Angst haben, weil es ja anders ist und keine Ahnung und immer so, weißt schon, so Fear, Uncertainty und Doubt. Und dann dachte ich, okay, ich mache jetzt einfach mal so ein paar Videos und zeige irgendwie, dass das alles ganz easy ist und wie einfach ein ZFS-Snapshot-Rollback und so weiter ist und wie man da sein System anguckt und welche Tools es da gibt und wie einfach man jetzt so ein FreeBSD 10 installieren kann, weil es jetzt Installer eben auch ZFS zum Klicken gibt sozusagen. Und hab sozusagen erste Videos FreeBSD 10 installieren, mach das auch auf einem echten Server über ein IPME-Interface. Was für ein Interface? Ja, IPME, also so Fernwartung, so eine Fernwartungskarte, wo du sozusagen mit so einem Java-Applet dann Remote-Konsole hast und der Kiste beim Booten halt zugucken kannst. Und da kannst du dann eben auch sagen, im BIOS hier, Boote mal Virtual Media. Hängst da so ein FreeBSD ISO rein und dann bootet der von dem ISO. Und dann installier ich das auf dem Server. Beim zweiten zeig ich halt so ein paar Tools, weil es gibt jetzt natürlich andere Tools als beim Linux, um zu gucken, wie es der Kiste so geht. Bei FreeBSD ist ja Sys-Stud, zum Beispiel ganz viel, um so IO zu betrachten und zeig halt mal so ein paar Tools. Dann irgendwie beim dritten mach ich glaube ich die Jails. Oder beim vierten, auf jeden Fall so ein paar Videos, um den Leuten mal so ein bisschen die Angst zu nehmen. Und kam auch schon mal ganz gut an. Haben glaube ich auch schon hier genau, das haben 1274 Plays das erste Video gehabt, haben auch schon ganz viele ganz nettes Feedback dazu gegeben. Und ich mache auch noch ein, zwei, ich habe da noch ein bisschen was in der Pipeline. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, da hat mir ein Typ geschrieben. Und der meinte, ja, irgendwie ist ja schon mal ganz geil. Und hat auch, weil ich gemeint habe, ja cool, irgendwie gucken sich ganz viele Leute an. Ja, aber warte mal, bis wir dich in unserem Vodcast, also er hat nicht Vodcast, aber in unserer Video-Podcast-Show erwähnen. Warte mal, da gibt es bestimmt noch ein paar Views mehr. Da dachte ich, was habt ihr denn? Dann war das der BSD Now-Podcast oder Video-Podcast, kannte ich vorher noch nicht. Da sitzen sich irgendwie jede Woche zwei so Typen hin, und zwar auch dieser eine Typ, der dieses ZFS-Layout verbrochen hat, in dem Installer. Ich meine, seine Argumente waren ja jetzt auch nicht total verkehrt, aber auf jeden Fall sitzen die da und erzählen so die ganze Zeit über alle möglichen FreeBSD-News und filmen sich auch noch dabei. Das wäre zwar eigentlich nicht nötig, finde ich, aber bsdnow.tv heißt das. Das kann man ja an der Stelle auch mal pluggen. Da sind auf jeden Fall hin und wieder auch ganz interessante Informationen in den Show-Notes zu finden, tatsächlich. Ja, genau, ich dachte eben, wenn, dann machen wir das auch gleich in Englisch, damit es auch irgendwie alle gucken können. Ja, ich mache jetzt noch so vielleicht zwei, drei und dann ist es auch erstmal wieder gut. Dann den Rest kriegen die Leute, die dann bis dahin noch weitergehören.
Von den BSC Now-Jungs.
BSC Now-Jungs, ja, das war schon in der letzten Folge. In der letzten? Ja, da irgendwo in den Show Notes relativ weit unten ist das. Die Seite, neue Episodes, die streamen übrigens auch live ihr Video. 24? Warte mal, nee, sorry, es ist die 23, weil letzte Woche.
Du bist in der 23 erwähnt worden.
Warte mal, ist das hier auch wirklich? Ja, Getting Started News Roundup, da in der untersten Sektion ist es mit drin. Jaja, genau, da linken sie aber auf dem Blogpost. Ja, das ist ja auch nicht schlecht, da ist der Flatter-Button. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall.
Ja, coole Sache, ich habe mir, glaube ich, das erste habe ich mir, glaube ich, auch angeschaut, dass du jetzt schon vier hast.
Ja, ich habe dann, ich dachte an dem Wochenende, okay, jetzt kicke ich die einfach noch raus bis zu den Jails, damit irgendwie...
Was mich ein bisschen wundert, gab es nicht bei Vimeo mal so diese Policy, dass sie nur so richtig Video-Video haben wollen und dass so Screencasts da gleich wieder rausgekickt werden?
Nee, also vielleicht gab es das mal früher, aber eigentlich sagen die nur, sie wollen vor allen Dingen HD-Content und nicht irgendwie, also sie wollen originellen Content, sie wollen halt nichts irgendwie, irgendwelche Schnitzel aus irgendwelchen Filmen oder so. Das wollen sie nicht, sie wollen HD-Content und sie wollen... Den coolen Shit nur? Nee, also irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, die Policy ließ sich eigentlich ganz entspannt so, was für Content das sein kann. Es soll halt nur vor allen Dingen von Leuten selber... Original Content sein und High Quality. Das sind so ihre Wünsche sozusagen.
Ja, das finde ich auch einen guten Ansatz, muss ich sagen.
Vimeo ist echt eine Menge gute Sachen.
Und ich habe komischerweise auch einen Vimeo Pro-Account.
Na, ich auch.
Aber man kann ja mit seinen Apple TV auch spielen, ne? Wo wir gerade bei Apple TV waren.
Wie, da gibt es einen Channel?
Schon lange. Auch mit HD und Tralala und so ist es unscharf.
Also auf jeden Fall, Vimeo finde ich auch immer sehr sympathisch. Und ich will ja auch irgendwie den Google-Leuten nicht noch mehr als so ohnehin schon haben geben. Und YouTube finde ich irgendwie... Da hätte man vielleicht noch so eine mehr Zufalls-Schauer, weil wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute dann eher bei YouTube noch mal nach einem Video suchen. Aber über Google findet man das ja dann auch bei Vimeo. Und ich finde halt so, dass das ganze Look-in-Field da einfach so ein bisschen angenehmer.
Das stimmt. Und vor allem ist halt auch mal wieder so ein Dienstleister, der einfach mit Qualität arbeitet und die Leute wirklich dazu bringt, Pro-Accounts zu klicken und davon lebt und nicht von Werbescheiße. Also das finde ich das richtig. Also es gibt wohl die Möglichkeit, auch Werbung einzublenden, oder?
Ja, es gibt ja auch. Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also ich habe ja einen Adblocker, ich sehe eh selten Werbung, aber...
Na gut, in Videos kann man da ja noch nicht so richtig blocken.
Ja, das stimmt. Also ich habe in Vimeo Videos glaube ich noch keine gesehen. Und ich habe auf jeden Fall auch einen Pro-Account, weil ich jetzt auch keinen mit irgendwie... Also ich will ja das auf Mobile und überall HD und HTML5 und so. Ja, wir haben dich auch gekriegt. Genau, mit dem Argument haben sie mich da sofort in den Bann gezogen.
Ich habe letzte Woche auch was installiert. Allerdings nicht, weil ich Spaß daran hatte, sondern weil ich musste. Das war eine ganz finste Erfahrung.
Eine ganz finste?
Ja, ich habe nämlich mal nach ewiger Zeit immer wieder ein Windows installiert.
Würdest du nicht lieber erstmal über dein FreeBSD Projekt erzählen, weil wir gerade bei diesem Thema sind?
FreeBSD ist aber viel zu schön, ist viel zu happy.
Ja, aber wir sind doch gerade beim schönen...
Wir sind ja gerade im Turny Mode.
Lass das mal ein bisschen happy sein.
Danach gehen wir wieder ins Thysotope.
Danach machen wir irgendwie die Bill Gates Experience.
Ja, wo wir jetzt hier gerade alles auf dem FreeBSD-Tipp sind und ich letzte Woche krank war, habe ich mir gedacht, ich gucke mal, dass ich mit meinem Pi mal etwas richtig überhelfe, weil diese komischen Linux-Distributionen, die die da drauf tun, die sind auch so überladen, man wird in welchem Scheiß... Naja, stimmt ja, der FreeBSD 10 Dollar... Demnächst gibt es sogar noch einen neuen Beagle-Bohnen, der auf meinem Land sitzt, auf mich wartet, der kriegt auch erstmal einen FreeBSD verpasst, aber jetzt so einen Raspberry Pi. Und mir dachte, probierst du einfach mal, da gibt es so erstmal fertige Binary, was man da runterladen kann. Inzwischen ein Bestandteil der FreeBSD 10, also nicht der offiziellen Distribution, aber es gibt einen FreeBSD 10 und dann steht ja da so, hier wir liefern dir für folgende Plattformen, das offiziell, dann gibt es hier noch folgende Leute, die liefern dir Binaries für Tralala und Pi-Papo.
Was heißt denn das eigentlich, was macht denn dieses Image? Also man macht das Image auf die SD-Karte, schiebt das in den Pi?
Allerdings ohne ZFS, weil das wirst du nicht spielen mit dem MNG auf einer SD-Karte.
Aber kommt das Ding schon mit dem fertigen Login hoch oder mit dem Installer?
Nö, fertiger Login.
Dem man dann noch ein bisschen...
Da ist halt ein Standard-Root-Password drauf, das sagen sie dir, und dann hackst du das um und danach machst du halt mit Ports-Installer, entweder wenn du willst, es läuft, es ist kein Witz, völlig krass natürlich auf dem Pi zu kompilieren, aber es geht. Damit habe ich erst mal angefangen, habe erst mal so ein paar Ports und dann rauppelt der halt so eine Weile rum und vor allem...
Das war ein Pearl-Bond.
Nein, das Schlimmste war halt, das Schlimmste war Ports-Snap. Und dann packt er sich erst mal seine, keine Ahnung, seine 20.000 Queach-Ports da, zieht er sich da runter und falte die aus auf der SD-Karte. Aber ich hab den ja Packages, das kannst du auch erzählen, aber der kommt echt mit Compiler und so und das Ding krabbelt halt, schubbert langsam auf der SD-Karte vor sich hin, aber es wird, es ist deutlich langsamer, aber es wird. Fand ich schon mal sehr nett, so ein kleines Ding zu haben, ich mag ja FreeBSD vor allem deswegen, weil es halt eben nicht überladen ist mit 5000 und drei Tools für diese, jenet und welche und da noch ein Bluetooth-Demon und da fünf grafische Oberflächen, sondern es ist halt einfach nur so the naked stuff, ja. Und was da halt haben wird, ist jetzt dazu, finde ich eigentlich sehr schön. Und da ich ja die Dinger auch gelegentlich mal einsetze so als Controller für dieses, jenes oder welches, habe ich mich jetzt auch gefreut. Habe da ein ordentliches Betriebssystem drauf, was von Hause aus V4, V6 spricht. Das ist auch alles an. Ja, da ist ein Pearl drauf, was ordentlich funktioniert. Das ist halt ein richtig schönes, kleines Unix, wie man das haben will. So schnufflig klein, fand ich sehr schön. Dann habe ich eine ganze Menge damit gemacht. Dann wollte ich dann doch mal einen Kernel, einen eigenen Kernel kompilieren. Und das willst du wirklich nicht tun auf dem Ding. Das geht, aber das läuft keine Ahnung, einen Tag oder so, ja. Und dann habe ich mal probiert, dann habe ich mal probiert, so Cross-Compilation zu machen. Das ist relativ einfach. Da gibt es inzwischen Skripts dafür. Das brauchst du einfach auf deiner normalen Intel-Kiste oder wo auch immer du da einen FreeBSD drauf hast. Dann werden so ein Set von Environment-Variablen gesetzt oder so was. Und dann machst du da Cross-Compilation auf deiner Kiste und erzeugst halt den selben Kernel, den Ratz-Fatz so in 5 Minuten oder so was auf deiner Intel-Kiste. Die spielst du da drauf auf die SD-Karte und ist gut. Finde ich also sehr sexy. Also gerade eben, ich muss ja erstmal so das ganze Krypto-Zeug anmachen, so IP-Sec da anmachen und einen PF da rein konfigurieren und was man halt so haben will, den ganzen Netzwerk-Scheiß. Und finde ich eigentlich sehr schön. Das ist jetzt mal so mein Pet-Project. Wie gesagt, next step ist Beagle-Born. Funktioniert nach demselben Prinzip. Kannst du auch mit demselben Skripten machen. Musst du ihm halt nur sagen, jetzt für Beagle-Born, nicht für Pi. Mal gucken, wie das so geht.
Beagle-Born ist aber noch keine offiziell unterstützte Plattform.
Doch, doch. Doch, gibst du auch schon.
Du kannst die ganzen Make-Files und die ganzen Konfigurations-Dinger dafür. Das ist jetzt alles zum Bestandteil von FreeBSD.
Aber es gibt jetzt kein fertiges Image.
Doch, findest du auch. Es gibt auch Leute, die das schon machen, aber nicht auf der offiziellen FreeBSD-Seite. Sondern es gibt halt irgendwelche Leute, die eben die Prozedur durchlaufen, also make-world und lalala und so für diese Plattform, und die dann da so eine kleine Distribution zusammenbauen. Aber kann man, wie gesagt, kann man machen. Was sie natürlich nicht haben, sie haben natürlich nicht diese Spezialunterstützung für diese, keine Ahnung, diese H264...
Für die Grafikkarte haben sie wahrscheinlich.
Für diese Grafikkarte. Die betreiben sie wie eine VGA. Also wie man jetzt so kennt früher, so diese Unix-Systeme mit VGA, so wo du denn diese Konsolen hast mit Umschalten von Alt-F1 bis Alt-F12 und so, diese Geschichten. Aber es gibt auch ein X und so was, aber du hast jetzt nicht diese Video-Unterstützung für den Pi oder so was. Das habe ich jedenfalls noch nicht gesehen. Aber der ganze andere Schmuddel, der da drauf ist, der funktioniert so vor sich hin.
Bei Fribis, die müssen jetzt alle auf diesen neuen Package-Manager umsteigen. Sie wollen im Oktober den Support komplett einstellen und auch die Software nicht mehr bereitstellen.
Für das Alte? Und das machen die Neun und Acht und so, die noch supportet werden?
Die installieren sich halt einen PKG-NG-Part oder Package.
Auch da kannst du umsteigen.
Bei mir zu Hause habe ich schon auf 10 umgestellt, habe auch alles an 9 weggeschmissen. Dann ging gleich auch erst mal alles. Überhaupt nichts ging mehr, weil ich habe die Lips alle entfernt. Dann musste ich alles neu bauen. Da dachte ich, wenn ich alles neu baue, dann auch gleich das neue PKG-NG. Ich dachte einfach, fuck it, alles weggeschmissen. Das ist immer grundsätzlich das Beste. Dann einmal alles neu. Dann musste ich alles neu bauen. Bei der Aktion dachte ich gleich, nach wie vielen Jahren, da brauche ich jetzt keine Apache. Habt ihr Lighty benutzt? Inzwischen ist er genauso schlimm wie der Apache.
Engine X, Mann.
Ja, das nächste Mal.
Der Lighty ist genauso schlimm wie der Apache?
Früher war Lighty ja light, aber inzwischen ist Lighty auch mehr so heavy. Er braucht auch schon so viele Modules und Zeug.
Also der Webserver der Wahl ist Engine X gerade. Und schon seit einiger Zeit sogar. Also alles andere ist schon...
Ja, also vor einem Jahr war das für mich noch keine Alternative, weil er noch nicht mal mit e-Text klar kam. Nee, gab es nicht. In dem Release gab es keinen e-Text. Da muss es da irgendwie...
Ja, so, guck mal, da ist mal wieder Zeit. Ich muss jetzt auch mal ein bisschen mit den Apaches mich befassen, weil ich nicht...
Ja, ich kann ja gleich nochmal gucken, meine Hierarchie. Da ist eh flache Files und ist eigentlich mehr fast ein Downloader als irgendwie ein Web-Server, aber...
Da ist meine komplette WordPress-Installation.
Super, ich kann dir da gleich Beispiele geben. Ich hab alles, alles, alles NGINX.
Beispiele brauch ich nicht. Ich brauch Leute, die meine Hand halten, während ich...... meine Systeme umstelle.
Und Blutdruck senken im Mittel brauchst du.
Ja, aber ich würd gerne mal... Also, die Meta-Ebene läuft auf FreeBSD, der Download-Server derzeit nicht. Und eigentlich würd ich gerne mal alles ein bisschen...
Kannste laufen lassen.
Ich würd gerne mal alles auf 10 konsolidieren, aber das ist halt ein etwas umfangreicherer Move.
Ich hab ja... Eine meiner FreeBSD-Installationen läuft ja... bei demselben Hoster wie dein Download-Ding. Und die unterstützt... Die FreeBSD 10 unterstützt jetzt von Hause aus... und natively diese virtuellen... also diese... diese Virtualisierungs-Devices als Block-Device... und für die Ethernet-Karte. Das heißt, die simulieren nicht mehr, ich bin eine Intel-Gruckenkarte, sondern die sagen gleich... hallo, ich bin eine virtuelle Ethernet-Karte. Hör auf mit der Simulation, gib mir das gleich roh. Und das gibt es halt eben... für die Ethernet-Karten gibt es eben auch für Block-Devices, für die Platten, und das war damals das Problem, dass das dein neuner, dass man das erst nachrüsten musste, der zehner kommt von Hause aus, das wirfst du da drauf, die Plattform hier bei Internet. Und dann sagt er, feiern alle toll und wupp und schön. Kann ich dich auch beinunterstützen? Die man da migriert, oder generierst eine neue Platte, ziehst du drüber und schmeißt die alte dann weg. Also eine virtuelle Platte. Das funktioniert eigentlich sehr gut.
Ich habe jetzt noch rausgefunden, die hatten in der letzten Sendung, war es glaube ich, überlegt, ich habe ja von diesen, wir hatten ja die FreeBSD 10 Änderungen erzählt, und auch die ZFS Änderungen 10, und auch dass es dieses, wie ist es, dass er bestimmte Blöcke nicht wegschreibt, No Write Patch, irgend sowas. Wie ist das genau? Dass die Snapshots noch kleiner werden.
Ja, Deduplication, das andere mit Compression Enabled, irgendwie.
Genau, wenn du ein File nochmal speicherst, und obwohl das File genau so schon da liegt, dann schreibt das ZFS diese Blöcke nicht, weil es erkennt, dass er einfach genau den gleichen Teil schreiben würde, normalerweise würde das Copy-and-Write woanders hinschreiben und so weiter, aber jetzt macht das einfach gar nicht, weil es liegt ja schon da. Dieses Feature geht nur, wenn man Compression anhat. Ich habe jetzt mal herausgefunden, woran das liegt. Leute, die Compression einschalten, gehen davon aus, dass Sachen, die sie schreiben, eventuell weniger Platz belegt, als bei einem normalen File-System. Bei diesen speziellen neuen Writings, der sich das spart, ist das auch so. Deswegen haben sie es als Grundlage genommen. Das ist keine technische Entscheidung, sondern eine user-experience-Einscheidung. Die wollten es einfach so. Ich sehe zwar jetzt auch nicht, warum man da, wie bei Compression, irgendwie Blöcke spart. Eigentlich ist das gar nicht der Fall. Das wird ja einfach nur nicht geschrieben, aber man spart ja nichts, weil es liegt ja schon da. Deswegen kann ich es noch nicht so ganz nachvollziehen, aber das ist erst mal so, wie in deren Diskussion, was der Grund war, warum man da für Compression braucht. Ich kann da ja noch mal nachhaken. Sollte ja nicht sagen, wir würden nicht auch irgendwie was nachhaken, ne?
Recherchieren.
Genau. Und ändern.
So, weil wir gerade bei Toys sind, erst mal jetzt Geschenke hier.
Es gibt Süßpies. Ich weiß nicht, warum mir das immer bei der Freak Show passiert, aber immer verlege ich die Zettel, wo drauf steht, wer uns das geschickt hat. Es ist wirklich zum Kotzen. Und ich muss mich entschuldigen, ich weiß schon wieder nicht, wo der Zettel ist. Das habe ich jetzt viermal, glaube ich, hintereinander gebracht, die Nummer. Das geht gar nicht mehr.
Danke an den anonymen Spender.
Ja, mach mal auf, hier gibt es eine Schokoladeneinsendung. Das Beste ist, dass es immer irgendwie, das ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was steht hier drauf? pui-ricard. Pui-ricard. Schokolatier-Konfiseur.
Habe ich hier auch, aber hier krümelt alles raus. Mein ganzer Rechner ist jetzt voller Schokoladenkrümel hier. Ernst nehmen.
Während ihr da rumknistert, plaque ich gerade noch mal ein schönes Toll, was ich mir noch mal zugelegt habe. Ich hatte euch doch diese tolle Peitsche mitgebracht.
Die hat nicht funktioniert, die Peitsche.
Nicht?
Ich habe die mitgenommen, die du hier hast liegen lassen, und sie hat einfach nicht Strom geliefert.
Scheiß China-Quack. Dazu habe ich jetzt neulich bei Konrad zwar so ein Walk-By-Ding. Entstanden eine kleine Batterie, so groß. Die Hörer sehen es jetzt leider nicht. Aber nur so ein Handvoll groß, 15 Euro. So diese übliche tragbare iPhone-Nachladeding oder so. Und das lädt halt eben mein iPhone noch zweimal. Und wie gesagt, für 15 Euro ist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig schwer oder wahnsinnig groß, dass man das mal mitnehmen könnte. Und dann hast du halt diese Peitsche da dran. Auf der einen Seite ist halt so ein USB-A-Stecker und auf der anderen so ein USB-Pfff-Mini oder so. Tralala. Auf der einen Seite lädste und auf der anderen Seite entlädste. Und das ist sozusagen gerade für die Reisenden, so für iPad und iPhone. Sollte gar nicht. Wie gesagt, für 15 Euro ist das durchaus passabel, das Ding, finde ich.
Schick mal hier Link in den Chat zu dem Produkt.
Muss ich selber mal klicken bei Konrad. Aber wird sich bestimmt finden.
Ach, das ist so ein Akku, der gleichzeitig versorgt und sich auflädt.
Das sollst du genau nicht gleichzeitig machen, aber du steckst ihn sozusagen mit der einen Seite des Krabels an ein Ladegerät oder an einen Rechner, um ihn zu laden. Und mit der anderen Seite des Krabels steckst du ihn an dein Telefon, um selbiges damit zu laden. Unterwegs dann. Wie gesagt, gibt es auch schon diese Dinger, die man sich in die iPhone-Hüllen mit Zeug darin trallert. Aber für 15 Euro fand ich das okay als Mitnahme-Teil. Das tut seinen Dienst.
Jetzt habe ich es irgendwie eingeschaltet.
Das geht von alleine wieder aus. Du hast jetzt nur diese Batterie-Anzeige da.
Vor zwei Wochen, als ich Pizza geholt habe, habe ich den Andreas Bog getroffen, der euer Bier hier macht. Der hat auch gerade Pizza geholt.
Voll Kraft.
Er hatte an seinem Telefon auch so einen Akku-Booster, aber er hatte nicht 3000 oder 5000 mAh, sondern jetzt haltet euch fest, er hatte 30.000 mAh.
Und einen Rucksack.
Nee, das war halt so eine kleine Platte, sah aus wie früher so eine Laptop-Batterie und war wahrscheinlich auch eine, aber 30.000 mAh, das ist mal eine amtliche Zahl. Jetzt hängst du an dein Telefon, an dein iPhone, dann hält das ein Monat.
Tims Gesicht gerade schon wieder rechnen, rechnen, rechnen.
Du wolltest einen Schokolader, Hucke? Kannst du mal die Tüte rüberrechnen?
Also 30 Ampere. 30 Ampere ist, na die Schucke, also das ist, also ja, das ist schon, also die ist gut.
Was ist denn das? Ich nehme mal hier so eine Platte.
Ah, ist schon ausverkauft wieder.
Was, die Schucke?
Nee, diese Ding hier. Ist jetzt erst wieder ab Ende April lieferbar. War auch, wie gesagt, ein Special-Preis für 15 Euro. Jetzt kostet 19,95. Kann den Link da trotzdem mal...
Ist das nicht so eine Conrad-Marke?
Das ist irgendein China-Quack.
Chinese Hamster drin, die die ganze Zeit drehen, merkt man auch.
Wie britt so ein bisschen?
Vier blaue LEDs.
Die müssen jetzt heutzutage mal blau sein.
Und die blinken sogar.
Er liegt aber auch aus.
Brauchen die irgendwie weniger Strom?
Waren früher sogar mal teurer.
2600 mA.
Es gibt witzigerweise einen Japaner, der arbeitet entweder bei Toshiba oder einem dieser Großkonzerne, der das Patent hat, oder das wichtige Patent für blaue Leuchtioden. Er verdient sich dumm und dämlich daran. Weil jetzt kreativ und kreativ überall immer blaue Leuchtioden einbauen. Kannste googeln. Sieht aus wie so ein typischer japanischer Forscher. Ganz bodenständig steht der da so rum. Der kriegt jedes Mal ein Mikrojent für jede blaue Leuchtige.
Wie dieses Muttersöhnchen von Flappy Bird.
Mit Kackmaschinen, jetzt ist halt meine Timeline zu.
Der Typ ist irgendwie geil. Zu viel Aufmerksamkeit und so.
Hat er kein Geld verdient?
Doch, ohne Ende.
Das ist die beste Presse, die er machen konnte. Der kommt nämlich nichts mit einem Flappy Bird 2 und der kostet richtig Geld. Doch, doch, warte mal ab.
Ich meine, warum sollte er das tun? Weil hätte er dann auch die erste Version einfach online lassen können.
Ich glaube, das ja noch.
Die war doch free und da gibt es doch keinen Bezahlfeature, oder?
Werbung. Und irgendjemand hat mal ausgerechnet, aber es gibt keine Bestätigung dafür, dass er angeblich mit dieser Software irgendwie 50.000 Dollar am Tag an Geld verdient hat?
Hätte.
Hat.
Die hatte kostenlos.
Werbung, Einblendung.
Die hat er gehabt?
Ja, nur. Aber dadurch, dass es halt Millionen Leute gespielt haben wie die Berserker, obwohl die Software eigentlich scheiße war, also vielleicht war sie auch nicht scheiße, ich habe sie nicht benutzt, aber sie ist schon gesperrt, die sich dann mal überlegt hat, ob ich sie mit unterlade. Und naja, dann war ihm aber der Rummel irgendwie zu viel und vor allem irgendwie so Leute, die ihm so geschrieben haben, ja, das ist ja total abhängig werden. Er meinte, die Software wäre halt addictive und er möchte halt nicht, dass die Leute abhängig werden von seiner Software und deswegen macht er das weg. Außerdem wohnt er noch bei seiner Mutter.
Der war erst 14.
Nee, das ist halt so ein...
Überall nochmal die Schoki-Dennis.
Der ist schon alle.
Mensch aus...
Fokussion.
Keine Ahnung. Also er will sich auch nicht fotografieren lassen und piepapo und scheut da die Öffentlichkeit enorm und hat halt irgendwie diese Software gesperrt, die halt sehr erfolgreich war. Für ihn. Ich meine, es gibt noch genug Installationen da draußen. Er wird wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Wochen und Monate vielleicht weiterhin da sein Revenue haben. Aber ich meine, da gehört schon einiges dazu zu sagen.
Mein Leben oder das Leben der anderen ist mir wichtiger. Respekt. Jetzt eine schöne Überleitung. Muss jetzt hier Thema für vier Wochen los werden, sorry. Sonst fällt Nick, äh, sonst fällt hier Hucke wieder mit dem Kopf auf die Tastatur und dann es wartet wieder. Hochachtung auch für die Leute, meinerseits, die sich nicht von einer Firma namens Zipgate haben verarschen lassen. Es begab sich nämlich zu der Zeit, da ätliche Kunden von Zipgate feststellten, dass im Zusammenhang mit den Änderungen, die einer ihrer ISPs herbeigeführt hat, plötzlich ihr Zipgate nicht mehr ging. Die Änderungen, die da konkret auf sie zukamen, was der ISP, nämlich so Kabel, gerade Kabelprovider in Deutschland, waren, dass sie gesagt haben, Kinders, das mit dem V4 ist kacke, hier habt ihr V6. Und im Übrigen machen wir Kerra ja grad natt. So, und das ist ja ohnehin schon ein bisschen heikle Sache so für Zip. Zip ist ja eh nicht so richtig das tolle Protokoll, was sich bei Natt freut und über Kerra ja grad natt, schon erst gar nicht. Und die haben sich dann natürlich an Zip-Geld gewendet und Zip-Geld erstmal so, ja, ja, das ist alles schlimm, schlimm, böse und gemein und redet mal mit eurem Provider, dass ihr wieder V4 macht und diese V6, das setzt sich eh nicht durch und so. Also so ein bisschen so der Tenor. Und das fand ich schon sehr gewagt. Und normal hat auch jemand dann geschrieben, der sich erstmal ganz ordentlich anhörte. Aber die Leute, die das gelesen haben, haben sich da überhaupt nicht darauf eingelassen, was ich eben sehr schön fand, sondern die haben so richtig Zipgate geschitztormt, haben gesagt, nein. Wo denn? Im Zipgate Forum. Ich kann mal den Link auch posten. Und gesagt, ja, aber eigentlich das Problem seid auch ihr, weil man hat euch jetzt irgendwie seit 15 Jahren gesagt, dass V6 kommt und warum könnt ihr das denn noch nicht? Und das fand ich wirklich sehr. Fand ich wirklich mal sehr schön, dass die Leute sich da haben nicht verarschen lassen von dusseligen Marketing-Argumenten und bla und sölz, und dann sagt die AppFail, ja, das ist einfach, hört doch einfach auf mit dem Quack. Und nein, wir rufen nicht bei Kabel Deutschland an, sondern bringt euren Shit in Ordnung. In dem Zusammenhang hat sich dann auch irgendwie vor ein paar Tagen jemand gemeldet bei mir, der hatte damit auch Sorgen. Und dem konnte ich aber in der Tat mit IPv6 weiterhelfen. Sehr zu seiner Freude. Der hat nämlich zum Glück mehrere Kisten am Start, und zwar mehrere Fritzboxen. Jetzt habe ich es schon wieder gesagt. Nämlich einer an seiner Arbeitsstelle und eine zu Hause, die er beide mit seinem Zipgate-Account betrieb. Deswegen war ihm auch klar, dass da irgendwie was bei ihm in dem Umfeld faul sein musste, weil seine Kiste in der Firma, die nämlich, glaube ich, an einem Telekom-Anschluss hängt oder so, noch schön mit Zipgate reden konnte und die zu Hause nicht mehr. Und er fragte also erst mal so, ist jetzt mal eine Fritzbox kaputt oder so? Und er hatte eine neue Software schon reingemacht. Ach ja, fiel ihm dann auf. Er ist ja von Kabel Deutschland umgestellt worden. Er hat nämlich seine Fritzbox hinter einem Kabelmodem. Das ist auch eine relativ heikle Installation immer. Und jammer, jammer, alles schlimm. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja, pass auf, wir machen mal folgendes. Fritzboxen sprechen ja schon länger vor sechs. Die sprechen auch im Zip vor sechs. Du verbindest jetzt mal einfach deine Zipbox bei dir zu Hause nicht direkt mit Zipgate, sondern verbindest sie mit deiner anderen Fritzbox über V6, die dann per V4 am Zipgate hängt. Weil das Schöne ist, du kannst Zip über IPv6 super machen, weil da ist kein Nut weit und breit. Diese ganze Kacke, die sie drum rumgebaut haben um das Zip-Protokoll, ja, mit äh, wiechen, äh, äh, extra Protokollen, um die eigenen Adresse rauszufinden und das Nutting zu evaluieren und bla, bla, bla. Das brauchst du halt nicht bei V6, weil bei V6 gibt's keinen Nut. Und gesagt, getan. Durch sein Kabelmodem durch, telefoniert die jetzt überall PB6, von einer Fritzbox zur anderen, die zu Zipgate und alles ist grün. Also kann man machen, ähm, äh, und wenn die Firma Zipgate da mal verstehen würde, dass sie jetzt im Jahr 2014 lebt, dann hätte sie wahrscheinlich sogar noch weniger Probleme als vorher, weil sie eben auch nicht mehr die ganzen Nut-Probleme hat. Aber momentan glauben sie noch nicht dran. Das hat mich so ein bisschen daran erinnert, eine schöne Anekdote, die ich hab im Frühjahr 2002, also so zwei, drei Monate nach der Einführung des Euros, mal auf meinem Land sitz, in dem nächstgelegenen Dorf, am Supermarkt zwei Frauen sich unterhalten hören, die eine zur anderen so, ja, jetzt hier Euro und wie finn sind dit? Und die andere so, ja, nee, sie macht ja nicht mit, weil das setzt sich nicht durch. Also war so ein bisschen auch so dieser State of Denial. V6? Nee, Euros. Und ungefähr so hört sich das an, was Zipgate da macht, ja, diese V6 ist eh bloß ein Schnupfen vergessen, das geht weg. Das ist jetzt gerade mal modern, aber das setzt sich nicht durch. Also so ein bisschen liest sich das da so. Also ist ja auch so.
Zipgate scheint aber schon so ein Laden zu sein, wo so der Disconnect zwischen Technikern unten und Management oben schon relativ groß ist, oder?
Ja, ich meine, man muss den Leuten noch zugute halten. Sie betreiben eigentlich schon, wenn man von solchen Leuten absieht, schon einen relativ stabilen Dienst unter relativ schlimmen Voraussetzungen. Sie werden schon relativ fies gegängelt von den großen Telecoms und so. Da werden immer wieder Steine in den Weg gelegt und die Telekom verweiger Zusammenschaltung und, und... Also dafür machen sie eigentlich schon einen relativ guten Job. Aber das jetzt zu verpennen, wo man ihnen jetzt sozusagen... Erstens haben sie seit 15 Jahren gesagt, ja. Und sie sind ja immer auch dabei. Sie sind ja bei den ganzen Netzwerkveranstaltungen dabei. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die sich nicht mal auf einem Raipe-Meeting rumtreiben würden. Und das, wo man ihnen jetzt sagt, so, hallo, V4 ist demnächst zu Ende, kümmert euch mal drum. Also, können nicht behaupten, dass sie das nicht gehört hätten. Oder so, ja. Und dann natürlich jetzt spätestens so seit ein, zwei Jahren, weil der Kabel Deutschland hat das ja auch nicht von heute auf morgen gemacht. Die haben es ja mit Ansagen gemacht. Mit anlaufenden Ansagen haben sie gesagt, so, dann machen wir das jetzt mal. Und alle haben immer gedacht, ja, das können die eh nicht machen, das schalten die nicht um. Und so. Und dann hat der Kabel Deutschland dann doch mal umgeschaltet.
Der schießt nicht. Der schießt nicht.
Runde die Bällen.
Ja, genau.
Vor allem, was ich besonders absurd daran finde, ist, da haben sie nun mal wirklich einen Migrationspfad, der so dermaßen in ihr Geschäftsmodell spielt. Nämlich weniger technische Probleme für den Betrieb unseres Kerndienstes. Und dann ignorieren sie das einfach. Da gehört schon echt eine Menge Dummheit dazu.
Und wie gesagt, nicht von heute auf morgen. Sie hatten lange genug Zeit. Aber das finde ich schön. Man kann das auch mitigieren. Man kann da so ein bisschen rumspielen. Deswegen kam ich überhaupt darauf. Was ich schön fand, ist, dass die Leute fast durchgängig in diesem Forum nicht von denen haben verarschen lassen, sondern immer gesagt haben, ja, schön, Kabel Deutschland ist böse, dass sie uns umgeschaltet haben, aber das Problem habt ihr, nicht Kabel Deutschland. Ja, das fand ich eigentlich schon mal sehr angenehm.
Gleich die erste Kommentare. Wäre die einfachste Lösung nicht ein Anbieten von V6-Diensten ihrerseits?
Man muss allerdings jetzt dazu sagen, dass auch die anderen Platzfirchen in Deutschland, wie z.B. Easybell oder Placitel, da nicht wesentlich weiter sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite haben die sich auch nicht zu solchen Statements verleiten lassen, dass das alles Quatsch ist mit dem V6. Man soll doch lieber seinen Provider überreden, V4 wieder anzubieten oder so.
Aber ist es nicht Quatsch mit dem V6?
Meinst du, das setzt sich nicht durch?
Ich meine das nicht, aber anscheinend ganz viele andere meinen das, weil irgendwie kommt das immer noch nicht so richtig.
Ach so, da kann ich den dann gleich...
Ich gebe Provider, die vergeben gar keine V4-Adressen mehr.
Weil sie keine haben. Ich kann mal was schöne pluggen, das könnte dich mal, wenn dich das interessiert. Und zwar habe ich für meinen Chrome ein kleines Säckchen von Plugins. Eins, was ich sehr schön finde und was ich sehr gerne benutze, was sehr interessant ist, also Extension heißt das ja, ist die, Moment, ich gucke gerade, IPvFoo heißt diese Ding. Also IPvFoo, der malt ja oben in dein Adress oder Searchbar, malt dir da oben in die rechte Ecke so Vieren oder Sechsen oder Vier und Sechs rein oder wie auch immer, wenn du eine Webseite ansurft, die dir anzeigt, ob du die jetzt per V4 oder V6 erreicht hast. Und was sehr spannend ist, so eine Webseite zieht ja in der Regel immer noch was anderes nach sich. Ich gehe jetzt hier zum Beispiel mal auf Metaebene.me. Das ist nämlich besonders peinlich. Da erscheint eine große rote Vier. Das sagt, dass diese selber auf Farbe Vier ist. Aber ihr malt hinten noch eine kleine grüne Sechs dran, was so viel heißt wie, die bindet Sachen ein. Die bindet nämlich zum Beispiel noch was von Facebook ein, was für V6 ist. Die bindet Sachen von Akamai ein, die von V6 sind. Sie bindet Sachen ein von ytimg, was auch immer, wahrscheinlich so ein Image-Surfding, diverse Sachen von Google und von Meta, Metaebene ME, was in der Tat inzwischen eine V6-Adresse ist. Das heißt, man sieht also auch genau, wenn du eine Webseite abrufst, was die alle sich von wo zieht, mit was für Adressen und so. Und übrigens auch gleich, ob die SSL gesichert sind oder nicht. Also das ist so ein ganz nettes Teil da oben. Ja, Herr Prittlauf hat's gefahren. Fahr mal mit der Maus auf die Vier oder klick mal da drauf. Aha, zack. Das heißt, du siehst gleich, was kommt von wo her und wie wird das gemacht und so. Und das finde ich mal sehr interessant. Und wenn du das nämlich mal machst, Dennis, dann kannst du nämlich sehen, dass eigentlich sehr, sehr viel Quatsch, was du draußen unsurfst, schon V6 kann.
Ich habe letztens mal wieder einen Squid installiert. Als ich halt hier meinen FreeBSD 10 neu gemacht habe, dachte ich, ich mache mal wieder einen Squid. Und dann habe ich auch mal so geklickt. Und es ist schon ein bisschen V6, also gerade Google und Flutter. Aber dass der Timme zum Beispiel nicht den Heise-Google-Facebook-Dingens da hat.
Heise-Google-Facebook-Dingens?
Na, die Beheise haben noch dieses Ding, dass nicht der Link automatisch zu Facebook geht, sondern man muss ihn erst einschalten, damit die mich nicht tracken können. Weil ich bin ja zum Beispiel gar nicht bei Facebook. Kennst du gar nicht?
Doch, kenne ich.
Wo man erst so einschalten muss, damit es geht.
Aber dann kriegt er seinen Revenue-Stream nicht von Facebook.
Kriegt er eh nicht, wenn ich da keinen Dings bin, oder?
Fiese Verleumdung hier, Streu.
Facebook? Ich bin gerade etwas überrascht.
Ja, wie gesagt, dann kann man gleich mal so sehen, was die eigene Webseite noch so alles mit ausliefert für Links.
Ja, ich habe Facebook alles ausgeschaltet, dachte ich.
Offenbar nicht?
Nee, offenbar nicht.
Wo ist es denn?
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wo ist hier noch ein Lada? Guck mal, gefällt mir.
Das ist nicht so, weil ich diese Xing... Die gefällt mir, die gefällt mir.
Das ist von Xing, mir wird es mir reingereicht.
Na toll.
Du übernimmst es einfach so.
Das sind halt diese Anmelde, bla bla bla, die könnte ich jetzt natürlich auch rausnehmen.
Wo wir gerade bei diesen Extensions sind. Ich habe noch zwei andere, die vielleicht für Security-interessierte Nerds gespannt sind.
Bevor der Shitstorm gleich wieder hinterher kommt, so zum Thema V6 und SSL und Metaebene. Also liebend gerne würde ich alles erst mal natürlich über V6 liefern. Da bin ich jetzt auch einen Schritt weiter gekommen. Also da, wo mein Blog läuft, da gab es lange Zeit keinen V6. Dann habe ich irgendwie meinen Provider getreten, die ihren Provider getreten haben. Und jetzt gibt es da V6. Hab die Adressen auch schon auf dem System. Jetzt muss ich bloß irgendwie alle meine Web-Server umstellen. Und das ist einfach nur so ein bisschen Fleißarbeit. Und man muss alles richtig machen, weil mehrere Domains auf allen Systemen, Virtual Hosting und so geht alles irgendwie, wenn man weiß, wie und die Ruhe hat. Und ich weiß halt nicht so hundertprozentig, wie und die Ruhe habe ich schon gar nicht.
Dann machen wir das mal zusammen.
Ja, kommt Zeit, kommt vor 6.
Ah ja, so jetzt kommst du hier mit solchen Durchhalteparolen, ja.
Ich habe das nie anders dargestellt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das nicht will. Oder so ganz im Gegenteil. Ich will das sehr.
Er bekennt sich zu seiner Schande.
Ich bekenne mich nicht nur zu meiner Schande, ich bekenne mich auch ganz klar zur Zukunft. Also Zukunft hat stattzufinden und zwar heute.
Vimeo, CDN, das nicht V6.
Zum Glück ist ja heute nicht mehr lange.
Und aber auch ich, I'm only human. Was wollte ich sagen? Ah ja, genau, SSL ist nochmal ein bisschen kniffliger, weil ich ja mich für so ein Multi-Domain-Konzept entschieden habe in irgendeiner geistigen Umnachtung, wenn ich jetzt alles unter Meta-Ebene hätte.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht für SSL ein Thema, sondern das ist für dein WordPress ein Thema.
Das ist vor allem für Zertifikate kriegen und managen und so weiter kein Problem. Wenn ich jetzt ein Zertifikat für alle meine Sites hätte, dann hätte ich halt eins und das wäre irgendwie etwas anderes als ich muss mir darüber Gedanken machen, wie ich jetzt mit zehn oder wieso bräuchte ich nicht.
Nein, brauchst du nicht, weil inzwischen jeder Drecksbrowser auf dieser Welt SNI kann.
Ja, da muss ich aber trotzdem mehrere Zertifikate in einem machen.
Nein, brauchst du nicht, weil dein Browser, dein Web-Server, kriegt jetzt mitgeteilt beim TLS-Aufbau, welcher Name erwartet wird. Das ist dieses S-N-I. S-N-I, Server Name Indication. Das heißt, bei dem HTTPS-Aufbau, bei dem TLS-Aufbau, sagt der Client, Hallo, ich möchte gerne mit dir HTTPS sprechen und ich erwarte jetzt von dir Metaebene.me. Das heißt, dein Apache kann rechtzeitig, bevor er darauf antwortet oder mit seinem TLS-Negotiation da weitermacht, sich rechtzeitig das richtige Zertifikat raussuchen und damit antworten. Das heißt, diese Problematik, die man früher hatte, dass man auf einer IP-Adresse, egal ob V4 oder V6, nur einen HTTPS dabei betreiben kann, die ist schon länger passé. Es sei denn, du hast noch Leute, die ein Internet-Explorer 4 haben oder so. Haben wir ja Leute im Chat, die ein Android 2-Device haben und mal kurz auf test.schrümpel.de klicken können. Da kann man nämlich mal oben nachgucken. Da wird dann geguckt, mit was für Krypto da verwendet wird. Da steht dann auch SNI gleich. Und da kann man dann nämlich sehen, was, ne, HTTPS bitte, Herr Prittlauf.
Also wirklich.
So, da SNI gleich test.schrümpel.de. Das ist sozusagen das, was dein Browser mir mitgeteilt hat, noch bevor wir den TLS-Layer hochgefahren haben. Das heißt, ich konnte rechtzeitig die richtige Zertifikate dafür raussuchen und dir dieses ausliefern.
Ja, die Konsequenzen gehen natürlich noch ein bisschen weiter, weil gerade bei so einer Podcast-Zeit sind natürlich Feats extrem wichtig und URLs extrem wichtig. Und wenn ich dann erst mal alles so im Dual-Modus habe, mit irgendwie HTTP und HTTPS, könnte gleichzeitig, das kann zu einer ganzen Menge Konfusionen mit Redirects und PipaPo führen, doch, kann es. Mit was ist jetzt eingetragen und auf einmal gibt es zwei Feats.
Ja, nochmal dein WordPress-Foo, das da vielleicht Schwachstellen hat, aber das glaube ich dir, da bist du der Experte, was das reine Web-Serving angeht. Es ist egal, ob Apache oder Endgings oder wie auch immer.
Das ist mir schon klar, das Web-Serving ist nicht das Problem, aber die Konsequenzen daraus, wenn du überhaupt erstmal über mehrere URLs sichtbar bist.
Ja, bist du jetzt auch schon?
Nein. Nicht. Metaebene ME gibt es nur über HTTP Metaebene ME. Wenn es das auch über HTTPS Metaebene ME gibt, dann sind das einfach technisch zwei unterschiedliche URLs. Die werden dann auseinandergehalten. Das ist für so ein iTunes-Podcast-Verzeichnis relevant. Das ist für jeden Podcatcher relevant. Und wenn ich da erstmal... Ja.
Mit einem doofen Apache-Redirect, der jeden HTTP-Request gleich auf HTTPS umwirbt und Ruhe ist im Bums.
Hätte ich auch gerne, würde ich auch gerne machen. Muss ich trotzdem die Redirects erstmal hinkriegen? Weil es wird auf HTTP noch monatelang zugegriffen werden. Das heißt, ich will zwar redirecten, aber ich muss quasi einen Schalter umlegen, der sagt so, ab jetzt ist alles entsprechend HTTPS. Das heißt, das muss auch funktionieren. Und zwar sofort, weil wenn es nicht funktioniert, haue ich mir unter Umständen meine kompletten Subscriptionen in den Arsch.
Deswegen stage-emitted vorher erstmal.
Ja, genau. Also das ist nicht unmöglich, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich das erstmal so testen kann und es läuft schon irgendwie.
Tim, ich weiß auch, dass das Arbeit ist. Und gerade mit WordPress und La und Sülz, ich wollte nur sagen, jetzt so...
Dich wollte ich ja nicht motivieren. Ich wollte nur für Verständnis sorgen, wenn sie jetzt gleich wieder alle anfangen zu schreien, was das doch für eine unglaubliche Blasphemie wäre, dass ja hier die Mitter eben nicht vorsetzt.
Ich wollte, wie gesagt, eigentlich dir auch nur die Excuses entziehen, dass du sagst, ja, ich habe ja so viele Domains und IP-Adressen und Blah und Sülz. Also wie gesagt, diese Geschichte ist schon eine Weile weg. Wie gesagt, da können wir wirklich mal gucken, ob wir noch irgendwie mal so ein Android 2 haben, der das mit dem SLI nicht kann.
Ja, aber es gibt halt alte Systeme, die dann gar nicht mehr zugreifen können.
Ja, ein Internet Explorer 4 und die Leute können mir dann auch gestohlen bleiben. Sollten die auch gestohlen bleiben. Ja, oder 6 oder irgendwie so was. Ich kann mal nachgucken bei Qualys, aber das sind schon uralte Internet Explorer. All mögliche andere Scheiß noch mal. Die Leute, die das hier im Chat lesen oder hören, können gerne mal auf httpstest.schrumpfepunkt.de mal klicken und dann sehen sie oben auch, was da so ausgehandelt wird, was ihr Browser so für Krypto machen will oder sowas. Ich hab das auch mal ein bisschen hinoptimiert, soweit es einen Apache zulässt. Es ist nämlich derzeit noch ein Apache 2.2. Der hinterlässt, der kann leider nur 1024 Bit Diffie-Hellman-Groups, aber ansonsten kann der eigentlich so kryptomäßig das, was gerade State of the Arts ist. Da könnt ihr auch mal gucken, ob er schön Forward Security und all so Zeug drin ausbordern kann. Aber nicht mehr Apache heutzutage wirklich nicht. Ich hab ein Problem, ich hab da noch Sachen drauf, die mit Mod Pearl laufen.
Clemens, Internet Explorer kann es ab Version 7, außer unter Windows XP, da geht es noch nicht mal mit.
Dann steht es jetzt nach April um, und wer nach April noch XP benutzt, ist selber schuld.
Da geht es noch nicht mal mit Internet Explorer ab.
Also die Hälfte des gesamten Internets also nicht.
Ja, also mit XP geht es nicht, Punkt.
Dann machst du das so, du hast ja unter V6 viele IP-Adressen.
Es ist mir ehrlich gesagt egal, ich werde auch gerne mal so eine Browser-Weiche mit XP-User-Go. Dann haben wir auch mal ein bisschen Arroganz.
Nach April, wir müssen mehr Arroganz wagen. Zum Thema Arroganz jetzt mal was lustiges.
Hast du kein richtiges IPv6 hier im WLAN?
Doch, haben wir.
Warum, wenn ich diesen Test aufrufe, kommt da nicht meine IPv6-Adresse?
Weil dein Happy Eyeball-Algorithmus, aber du kannst gerne test6.schrumpfepunkt.de eintippen. Dann hast du auf v6 gezwungen. Der kann dir doch erklären, warum das Happy Eyeballs hier daneben liegt. Weil wie vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt, als hier die Streams immer abrissen, Tim betreibt ja noch seine v6-Konjunktivität über einen Tunnel von 6. Das heißt, seine IPv6-Konjunktivität kommt über IPv4. Damit ist sie auf jeden Fall langsamer als das v4. Und das Happy Eyeballs präferiert dann gerne mal das v4 hier. Happy Eyeballs? Das kommt wahrscheinlich aus dem Marketing, weil die Leute sagen, die Leute wollen gerne glückliche Augen haben, wenn sie im Web rumsurfen. Und deswegen nehmen wir das, was am schnellsten die Augen glücklich macht. Ja, Windows, Windows XP und so. Schöne Anekdote, neulich gelesen. Mehrfach auch, also kann man natürlich sagen, das treibt sich wieder mal im Netz rum als Urban Legend oder so was. Aber Herr Bill Gates hat ja seinen Job wieder angetreten als Technical Advisor bei Microsoft. Und hat sich natürlich in seinem Büro einen neuen Rechner hinstellen lassen. Da hat sie gedacht, da richtigt man jetzt mal Windows 8.1 drauf ein. Was so aktuell ist. Hat irgendwie ein paar Stunden lang dran rumgefummelt und hat sich ein paar Kollegen dazu geholt, die ihm dabei helfen sollten. Hatte an seinem ersten Tag nicht hingekriegt, Windows 8.1 zu installieren und hat darauf erst mal einen Fass aufgenommen.
Ist das eigentlich confirmed?
Das kann man ja noch mal gucken, ob das confirmed ist. Aber ich finde es trotzdem eine nette Story. Ich kann es auch gut nachvollziehen. Ich mache gerade Consulting bei so einer Bude in Kreuzberg. Da haben jetzt Anfang Februar zwei neue Leute angefangen. Da durfte ich dem einen dabei zuschauen, wie er sich damit abgequält hat. Es war nicht schön. Ich habe letzte Woche nochmal, weil ich für die Consulting mache, in einer VM mal Windows 7 installiert. Ich muss echt sagen, ich verstehe nicht. Und Windows 7 ist noch besser als Windows 8.1. Ich verstehe echt nicht, wie diese Firma sich trauen kann, das für Geldleute anzubieten.
Ich verstehe sowieso nicht, wie sich dieses Zeug durchgesetzt haben kann.
Wir sind ja nun schon dafür verschrien, ehe wir hier wie die Fanboys sind. Jetzt werden wieder die ganzen Windows-Apologeten sagen, wieso ist doch alles ganz easy? Ich habe wirklich richtig geradeaus. Das ist eine virtuelle Maschine beim Hoster. Also die hat auch richtig fett Internet-Konnektivität. Ich habe da eben die virtuelle Windows-7-Installations-CD reingeschoben. Ich habe immer nur ja, ja, ja, nicht spezial Clemens-Schrümpel-Installationen und hier noch ein paar Sachen. Immer nur ja, ja, ja, mach mal, ja. Wieso Windows 7?
Das ist doch gar nicht aktuell.
Ich habe es ja nur für einen Kompatibilitätstest für ein Thema und das ist halt Windows 7. Und dann guckst du dir den Ding so zu. Ich habe der virtuellen Maschine 4 GB gegeben, was für Windows 7 eigentlich relativ viel ist. Und die hat stundenlang an ihren Updates geprebelt. Nochmal, diese virtuelle Maschine hängt mit Gig am Internet. Das liegt aber gar nicht daran, weil dann guckst du nämlich zu, es gibt den Windows-Update-Prozess, der sich von 4 GB ungefähr 5 schnappt. Der hat irgendwie einen Memory-Leak. Deswegen braucht der 5 Stunden oder so was, um diese Updates da reinzufressen und stürzt am Ende ab. Nochmal, ich habe nichts Spezielles gemacht. Ich habe nur gesagt, gut ist ja das Windows 7, da sind Updates, da habe ich gesagt, ja mach mal. Also nicht mal Spezialauswahl, ich habe einfach nur gesagt, ja im Microsoft, ich vertraue dir, mach mal das so, wie du das für richtig hältst. Ich dachte echt, mein Schwein pfeift. Und ja, es swoppt sich dann selber ein paar raus und platzt dann irgendwie. Dann die Übersetzung, du musst ja bei Windows immer noch auswählen, ob du jetzt eine deutsche Variante hast oder nicht. Da das Ding direkt am Internet hängt, was ich der Kiste auch gesagt habe. Bei Insta, da hab ich gesagt, du hängst an einem bösen, bösen Netz. Ich weiß nicht, wie Microsoft das nennt. Du kannst ja auswählen, ob du an deinem Heimnetz hängst oder in einem Work Group oder in einem nicht vertrauenswürdigen oder so. Jedenfalls hab ich das dann so eingestellt und dann musste ich aber trotzdem mal nachgucken, was da läuft und dann guckst du in diese Systemerwachung rein oder Systemeinstellung und wollte ich jetzt mal wissen, welche Prozesse horchen denn jetzt eigentlich auf dem Ding? Ja, so das, was man so in der Unix-Maschine so guckt, mit Netzstaat minus N und so, mal so zu sehen, was ist hier so Listening? Und dann findest du, ja, man kann die Überwachungsports kann man sich anzeigen lassen. Was sind Überwachungsports? Ja, da war ein Profi- Übersetzer dran. Das sind natürlich Listening-Ports. Und da der halt einfach mal nachgeschlagen hat in seinem Webseiter, unter Listening hat er Überwachungen gefunden, also sind das keine Listening-Ports, sondern Überwachungsports. Und dann natürlich so die Sachen, die ich schon längst vergessen hatte, Sachen, die ich bei Apple nie aufgetreten sind. Ich hab natürlich diese virtuelle Maschine, weil mir das jetzt alle zu langsam ging, hab ich einfach mal virtuellen 4 Prozessoren ausgestattet. Das ist natürlich Windows 7 geht hin, sagt ja, da sind 7 Prozessoren. Ich benutze aber nur 2. Ja, weißt du, nur so ein Scheiß. Das ist wirklich echt so und jetzt hab ich mal ordentlich abgerentet. Dankeschön, das braucht ich jetzt mal. Ich kann wirklich echt nicht verstehen, wie die Leute das für Geld an Leute fahren. Das muss denen doch peinlich sein. Wie können die Leute nachts ruhig schlafen in Redmond? Ich verstehe es.
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht, wenn du auch nicht mal Bill Gates inszudreht bekommst.
Also ich hab ja im Sommer so eine Segeltour da gemacht. Da war auch so ein relativ langjähriger Microsoft-Mitarbeiter. Der war auch sehr nett, der war damit auf dem Boot. Der hatte auch sein Surface-Tablet dabei und so ein Laptop, weil er musste auch noch ganz dringend von dem Boot in dem einen Marina noch irgendeinen Report fertig machen. Und er hat so erzählt, wie das so läuft bei Microsoft. Und so aus seinem Wieso sein Job so abläuft und warum er jetzt diesen Report abschicken muss und warum er jetzt noch ganz dringend telefonieren muss. Microsoft Deutschland? Also war Amerikaner, der da richtig im Hauptquartier. Wie kommt man von Headquarter und an hier zu Herzen? Und der ist da auch schon relativ weit oben in der Hierarchie und hat schon viel gesehen. Und der hat so erzählt und uns so erzählt und wir haben uns alle so angeguckt und so... Du arbeitest da freiwillig, oder? Ja, also, naja, alle Klischees im Prinzip, die man so hat, von diesem management-getriebenen Komplex, wo die eine Hand nicht weiß, was die andere managt und so weiter.
Dilbert Reality.
Genau. Also einfach dieser Management-Overkill und Overhead, wo irgendwie auch nichts mehr wirklich zustande kommt, weil die ganze Zeit eigentlich damit beschäftigt sind, sich selber zu managen. Also, er hatte halt so ein paar Storys erzählt und er hat die aber so erzählt, also er ihm ist das jetzt gar nicht unauf... also nicht so als... so scheiße auf Arbeit, sondern halt einfach so ganz normal erzählt, als wäre das jetzt eben so... es ist halt so, ne? Ist halt so. Und wir eben saßen daneben und da hat er uns so... So irgendwie 15 Jahre. Und er meinte, ja, ich bin da halt irgendwie drin in dem Flow, alles ist super und...
Ja, gibt's auch in Deutschland.
Der war auch ganz nett, als er war. Na, so dein Alter wahrscheinlich, würde ich sagen.
Sollen das heißen? 30, also okay.
Ja, okay, dann vielleicht Tims Alter. Nee, also so, er hatte schon auch so eher gräulichere Haare.
Das heißt, er denkt nur noch an seinen Monthly Income und alles andere aus dem Schnuckern.
Nee, der war total passionate und in seinem Job auch drin. Der hatte auch Spaß an diesem Management.
Es gibt so Leute, die finden es auch hier. Es gibt echt Leute, die fühlen sich total wohl. Die sind behütet von diesen Prozeduren. Die wissen, dass sie jede Woche einmal ihren Report abgeben müssen. Das ist auch gut so, weil sie kriegen ja auch von ihren Untergebenen jede Woche einen Report. Und das ist alles so schön eingeschwungen. Da muss man nicht dauernd immer kreativ sein oder so. Und man hat seine regelmäßigen Kantinen-Pausen.
Ich wollte ja auch das nur so als Anekdote anführen, weil die sich nicht schämen und so.
Du meinst, auf meine Farge gehen, wie die die Nacht schlafen?
Ja, die sind ganz entspannt. Die haben da ihre eigene kleine Bubble drum herum. Und da ist auch alles super.
Ja, liebe Zuhörer, auch nicht alles, was aus Cupertino kommt, ist golden. Ganz bestimmt nicht.
Wir renten doch aus.
Das war wirklich echt wieder mal so eine Erfahrung. Was man nicht alles macht für Kunden, habe ich sie auch gleich für bestraft. Jetzt wieder Schmerzensgeld mit auf die Rechnung geschrieben. Ja, aber es... Wenn ich jetzt noch kurz nochmal schnell noch weitere Browser-Plugins pluggen darf? Also nochmal kurz Richtung IPvifu. Ich habe noch einen weiteren drin. Ist allerdings auch wieder nur etwas für Fans und Freaks. Ein bisschen Kryptobereich. So langsam, sehr langsam, aber immerhin langsam kommt auch der DNS-Standard ein bisschen aus den Puschen. DNSSEC, also die Absicherung, die kryptographische Absicherung von Einträgen im DNS. Leider nur sehr langsam, aber sie bewegt sich langsam voran. Ich habe das auch schon seit etlicher Zeit auf meinen Servern drauf. Und wenn ich jetzt mal so sehe, wer so etwas noch alles betreibt, ob mal ein paar große Player da mit dabei sind, gibt es auch dafür wieder eine Browser-Extension, die so ähnlich funktioniert wie diese IPWFU. Ich gucke gerade nochmal, wie die heißt.
Wenn man mehr Code in seinen Extensions laufen hat als ein Browser selber.
Na ja, das ist bitter. Wenn mir jetzt der mal die Präferenz zeigen würde. Und zwar ist das der DNSSEC-Validator. Den kann man, wenn man mag, auch gerne ausprobieren mit testschrümpel.de.
Wir haben jetzt schon seit einer halben Stunde wieder ein stabiles Netz.
Ja, beschwer dich noch. Der zeigt dir an, ob die Domain, die du da gerade angesurft hast, ob das auch wirklich die Domain ist, die du glaubst, dass es ist. Nicht nur eine, die dir ein Zertifikat zeigt, was es ist. Weil das ist ja das größte Problem, was wir haben mit den Zertifikaten heute. Fefe nennt dich immer so schön, das Umfallen oder die Apokalypse der CAs oder wie auch immer. Dass mit den Betriebssystemen auf deinen Desktops und auf deinen Telefonen inzwischen Hunderte von CAs mit ausgeliefert werden. Also Leuten, denen erlaubt wird, Zertifikate auszustellen, die dein Telefon oder dein Rechner für glaubwürdig halten. Und wer sich mal diese Liste anguckt, kann sich wirklich nur an den Kopf hauen, wem da alles vertraut wird. Das ist ja auch keine wirklich politische Frage von Vertrauen, schon gar nicht in Zeiten von NSA und GCHQ. Jetzt habe ich schon wieder gesagt, Achtung, wir beobachten den Stream. Den Stream? Noch hältet. Und das heißt, man kann also jetzt den Zertifikaten nicht notwendigerweise trauen in dem Sinne, dass sie jetzt wirklich auch nur von dem einen Aussteller kommen. Also das konkrete Beispiel ist, nehmen wir an, jetzt Tim sichert seine Metaebene ME ab und holt sich jetzt ein Zertifikat von VeriSign, was dämlich wäre, aber das ist das nur als Beispiel. Das hindert dann irgendwie die nordkoreanische Certification Authority überhaupt nicht daran, nochmal ein Zertifikat auszustellen für ihren Geheimdienst, was auf Metaebene ME ausgestellt ist. Und wenn halt die nordkoreanische CA ihr Ruh-Zertifikat irgendwie in euer iPhone reingekriegt hat oder auf euren Desktop, egal ob Linux, Windows oder noch irgendwas, wobei Windows die Dinger sogar frech wieder nachinstalliert. Wir hatten das schonmal in einer Show neulich mal erzählt.
Kann man einfach irgendeine andere IP-Adresse unterschieben und schon...
Kannst du Spaß haben, ja. Eine IP-Adresse steht ja nicht im Zertifikat. Du musst dich schon in den Datenstrom einschmuggeln, aber...
Du kannst eine andere IP-Adresse zuspielen, die wird dann connected und da steht trotzdem drin, dass es Metaebene ME ist.
Genau, und dein Browser sagt alle toll. Dafür gibt es jetzt auch nochmal DNS-Extensions, nämlich sogenannte TLSA. Das heißt, der Typ, dem die Domain gehört, der vermutlich dann auch den Names aber betreibt, kann sagen, ja, liebe Welt da draußen, ich habe hier ein Zertifikat, aber nur dieses ist gültig. Also nur dieses mit folgendem Fingerabdruck ist gültig. Das heißt, wenn jemand anders da irgendwie oder einen anderen Key damit ankommt, mit einem anderen Public Key ankommt, der ja das wichtige Teil ist von dem Zertifikat, dann ist es schön, dass der vielleicht ein Zertifikat hat, für nun eine CA, die bei euch in dem Rechner als glaubwürdig markiert ist, aber das ist trotzdem gelogen. So, und jetzt kommt natürlich die Brücke zu dem Anfang, wie ich sagte, mit dem DNS-Sack. Ist jetzt schön, wenn man jetzt vertrauenswürdige Daten oder Schlüssel im DNS speichert. Jetzt muss man halt noch dafür sorgen, dass die Leute nicht am DNS rumfaken. Und dafür ist halt eben DNS-Sack da. Und für beides gibt es, wie gesagt, Validatoren, als Chrome-Extension, auch für Firefox übrigens. 10 Minuten. Das weiß ich selber nicht. Und zwar wie gesagt, die eine Extension ist dieser TLSA-Validator, der sagt, ob sozusagen das Zertifikat, was da ausgelegt wird, auch das ist, was der Web-Betreiber, der Web-Server-Betreiber, der echte Web-Server-Betreiber da wirklich haben will.
Wie viele Einträge gibt es denn? Also so gefühlt, wie viele Websites benutzen das tatsächlich schon, dass sie auf ihr Zertifikat hinweisen?
Also TLSA ist noch verhältnismäßig selten, aber das Interessante ist, dass in den Working Groups für sowas auch immer große Leute dabei sind, die ein Interesse daran haben, dass das gut funktioniert. Also die Paypals dieser Welt, die Ebays dieser Welt, die Amazons dieser Welt und die Googles dieser Welt. Die haben alle so Testbats und so. Die werde ich jetzt auch mal wieder Ende des Monats da in London zum ITF-Dingsten treffen, wieder treffen, die Kollegen, um mich da auch in die Working Groups mal reinsetzen. Und das Schöne ist, dass diese großen eben dann auch am ehesten bereit sind, mal zu sagen, ja, wir testen jetzt mal ein halbes Jahr und dann machen wir das einfach mal an. Ähnlich wie vor sechs, es gab ja da vor ein paar Jahren mal diesen IPv6-Day, wo sie dann eben Facebook und Google und PayPal und so alle hingegangen sind, das einfach mal angeknipsen haben. Seitdem ist es ja auch an und ähnliches erwarte ich auch dann. Und wenn die das erst mal machen, dann machen es die anderen auch. Es ist übrigens auch keine Rocket Science. Ja, du brauchst ein relativ simples Tool, was einfach mal sozusagen so ein Fingerprint macht über dein Zertifikat und schreibst dir dann dein DNS rein. Es macht aber, wie gesagt, nur dann Sinn, wenn du auch dein DNS selber gegen Rumsauen absicherst durch DNSSEC. Und dann kann man das alles mal so eine Kette herstellen, wo man sagt, okay, der Typ, der jetzt wirklich die Domain hat, bestimmt, welche Zertifikate gelten und welche nicht. Und das auch alles kryptographisch abgesehen.
Also, wer jetzt vielleicht komplett ausgestiegen ist, vielleicht kann ich das ja noch mal so ein bisschen zusammensetzen. Also, die grundsätzliche Idee von DNS ist halt, du hast halt hierarchische Namensabstufungen und darüber werden dann halt Records rausgegeben, die halt in der Regel Adressen sind. Also, Metaebene ME, da gibt es halt so die Delegation von von Route zu ME und von ME zu Metaebene und darunter ist dann halt abgelegt, so ja, hier es gibt halt dafür eine IP-Adresse, eine IPv4-Adresse und es gibt auch eine V6-Adresse und dann kann man die da halt erfragen. Aber wenn jetzt halt irgendein anderer mir irgendwie dazwischen geht und so was ist ja hier gerade beim Club passiert, ne, habt ihr da eigentlich irgendwelche Einblicke, was da passiert ist? Da war noch gerade irgendwie eine Eise-Meldung, eine CCC-Meldung.
Als ich aufgestanden bin, war es schon gefixt. Also es war um 11.30 Uhr schon gefixt.
Also der Public DNS-Server vom CCC ist...
Hatte ein Problem.
Hatte ein Problem, ist irgendwie attackiert worden.
Was war das? DJ Tralala? Genau, und da gibt es wohl irgendwie eine Vulnerability. Und die ist auch schon bekannt gewesen, aber der hat wohl nie Patches dafür rausgebracht und so weiter.
War das nicht der, der irgendwie 1000 Dollar Bounties für Bugs geboten hat?
Keine Ahnung. Der immer super sicher sein will, ja. Und alles besser weiß.
Kann schon sein, weiß nicht genau.
Und jetzt ist seine Software irgendwie buggy und jetzt hat sie aufgeregt.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie gemacht haben, um das zu fixen. Vielleicht haben sie einfach einen anderen genommen.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall ein Public-DNS-Server, den vielleicht manche auch verwendet haben, hat auf einmal ganz andere IP-Adressen rausgespült. Das ist genau dieses Problem, dass man halt als Client das überhaupt nicht überprüfen kann. Antwortet mir dieser DNS-Server, den ich da jetzt angesprochen habe, mit DNS-Server kriegt man halt zugeteilt, wie nix Gutes. Man wählt sich irgendwie zu Hause ein und dann kommt dann erst mal so ein frecher Alice-Internet-Zugang, der sagt, ja, hier DNS-Server, haben wir eigene, ganz toll, hier super. Und wenn man eine Adresse nicht da ist, dann blenden wir dann auch gerne noch Werbung ein oder sonst so ein Scheißdreck. Also einfach so Pan-Marketing-DNS-Server, die auch mal vielleicht scheiße konfiguriert sind oder vielleicht...
Nein, die helfen dir nur bei der Suche. Das ist kein Marketing. Das dient alles nur, um deinen Happy Eyeballs zu dienen.
Das sind alles Gauner und Verbrecher.
Dafür ist es da.
Und man kann sich ja sowieso auf nichts mehr verlassen im Internet. Das weiß ja mittlerweile jeder. Und deswegen gibt es halt diesen neuen Ansatz, der vielleicht auch noch seine Fehler hat, aber der zumindest schon mal ein paar ganz grundsätzliche Probleme des täglichen Betrugs ausschließen kann. Und das läuft im Wesentlichen so, dass diese selbe Hierarchie von Root zu deiner Domain im Prinzip kryptographisch abgesichert ist. Das heißt, diese Root, wie läuft das dann? Diese Root-Keys, wir wollen uns jetzt nicht alles erklären, aber ich wollte das mal so ein bisschen transparent machen.
Hier war ja auch gerade jemand im Chat danach gefragt. In der Tat wurde das natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein I-Can getrieben oder sowas. Und es gibt eine Key-Hierarchie, also das wird die, die, die, genauso wie das DNS ja selber auch eine hierarchische Geschichte ist, von den Roots eben runter durch First, also Top-Level-Domains, dann Second-Level-Domains und so weiter und so fort, den Delegationen. Passiert das auch mit den Keys, das heißt, die müssen sich gegenseitig vertrauen und Schlüssel unterschreiben. Und irgendwann gibt es natürlich einen Root-Key, dem alle mal vertrauen müssen. Und dieser Key wird in einer wahnsinnig, naja, was heißt wahnsinnig, aber in einer sehr aufwendigen Prozedur mit Live-Video-Übertragung und tralala von bestimmten Personen erzeugt, regelmäßig, ich glaube, einmal alle halbe Jahr oder so was, muss ich mal nachgucken, muss mal Root-Key Signing Ceremony heißt das. Ja, sie machen es deswegen in Affentanzweise, dass man dem vertrauen können muss. Deswegen kannst du dem live zugucken, wie die das machen, was die da machen. Dann kannst du sozusagen den Live-Zuschauen auf der Glotze, wie sie da einen Key generieren, unter Aufsicht von diversen Leuten. Hier war eine z.B. KSK Key Signing-Ceremonie vom 16. Juni 1910. Da kann man sich das mal angucken. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie jede damit machen.
1910.
2010. Ich bin heute echt gar gar nicht. Da muss er in diesem Bugbier liegen. Da kann man sich das anschauen. Aber vom Prinzip ist danach... Sagen wir mal so, die stellen halt die Integrität des DNS-Baums sicher. Die stellen nicht sicher, dass du du bist. Der Gemüse macht sich nicht, um von dir einen genetischen Fingerabdruck zu verlangen. Aber die sagen halt, dass die Leute, die über das DNS bestimmen, bestimmen dann sozusagen auch, was richtig und was falsch ist im Rest des Netzes. Und das macht in gewisser Art und Weise auch Sinn. Dass es dann natürlich immer noch Leute gibt, Behörden oder sonst immer, die dir per Beschlagnahme-Beschluss deine Domänen wegnehmen und dann damit irgendeinen Quack machen. Das ist ja unbenommen. Aber wenn du die Hoheit hast über deine DNS-Zone, dann kannst du halt eben auch deine eigenen Webseite darauf einrichten, denn obliegt es damit, zum Beispiel eben auch dir zu sagen, welche Zertifikate da gültig sein sollen. Und eben nicht die von Nordkorea oder sonst woher, sondern nur die von deiner CA, die du dort geheuert hast, für teures Geld dir ein Zertifikat auszustellen. Wie gesagt, wer damit mal spielen mag, ich hab das alles mal, da ich DNS-DAC schon länger betreibe und jetzt auch schon seit einiger Zeit diese TLSAs drin habe, wer das mal ausprobieren möchte oder diese ganzen Plug-In-Tools, oder es gibt auch so Webseiten, die so was testen, da könnt ihr wie gesagt gerne test.schrimpfe.de benutzen, die sollte V4, V6 und Crypto bis zu Arts kommt und so alles können. Den kann halt leider nur noch sehr kleine Diffy-Helmen-Groups, das liegt aber am Apachen, sobald ich den loswerde. Da waren wir vorhin gerade stehen. Genau, ich hab nämlich noch Modperl-Sachen drauf und deswegen kann ich von dem Apachen 2.2 da nicht weg. Gibt das eigentlich so ein Modperl für ein Endgings?
Keine Ahnung, das ist so ein Thema, das hab ich ja nicht weiter beigekriegt. Ja, Umi, weil ich das jetzt schon dreimal, glaube ich, bei Podcasts irgendwie durchgereicht habe, ins kurze Thema ein Kollege von mir, hat das Thema digitale Archivierung irgendwie sich jetzt so ein bisschen auf die Fahne geschrieben. Er will keine Fotos irgendwie mehr verlieren und durch Festplatten-Crashes und so weiter. Und hat jetzt irgendwie rausgefunden, es gibt MDisc, ne, DVD, die damit wirbt, 1000 Jahre zu halten. Man braucht einen speziellen Brenner dafür, aber die sind auch jetzt von LG und allen möglichen Firmen, gibt es die auch, die die brennen können. Und lesen kann das aber normale DVD-Laufwerke, beziehungsweise es gibt jetzt wohl auch eine Blu-ray-Variante davon. Und ja, wie gesagt, komplett mit inorganischen Komponenten, da kann irgendwie nichts verfallen und soll eben.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich so ein bisschen Blödsinn, weil diese Geräte werden auch dann irgendwann eh nicht mehr unterstützt oder sind zu klein oder, oder, oder. Man muss doch seine digitalen Daten eben mal von einem Medium zum nächsten retten.
Naja, aber zumindest, wenn du so lange, kannst du dir die DVD so lange in den Schrank legen, bis du sozusagen an der Grenze zur neuen bist und so weiter.
Das hast du teilweise gemacht, wie von früher, hebst du deine Disketten auf, dann sind die irgendwie in deiner Box, hast alles schick aufgehoben und die gehen da auch noch. Also ich hab letztens erst eine 30 Jahre alte Diskette eingelesen. Aber dann hast du gar keine Geräte mehr, die das halt noch lesen können. Ja, das denkst du mal so einfach, aber ich meine, nur weil du jetzt hier doch übermorgen deinen letzten Rechner mit DVD-Laufwerk bekommst, warst du aber auch der Letzte.
Ein externes DVD-Laufwerk kriegst du schon noch eine Weile.
Ja, aber guck mal in 10 Jahren nochmal.
Ja, aber dann geht in 10 Jahren oder in 5 Jahren hast du halt noch deine DVDs und die sind ja noch nicht weggegammelt.
Nee, das kann schon sein, aber ich würde meine Daten immer schnell wieder rauf auf den Computer und wieder aufs nächste Medium und immer so immer aufs nächste Medium.
Ich sag jetzt auch nicht, du sollst jetzt alles auf M-Des sprechen. Ich wollte das nur mal erwähnen, weil ich das ganz interessant fand, weil dieser Rot von CDs und DVDs ja durchaus mir auch schon ein paar Mal passiert ist. Und man sich ja da nicht so wirklich toll lange drauf verlassen kann. Und vielleicht es ja auch Leute gibt, die sich denken, ja okay.
Aber warum soll ich einem Typen vertrauen, der lange tot ist, bevor sein Versprechen irgendwie tatsächlich wahrweisen muss?
Ich würde Hucke insofern zustimmen, dass DVD noch so ein bisschen Zukunft hat, weil ich habe es gerade neulich, ich habe jetzt leider gerade keinen Link zur Hand, aber ich glaube bei Facebook. Ich meine, die wissen schon, wie man das mit den Daten so macht. Die testen jetzt auch gerade und sind so der Meinung, dass sie da vielleicht darauf umwechseln, dass sie quasi Daten, die sie zwar archivieren müssen, aus legalen Gründen, die sie aber jetzt nicht online brauchen, dass sie die einfach auf DVDs schreiben. Weil sie dann quasi für den Zugriff da drauf eigentlich nur noch ein Laufwerk brauchen und halt eine robotische Zuführung des Mediums, aber eben nicht so Festplatten-Scheiße, wo Medium und Laufwerk immer eins sind.
Aber eine Festplatte mit vier Terabytes, wieviel DVDs brauchst du dafür?
Entschuldigung, Blu-ray war das, nicht DVD.
Wieviel Blu-rays brauchen wir dafür? Vier Terabytes und 30 Gig Blu-ray sind wieviel? 4.000 geteilt durch 30.
Aber du hast halt die Trennung zwischen Medium und Laufwerk. Du kannst halt ein Laufwerk austauschen und aktuell und gut lesbar halten und an den Medien ändert sich halt nichts. Und die rotten halt auch nicht so schnell weg. Also das ist schon nachvollziehbar.
Ich will mir auch keine MS kaufen.
Die Medien halte ich auch nicht für das Problem, sondern die quert man drum herum. Es kommt auch jetzt demnächst gerade wieder so eine kleine Weltraumsonde vorbei, die die Menschheit irgendwie mal in den 80s oder 70s um die Ecke geschickt hat. Die rennt sozusagen auf der Erde ein bisschen hinter, auf der Erdbahn um die Sonne rum, ein bisschen langsamer hinterher. Das heißt, die ist jetzt ein paar Jahrzehnte mal so weg und kommt jetzt wieder auf die Erde zu. Und jetzt haben sie sich gedacht, oh ist ja geil, das Ding funktioniert sogar noch, aber wir können leider mit dem Teil nicht mehr reden, weil die NASA oder die ESA alles weggeschmissen hat, was sie brauchten an Equipment, um mit dem Teil noch reden zu können.
Hier hat jemand den Golem-Artikel rausgeworfen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den gelesen hatte. Aber das ist die Story hier. Ein Petabyte in einem Blu-Ray in einem Rack. Na ja, könnte sagen wir mal dazu führen, dass vielleicht DVD-Laufwerke oder Blu-Ray-Laufwerke sogar noch ein bisschen länger hergestellt werden. Who knows?
So, ich will jetzt mal auf das Feedback für die letzte Sendung eingehen, was da steht bei dir. Mach ich jetzt einfach mal. Mit dem Darknetz, und zwar Hyperborea hat man uns unterhalten. Das haben wir vergessen, wir sind gerade mal bei der Hälfte. Jedenfalls, der Clemens hat schon irgendwie von Remote gesagt, weil er war letztes Mal ja nicht hier vor Ort, dass er auch gerne Hyperborea rumspielt. Ich auch. Hab auch ein bisschen rumgespielt, hab auch da in dem Chat die Leute schon irgendwie ein bisschen gedrängelt. Aber irgendwie wollte mir keiner einen Pier nennen. Ich hab das dann Twitter gefragt, die haben alle gesagt, sie könnten mir was anbieten, aber keiner hat direkt einen gesendet, was vielleicht auch ganz gut ist. Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht auf meine Mail irgendwie tausend Leute, die mir da ein Zeug schicken. Deswegen wäre meine Idee, dass alle, die sich damit beschäftigen oder schon einen Pier haben, dass die halt immer die nächsten Tage immer mal wieder hier in unseren Freak Show Irk-Channel gucken. Die Leute, weil sind jetzt nicht alle Leute im Irk-Channel, aber die Leute, die Hyperborea am Start haben, ich denke immer, die sollten das hinkriegen. Und dass sie da immer mal wieder schauen und dass wir das dann über Direct Messages da im Irk irgendwie vielleicht klarmachen oder uns da so eine kleine Hyperborea-Community irgendwie im Irk zusammenbasteln. Weil man soll ja eben nicht, dass jetzt einer halt der zentrale Server und sich alle mit dem connecten, sondern soll es ja so Spaghetti-Code, jeder mit jedem irgendwie so kreuz und quer connectet sein, damit das halt keine zentralen Punkte gibt. Und dann würde ich das schon gerne nochmal aufprobieren.
Also du willst sozusagen dein eigenes Netz jetzt aufziehen, weil wir keine Piers kennen?
Nee, das kann man auch machen. Wir machen kurz unsere eigene Wolke. Und wenn ein einziger davon eine Connection zu der äußeren Wolke hat, dann schon schwupp, dann geht's ja schon. Und irgendeiner wird's ja wohl haben. Und wenn nicht, ist es auch egal. Aber ich denke schon. Na mich schon. Ich hab per Twitter mal gefragt, aber ich hatte dann keinen Bock dann per Twitter und Direct-Messages und Zeug oder dass die das direkt senden. Das war mir alles irgendwie zu blöd. Ich hab das einfach wegignoriert. Aber die hören jetzt diese Runde wahrscheinlich auch zu. Und wie gesagt, ich würde sagen, wenn Sie beim Match-and-Live-Höre haben, dann sollen Sie es mir im Irk jetzt hier direkt irgendwie pasten oder sowas, dann speichere ich mir es jetzt. Ansonsten, vielleicht bin ich nachher einfach noch nach der Sendung, wenn ich zu Hause bin, noch mal irgendwie ein paar Stündchen im Irk rumhängen. Oder über die nächsten Tage, dass man immer mal wieder guckt, irgendwie wird man es wohl schon hinkriegen. Aber eigentlich sollte halt nicht einer so seine Adresse pasten, weil es sollte halt möglichst, ja, unübersichtlich durchconnected sein. Also nicht nur einmal posten, sondern immer nur eingeben und dem nächsten wieder eine andere oder irgendwie so, keine Ahnung. Also dass es kreuz und quer geht.
Ja, fette Scheiße hier und so.
Ja, da, wie gesagt, sowas könnte durchaus spannend werden. Ich finde das Konzept ganz spannend, dass man eben den schönen IPv6-Adressraum ausnutzt, um eben den Publick hier gleich mit reinzuschmieren oder so. Das Schöne ist, dass man das eben auch in irgendwelche Gateways einfach reinbasieren kann. Das ist auch so ein Punkt, da bin ich mal so ein bisschen am Basteln, ob ich das vielleicht mit den Pies mache oder dann gleich auf dem Edge-Router oder sowas eben so ein hyperboreal Gateway vom Prinzip gleich in den Router mit einzubauen, dass du damit eben dein ganzes Netz damit versorgen kannst.
Wie würde sich das dann so konkret...
Ja, das ist ein bisschen fishy auch, weil dann hast du es ja wieder nicht End-to-Ende und lalalalala, aber wirklich bastel mal da so ein bisschen mit drin rum gerade. Ich finde es irgendwie die Idee ganz nett, eben mal den großen Adressraum auszunutzen, den der IPv6 bietet, um halt mal mehr Informationen zu übermitteln als nur jetzt eine Zieladresse.
Und dann soll ein Key in der V6-Adresse drinstehen, oder?
Ja, deine V6-Adresse ist dein Key.
Deine V6-Adresse ist dein Key, dein Public Key.
Wir erzeugen solange ein Key bis vorne mit FC anfängt, und FC ist ja bei IPv6 die Link-Local-Adresse. Nein.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall so was, ein Adressraum, den du benutzen kannst. Das ist eigentlich ein Bereich der sogenannten ULA's, der Unique Local Addresses, also keine Link-Local-Adresse. Weil die würde ja nur auf deinem Link gelten, also nur auf deinem Ethernet. Das sind die mit FE 80. Und FC und FD vorne sind für sogenannte Unique Local Addresses, wenn du so willst, Adressen, die dir dir selber ausdenken oder errechnen darfst. Deswegen sind sie da eigentlich schon ganz okay. Du bist dann natürlich innerhalb dieses Zoos gefangen. Aber darum geht es ja. Du sollst ja nur innerhalb dieses Vaboria-Netzes bleiben.
Also so eine Art 1918 für IPv6?
Richtig, ja.
1918?
Also diese private Adresse ist diese 192.168 und so. Und 10.8 und so, diese ganzen privaten Adressen.
Das FC war halt 192.168.
Und jetzt, wo du es sagst, fand ich es auch viel lustig.
Damals, damals auf den Ardennen. 1918.
HTML5-Audio. Ja, hab ich mir angeguckt. Ich bin ja immer noch am Überlegen. Also ich krieg ja einfach konstant Hass auf Soundcloud, wenn ich das benutze. Vor allen Dingen im Safari. Ich glaub, das muss ich jetzt auch ganz sein lassen, weil Safari ist da schon mal gar nicht mehr so im Soundcloud. Aber ich bin ja immer noch am Überlegen. Vor allen Dingen im Safari. Ich glaub, das muss ich jetzt auch ganz sein lassen, weil Safari ist da schon mal gar nicht mehr supported, scheinbar, dass es einfach nur langsam und stinkt. Und in Chrome geht es so einigermaßen. Wenn ich jetzt so die Features, die ich jetzt wirklich da benutze, wenn ich die jetzt selber bauen würde, womit fängt es jetzt an? Und als erstes dachte ich mir, okay, dieser Player, der kotzt mich schon an mit dieser bescheuerten Kommentarfunktion und dass das sich alles so hackelig verhält. Wie schwer ist es denn jetzt eigentlich, so einen HTML5-Audioplayer zu basteln? Dann hab ich erstmal einen von Hand gestrickt und hab mich auch gefreut, dass der so in Chrome und Safari einfach so ging. Weil der Firefox irgendwie ganz andere Property-Names hat für alles Mögliche. Kann ich übrigens auf... Nee, kann man nicht. Nee, nee, die Adresse gibt es noch nicht. Ich kann die mal ins Workflowey pasten, dann kannst du es dir mal angucken. Weil es hat auch so, ich hab mir das Waveform statisch gerendert und hab dann so Click to Seek und so alles mal gebaut. Warte mal hier, da ist die URL und die past ich mal ins Workflowey. Wo ist es denn hier? Das HTML5, Enter, Tab, da. Also habe ich festgestellt, alles klar, es ist zwar 21. Jahrhundert, aber Facebook hat es wieder alles anders gemacht und wahrscheinlich ist im Chrome dann nochmal alles anders. Ja, dann habe ich nach HTML5-Audio-Libraries geguckt und habe natürlich erst mal geschaut, was Potluff benutzt. Dieses Mediaelement JS. Aber das kommt ja gleich mit so Player und mit Video und ganz viel Phonebar daher und das brauchte ich ja alles nicht. Und dann habe ich natürlich gegoogelt HTML5-Audio-Libraries und habe jetzt eine gefunden, die heißt Buzz, glaube ich. Kann ich mal hier in den Chat pass-tieren. Und im Prinzip, was sie tut, ist eigentlich so ein ganz dünn Rapper, um die HTML5-Audio-API da zu legen. Und das eben browseragnostisch. Und dann gibt es ja, das gibt ja die HTML5-Audio, das Tag. Und dann gibt es ja diese Web-Audio-API, wo du so Filter und Routing und Kanäle und so diesen ganzen Scheiß machen kannst. Das wird zwar jetzt noch nicht von allen supported, ich glaube nur Chrome so richtig. Aber das wird ja richtig fett. Naja, auf jeden Fall, das Buzz, das funktioniert ganz gut und kriegt auch am Firefox hin. Allerdings, am Firefox ist halt das immer noch ein bisschen kaputt, weil der kann von diesem MP3, was ich da verwende, bei dieser kleinen Demo, das kann dann irgendwie die Duration nicht ordentlich ausrechnen. Und dann siegt man da umher und siegt daneben und dann ändert sich die Duration beim Abspielen im Firefox. Ja, das zeigt dir natürlich auch gleich. Fahren wir mal über das Auto noch, über das links oben, glaube ich. Das zeigt dir gleich, was da so geht. Was man so kann. Und bei Demo kannst du hier auch ganz liebevoll gemacht. Kannst du dir die Steinchen da jetzt drauflegen, so ein Puzzlespiel? Nein? Das wird jetzt nicht den Buchstaben sein? Also, es gibt auch noch advancedere, es gibt für verschiedene Anwendungsfelder, verschiedene Audio-Libraries. Zum Beispiel, wenn man Spiele macht, dann gibt es auch welche, die so auf Sprites, die die Sounds richtig metten können. Aber ich fand jetzt Bass erstmal so für diesen Minimal-Ansatz, wenn man sich den Player und die ganze Kontrolle von dem Abspielen des Audio-Files in das Einbinden von verschiedenen Mediatypes und so, wenn man sich das so ein bisschen einfacher machen will, dann ist Bass erstmal funktional gut. Und jetzt habe ich auf jeden Fall das Problem schon mal so in etwa verstanden und es ist alles gar nicht so schlimm, wie ich dachte. Und jetzt kann ich mich ein bisschen weiter drum kümmern. Ein Elefant halt. Ja, ist zu laut. Machen wir wieder aus. Ja, also ich habe ja lange kein Web jetzt gemacht und war eigentlich ganz positiv angetan, dass du es jetzt so mittlerweile eigentlich...
Ja, du kannst jederzeit bei PodLav anfangen. Also da gibt es gerade sehr viel Bedarf in dieser Hinsicht.
Ja, da müsste man glaube ich auch noch was machen.
Erik walt ja wohl auch im Außenlande.
Der den PodLav-Publisher vor allem voran treibt.
Ja, was ich ja gerne haben will, ist zum Beispiel, ich lade ja immer so von unseren drei Stunden schon Proberaumaufnahmen einfach so einen Fall hoch, weil mir das dann zu schneiden und so ist danach irgendwie zu viel. Und die anderen markieren dann im Soundcloud immer, wo geile Stellen sind und so. Und wenn die dann jetzt einfach gleich so Regions marken können und dann werden da einzelne Tracks gleich so raus und dann klickt man da so die Tracks und... Also dieses Chapter-Marker editieren gleich da im Fall auf dem Ding. Das finde ich auch sehr gut.
Es ist einfach so schade, wie wenig getan wird. So viel könnte gemacht werden. Die Früchte hängen so tief.
Man muss sie schon bücken. Man muss sie eigentlich schon nur noch aufheben. Ja, vielleicht. Ich will dir jetzt nichts versprechen. Ich habe ja auch viel zu tun. Auf jeden Fall ist es eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig, da so ein bisschen drum zu spielen. Also das Mediaelement JS macht bestimmt noch ein paar fancy Sachen extra. Der Gerrit hat wahrscheinlich dann so geschraubt, dass man dann diese Chapter-Markers irgendwie schön auslesen kann und damit integriert werden. Das kann ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht von sich aus der Mediaelement JS.
Nein, damit fing es ja irgendwie an. Wir haben uns einfach dieses Mediaelement JS genommen und ihm erstmal so ein Chapter-Interface aufgedrückt. Daraus hat sich dann quasi diese Version 2.0 herausgebildet, die derzeit so im Einsatz ist, die so ein bisschen mehr fancy-schmancy macht, aber darunter immer noch denselben Player hat, was sich auch immer noch widerspiegelt, dass der Videomodus anders ist als der Audio-Modus. Da ist halt derzeit einfach keine Konsistenz drin. Und es gibt allerdings schon sehr geschmackvolle, stilsichere Design-Marschruten, die allerdings noch einen Mangel an Code-Unterfütterungen haben. Aber konzeptionell ist eigentlich der Weg zu drei schon klar. Wir haben halt immer alle Angst vor dem Web.
Na ja, ich dachte so, ey komm, das ist ein HTML5-Audio-Tech, da sitzt ein MP3 drin. Kann doch so schwer nicht sein. Und ich will Play sagen, dann kommt dieser Firefox-Day und dann sind die Properties alle anders benannt.
Ich verstehe das auch überhaupt nicht. Ich meine drei oder vier Browser weltweit, die sich irgendwie da echt alles teilen. Das kann doch so schwer nicht sein, sich auf so ein paar Strings zu einigen.
Naja, aber auch sogar die normalen Click-Events. Ja, dann klickst du irgendwo hin, kriegst den Event und dann heißt der innerhalb des Elements, den Offset sozusagen, wo du innerhalb des Elements bist, x, y. Das heißt in WebKit, also Rom und Safari heißt das Offset x, in Firefox heißt das Layer x. Wieso denn? Ist das nicht irgendwie ein Dom-Event?
Hätte man nicht jemand fragen können. Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Wollen wir... Vielleicht, also ein Thema würde ich gerade noch so aushalten, aber ihr wisst ja, wie es ist. Ich muss morgen früh raus. Der Dennis muss nach Hause fahren werden.
Ich bin durch. Ja, ich denke, wir sind jetzt auch schon am Rande unserer Belastbarkeit angekommen. Wenn du dich ausspielen willst, dann musst du halt nächstes Mal wiederkommen.
Ich war eh vor dir hier, kann ja auch nach dir gehen. Du lässt das halt einfach laufen.
Morgen früh.
Die Clemens-Eyeball-Party.
Hast du das Eibildner eigentlich? Hast du zwischendurch mal neu gestaltet?
Don't ask.
Ach, er hat dann einfach so getan, als hätte er uns das Telefon wieder gekillt und hat dann die gleich genommen.
Nächstes Mal, wenn ich... Heute war es ein bisschen knapp hier mit der Vorbereitung, aber nächstes Mal mache ich mal Dual-Recording und so.
Dual-Recording.
Ja, weil ich kann ja hier, das ist ja der Luxus eines Audio-Netzwerks, ich kann ja auf zwei Rechnern gleichzeitig rekorden, Multitrick. Was klingelt denn hier immer so?
Das ist wahrscheinlich dieser komische Client hier, diese Chat-Client. Ich werde hier ange...
Ja, du machst mich ernst, das ist halt dieser Standard Apple-Notification-Sounds. Du weißt, wie die Leute...
Das ist ein Irk-Client. Glaubst du, da konfiguriere ich irgendwas dran?
Du hast auch die ganze Zeit dieses Wupp, neue Nachricht-Message-Sounds-Teil.
Besser als die ganze Zeit den Tisch febrieren zu lassen.
Hörer werden wahnsinnig, wenn sie einen Podcast werden. Und die ganze Zeit solche...
Das Einzige, was ich habe, ist diese Ping hier von meinem... Von diesem Text schuld.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall werden die Hörer diese Folge rechtzeitig hören. Ihr könnt uns dann Freitag so gegen 13 Uhr am Grabe in der Kultur Brauerei...
Der Hucke traut sich da nicht alleine hin. Ach, geht schon.
Ich hole meinen Rechner schon alleine. Aber wenn es ein kleiner Laden ist, sitzen da wahrscheinlich nur drei Leute drin.
Dann kennen Sie doch eh schon alle. Ich dachte, deine ehemalige...
Ja, die ist ja dann zwei Tage.
Nun denn...
Wollt ihr noch eine kleine Anekdote aus der Admins vom Hell?
Ja, während hier die Abschlussmelodie schon spielt vielleicht.
Betreue gelegentlich mal so User. Das kommt vor. Das habe ich mir mal so eingetreten. Dann wird man dann auch nicht wieder los. Bereut auch sehr. Und das Schlimme ist, wenn die denn noch irgendwelche anderen Leute haben, so Firmenadmins, die ihnen dann so irgendwelche Sachen zuraunen. Jedenfalls hat da einer von meinen Patienten eine Anweisung gekriegt von seinem Admin. Er möchte doch bitte mal den Mails, sie würden jetzt den Mails aber irgendwie umstellen auf einen anderen Provider. Und er möchte doch mal bitte jetzt das umstellen. Er hat dann so eine schöne Liste geschickt, natürlich als Word-Dokument mit Anleitung für Outlook, ist klar, weil es gibt ja nichts anderes auf dieser Welt. Und der arme Apple-User ist dann hingegangen, hat sich gedacht, na, ich will den Clemens nicht mehr belästigen, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal. Ist dann hingegangen in seinen Apple-Mail, hat dann auch die Einstellung gefunden und hat dann einfach bei der alten Account beschrieben, wo ich jetzt sage, weil es waren so 9000 Mails drin, ist er dann hingegangen, hat einfach einen anderen Mailserver eingetragen, weil er dachte, war schlau. Hat Apple-Mail auch gesagt, hat zu dem neuen Mailserver connectet. Ich sagte so, hallo, ich möchte mich mal mit dir sinken. Und der, ja, super, willkommen, deine Inbox ist leer. Daraufhin hat der Apple-Mail-Klient gesagt, okay. Weg waren die 9000 Mails. Ja, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich als Admin da wäre, hätte ich natürlich erst die Mails von dem User von Server A auf Server B rüber kopiert. Oder ich hätte dem User gesagt, ne, richte mal einen neuen Account ein. Aber er hat halt brav umgehackt, den alten Account. Und Apple Mail geht dann glanlos hin und sagt, so, SYNC, wie sieht es aus in der Inbox? Server sagt, Inbox leer. Sagt Apple Mail beim SYNCen, ja, dann ist die Welt halt leer. Ich erwähne das deswegen, weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auch gelegentlich mit anderen Leuten passiert.
Aber die haben ja alle einen Arc-Backup. Die haben alle FreeBSD.
Oder Zeitmaschinen oder so.
Postfix oder Exim oder ein Daft-Cut oder was auch immer.
Die wechseln deswegen ihre Mails aber nicht.
Die bleiben für die Ewigkeit. Abtime von 10 Jahren, mindestens.
In diesem Sinne, denke ich, können wir uns dann jetzt auch mal hier verabschieden.
Aber wir bleiben stark wie Rj45-Stecker.
Und wir kommen wieder.
Wie Rj45-Stecker.
Ich bin nächstes Mal in London. Vielleicht komme ich ja live aus London dazu.